Es kommt ja APFS für 10.3.
Kommt nicht nur, es ist schon da in den Betas, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab.
Und in dem Fall ist es dann auch wirklich wichtig, dass man vor dem Update noch mal wegkommt. Zumindest bis klar ist, ob jemand alle seine Daten verloren hat.
Ich hab so einen Tipp, wie das funktioniert.
Na dann, gib mal deinen Tipp ab.
Das ist schon ein bold move und ich würde trotzdem so einen warten. Also ich mach das nicht sofort. Der war ich eigentlich immer schnell dabei. Ich meine, das gab schon dicke Fails. Auch letztens erst wieder, wo die Updates zurückziehen und wo Fehler passieren. Wo Leute nicht sich installieren, merken, dass es schief gegangen ist. Auch bei Mac OS, das war alles ohne, dass die Fallsysteme on the fly ändern. Also Fehler passieren einfach.
Du kannst nicht absprechen, dass es ein risky move ist. Aber wir werden es gut testen, davon wie ich auch mal ausfahre.
Wie fand ihr, was werden wir davon haben? Einmal durchgeräuspert. Ja, hier ist die Freak Show. Guten Tag, die 193. Ausgabe. Heute in Gold. Bei mir einfach so mit Goldkante, genau. Freak Show mit Goldkante. Das kennt bestimmt auch keiner mehr, oder?
Ich nicht. Ado Goldkante, Gardin da irgendwie.
Mir schwarrt da irgendwas, aber uiuiuiui.
Hast du deine Jugend etwa nicht von dem Fernseher?
Doch, aber sowas von.
Na dann musst du auch die Ado Goldkante kennen. Sorry.
Na ja, da klingelt irgendwas, aber...
Das war noch immer so eine komische... Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe...
Hast du Westfernsehen geguckt?
Ja, nee, das war immer so eine komische Wohnung, die so ein bisschen graumiliert halt auch aus sah. Im Generellen war das so eine spießig aussehende Frau, und die hat dann aber ihre glänzenden Vorhänge mit Goldkante präsentiert oder irgendwie. So war das.
Da war aber nur die Kante wahr, nicht der Rest. War das übliche Grau.
Ja, heutzutage heißt das ja nicht mehr Gardine. Heute heißt das Privacy Shield.
Ich habe auch jetzt die politisch korrekte, also man sagt jetzt auch nicht mehr retarded or disabled, sondern differently abled in den USA. Um jetzt ganz PC zu sein, weil alle sind ja differently abled.
Differently unabled.
Das kann man jetzt auch gleich hier mal, unser Glossar mit überfliegt.
Die Gardo Goldkante gibt es immer noch im Web 2.0.
Also Raul hat das mal so schön gesagt, also behindert sind ja eigentlich alle nur zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten. Also wer es heute noch nicht ist, der ist es halt später irgendwann dann auch irgendwann mal. Von daher betrifft es eh alle. Ja, die Goldkante, so ist das.
Früher oder später trinkt jeder Wurzelpeter.
Ja, ich denke, muss man sich noch über das Weltgeschehen großnehmen? Das ist durch, ne?
Da hast du ja andere Sendungen für mittlerweile, oder?
Genau.
Ja, die Leute störenden da natürlich auch schon. Mir kam gerade so ein Aspekt noch entgegen. Jetzt haben sie ja vor, also ich weiß gar nicht, in welchem Zustand der Debatte das ist, das sagt ja heutzutage auch gar nichts mehr aus. So gleich so die Passwörter direkt an der Grenze einzusammeln, so hier du hast so einen Twitter-Account, gib mal her.
Finde ich voll gut, voll privacy awareness. Jetzt wird den Leuten mal so richtig gezeigt, wie schlimm es werden kann. Weil die haben ja gesagt, ja, niemand will das und es interessiert sich ja keiner dafür. Ist alles nicht so schlimm.
Jetzt sollten als Deutsche die Schnauze nicht so weit aufreißen, weil heute gab es gerade den, frag mich was, Kabinettsbeschluss oder wie auch immer, dass sie das in Deutschland auch machen wollen.
Damit werden sie aber wirklich sehr weit kommen in Deutschland.
Sie machen es ja erst mal mit Asylbewerbern. Das geht dann bei den AfD wieder ganz gut durch und so. Und dann mal sehen, wenn das erfolgreich ist, dann kann man das auch mit anderen Leuten machen, die so eine Grenze überschreiten.
Ja genau, aber ich habe mir nur darüber gedacht, also unabhängig davon, wo denn das jetzt alles in Kraft tritt, habe ich mich jetzt nur gefragt, was man dagegen eigentlich tun kann. Also auf der einen Seite kann man wahrscheinlich erst mal insgesamt am Ende wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel dagegen tun, aber vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen. Ich habe mir nur gefragt, wenn sie jetzt ein Passwort haben wollen.
Wer jetzt? Sie. Wer sie?
Sie halt.
Die mit dem Gewaltmonopol.
Ach die mit dem Gewaltmonopol.
Zumindest mit dem temporären Gewaltmonopol zum Zeitpunkt des Übertritts eines speziellen Bereichs. Die auch immer sozusagen die Möglichkeit haben, dir wieder die andere Richtung zu zeigen oder andere schlimme Dinge mit dir zu machen.
So lange nur die andere Richtung ist es ja okay.
Ja genau, oder halt zu zeigen, wo du bleiben kannst. Anyway, wenn man jetzt mal überlegt, Passwort, klar, also ich meine, die können natürlich dann irgendwie foltern, dann ist vorbei, ja, man könnte dir natürlich auch ein Passwort geben, aber wenn man halt Two-Factor Authentication eingeschaltet hat, reicht das ja nicht.
Ja, dann wollen sie das von dir auch haben.
Ja, aber wenn du dann kein Gerät an dir hast, wo du eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung tun kannst. Na ja, dann kannst du das, wie ich schon anhub, es ist mir klar, dass beliebig viel Repression folgen kann, nur auf diesem Scale von, wir lassen uns das jetzt mal von allen geben, die da so durchkommen, was natürlich gewisser Ansicht auch illusorisch ist, aber sie werden da irgendwas sieben, oder werden irgendwelche Trigger haben, oder irgendeine AI, die das dann sozusagen auf Basis der Flugdaten schon vorher bestimmt, wo sie dann ganz gerne mal ein bisschen mehr Zugriff hätten, oder vielleicht auch gar keine AI, sondern einfach nur eine normale AI.
An den Grenzen nicht so häufig zu finden, aber gut.
Naja, aber hinter den Grenzen, also die sogenannte Intelligence. Die Very Bad Intelligence. Was machen die jetzt sozusagen, wenn du sagst, also mein Twitter-Passwort ist irgendwie lalala, dann gibst du es ein und dann sagst du ja, und jetzt bitte noch den zweiten Faktor. Hab ich nicht dabei, hab kein Gerät, weil Telefon nicht dabei.
Jetzt glaubst du, dass dann so ein Grenzbeamter sich dann sagt, oh na dann, na dann haben wir natürlich Probleme, jetzt treten sie bitte einfach durch, ich glaub, sie haben ja vollkommen recht, sondern der macht einfach genau das, als wenn du ihm das Passwort nicht sagst. Genau dasselbe.
Ja, weil ich so, aber du kannst ja beweisen, dass es dein Passwort ist.
Hallo, das interessiert den nicht. Das, was da passiert, ist postfaktisch.
Die diskutieren auch nicht mit dir.
Ich weiß.
Du gibst dir den Zugriff auf deinen Twitter-Account und wenn du das nicht machst, dann egal warum, ob mit Gründen oder nicht, oder sonst, dann fliegst du da raus.
Die Sendung ist zehn Minuten alt, da können wir doch nicht alle Nerd-Träume schon fliegen lassen. Ich dachte, ich räume das mal am Anfang weg, damit das nicht so am Ende kommt.
Die haben mich mal da vor Jahren, da war alles noch gar nicht schlimm, zurück zum Flugzeug geschickt, weil ich die Hausnummer nicht wusste, wo ich hin will. Aber den Rest der Adresse. Ich wurde sogar abgeholt vom Flughafen, aber die wollten mich auch nicht die Leute zum Schalter rufen lassen. Hatten das dann stewardess dann freundlicherweise noch gemacht. Und dann konnte man das noch klären. Aber wenn die dann wegen so einer Sache, die schon, zurückschicken, dann kannst du aber wissen, dass das...
Wenn ich dir mal das...
Ja gut, aber das wird ja dann im Umkehrschluss dazu führen, dass einfach mal so die Zahl der Touristen dann doch auch zurückgeht. Weil ich glaube... Oder noch mehr. Ich meine, das wird dann irgendwann nicht mehr ökonomisch. Aber man kann sich halt zumindest schon mal...
Wir leben aber nicht vom Tourismus.
Das dauert eine Weile, bis es durchlegt.
Zwei Factor Authentication, ohne ein Zwei Factor Authentication Device dabei zu haben, ist ja schon mal auf jeden Fall hilfreich.
Ja, aber das riskiert niemand, weil keiner will zurückgeschickt werden.
Ich habe jetzt gerade einen Artikel gelesen von einem Kanadier, der ist das erste Mal an der Grenze abgeprallt. Der wollte da unbedingt dringend rein. Und dann hat er ihm das Passwort gegeben und dann haben sie festgestellt, oh, der Typ ist ja schwul und sonst so was. Und das geht ja gar nicht. Und dann hauen sie mal wieder ab. Und dann hat er ein paar Wochen später noch mal probiert. Diesmal musste er ihm das Passwort gar nicht geben, weil das hatten sie noch gespeichert. Er hat aber vorher seine ganzen Dinge alle gesäubert. Er hat auch sein Telefon gesäubert. Dann haben sie gesagt, was haben sie da? Ihr Telefon ist ja gesäubert. Wieso haben sie ihr Telefon gesäubert, bevor sie hier reinkommen? Sie haben ja was zu verbergen. Wieder raus.
Aber so wird es kommen wahrscheinlich. 1984, hallo. Nur ein besser. 1984 2.0. Habt ihr hier zuerst gehört, ne?
Bestimmt. Ich finde das politisch spannender daran, dass sie das da jetzt so ein bisschen aus dem Fugen gerät, weil die Grenzschutzpolizei dort hat sich sogar Gerichtsbeschlüssen verweigert. Die haben einfach gesagt, das interessiert mich nicht. Schön, dass ihr hier einen höchstrichterlichen Beschluss oder einen hohen richterlichen Beschluss habt. Den lese ich einfach nicht so. Fertig, zack. Und das ist echt krass, wenn die Gewaltenteilung derart kaputt geht, dass du keinen gerichtlichen Schutz mehr hast vor irgendwas, was die dort machen. Den hast du als Ausländer sowieso nicht, weil gerade wenn du da aus Deutschland kommst, kommst du ja meistens über diesen ESTA-Mechanismus, also Visa Waiver Program, und da schreibst du ja faktisch, dass du sagst, du nimmst die Entscheidung dieses Border-Patrol-Typen da an, egal was der sagt. Und wenn der sagt, du kommst hier nicht rein, weil deine Nase gefällt mir heute nicht, dann ist das ausreichend. Wie gesagt, als Ausländer hast du ja eh verkackt, aber selbst Amerikaner, die sich da drin verfangen hatten, wo es denn Gerichtsbeschlüsse gab und die CBP einfach gesagt hat, mir doch egal.
Rufen sie den Präsidenten persönlich an?
Die kommen dann mit so tollen Argumenten wie, naja, die Grenze ist ja nicht US. Das ist ja alles sozusagen außerhalb. Meine nächste Frage wäre dann gewesen, okay, was maßen sie sich denn jetzt die Authority an, wenn die nicht US ist? Aber abgesehen davon, die sagen halt gnadenlos, mir ist das scheißegal.
Welche Social Networks, was wollen die denn alles so haben, bei Twitter zum Beispiel? Warum haben wir da kein Passwort zu sehen, das ist doch public.
Alles. Ich seh deine Datei messages nicht, wenn sie public ist.
Ich hab keine.
Aber gut, da wollen die ran.
Und deine privaten Facebooks.
Und beim zweiten Mal fragen die nicht nach dem Passwort, aber du kannst es doch ändern. Was ist denn das für ein bekloppter Scheiß?
Der Typ hat es nicht geändert. Die haben ihm wieder das Telefon abgenommen, haben ihn diesmal nicht nach einem Passwort gefragt, haben trotzdem drauf rumgestochen. Kramen dann wieder nach einer Stunde, haben sie gesagt, ihr Telefon ist ja leer.
Ich werde dir einfach keinen Telefon mitgenommen. Also man sollte halt einfach, wenn man dahin schon...
Genau, man nimmt einfach die SD-Karte raus aus seinem iPhone und...
Du kaufst da einfach ein Gerät.
Ja, hm, klar.
Restores da, deinen Kram über iCloud.
Du, der du genau dein Handgeklöppeltes iPhone haben musst und nichts anderes auf dieser Welt, was auch nur irgendwie atträglich wäre. Gehst denn hin und kaufst exakt dieses iPhone nochmal in den USA, ja?
Wenn er eins kriegt, da ist er sogar froh.
Ja, also ich will da nicht hin. Ich wollte da schon ganz lange nicht hin jetzt wieder und jetzt noch viel, viel weniger. Und insofern, ja, ist mir erstmal egal. Solange das jetzt nicht überall auf der Welt und dann auch noch in ganz Europa so ist, ich muss noch vorher mein Segelboot klarmachen, damit ich dann einfach da auf dem Meer rumschippe.
Dann setze dich so drei Meilen vor San Francisco in der, wie heißt das hier, die Zone, wo die nichts mehr zu sagen haben, weißt schon.
Internationale Gewässer.
Ja, genau, aber so Navi geht.
Da hast du Fehler noch, echt.
Genau, ihr könnt mich.
Ja, kommen wir zu Reisealternativen Clemens. Du warst ja jetzt schon längere Zeit nicht mehr hier. Wo hast du überall gebadet?
Ich war in Singapur.
Und geduscht.
Ja, das war lustig. Auch so über Neujahr und so. Auch angeblich ein Polizeistaat, aber so einfachste Einreise wie dort hab ich schon lange nicht mehr erlebt.
Weil die wissen eh schon alles vorher.
Ja, wiss ich nicht. Aber die sind halt cool an der Grenze. Und höflich und so. Und machen nicht so einen Stress. Nee, das war da ganz nett. Ich hab ja viel gemacht so Mitte der 90er Jahre dort. Und das war nur 20 Jahre her. Und da hat sich jetzt nochmal eine ganz Menge geändert. Manche jetzt irgendwie nicht so schön. Aber andere haben sie beibehalten. Diese Multikulti-Geschichte dort scheint zumindest bei denen ganz gut zu funktionieren. Ich war jetzt nicht lange genug da und kenne auch nicht genug Leute, um das beurteilen zu können, woran das liegt. Ob das jetzt an staatlicher Oppression liegt oder wie auch immer. Aber da kann man mal sehen, wie so Christen, Muslime, Buddhisten und all mögliche andere Leute da mal sich zusammen raufen können. Das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut. Was dann auch gut funktioniert, ist halt so öffentliche Infrastruktur. ÖPNV und solche Sachen kann man echt nicht meckern. Und alles in allem habe ich auch wenig gemerkt von diesen Polizeistaatsnummern. Also das war ja vor 20 Jahren, die waren ja so krass drauf. Die haben wir dann so, keine Leute mit langen Haaren rin gelassen oder so. Oder die so ein bisschen hippiemäßig aussahen. Weil die halt schon sehr, denke mal eine sehr enge Vorstellung davon haben, was jetzt sozusagen dort probat ist. Aber das, was ich da jetzt an Leuten habe rumhüpfen sehen, das ist guter Schmelztiegel.
Lange Haare sind jetzt auch in Asien langsam durch.
Weiß nicht. Oder es interessiert sich einfach nicht mehr. Vielleicht gibt es auch ein paar Leute, die sagen, wir haben jetzt andere Sorgen oder so. Ich habe jetzt auch nicht probiert, ob das immer noch böse ist, weil man dort einen Kaugummi auf dem Fußweg spuckt. Hatte jetzt nicht das Bedürfnis. Aber ja, ansonsten ist das ganz nett. Werbt ja jetzt dieses Jahr, Ende des Jahres, kann ja nochmal wieder ITF dort machen. ITF 100, das 100. Meeting haben wir in Singapur.
Und gibt es jetzt noch...
Da gab es ein bisschen Streit vorweg.
Wie ist denn das jetzt, das USA-Thema hier zu sehr verlassen zu wollen? Aber ich hab so gehört, gerade internationale Gremien, da dürfte ja die ITF auch dazu gehören, haben jetzt sozusagen auch dieses Problem mit Muslim-Bands und sowohl mit Leuten, die nicht in die USA können, vielleicht nicht können oder mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr wollen. Beziehungsweise halt auch Amerikaner, die derzeit in der aktuellen Situation ihr Land auch nicht verlassen, weil sie Angst haben, es nicht wieder betreten zu können. So in beide Richtungen.
Das ist auch das, was ich denke. Wird das diskutiert für euch? Es gab letztes Jahr einen riesen Bohau zum Thema ITF 100 in Singapur. Weil es wird immer so ein paar Meetings vorab angekündigt, wenn es sozusagen in Sack und Tüten ist mit dem Hotel oder aber doch immer mit dem Konferenzzentrum und allem, dann wird immer, das ist mal so ein Jahr, vielleicht 18 Monate vorher, ist das klar und dann wird es halt auf dem nächsten Meeting klar gemacht, dass sie sagen OK, ITF 99 ist da und da und ITF 100 ist da und dort. 99 ist immerhin in Prag unumstritten. Und die 100? Prag ist immerhin, 100 ist in Singapur. Und bei Singapur waren sie alle erst so, ja, ist doch cool, die Asiaten freuten sich dazu mal nicht so weit reisen müssen und so und alles schick und alles schön. Und dann stand aber einer auf und meinte, Singapur geht gar nicht, weil in Singapur ist Homosexualität strafbar. Immer noch, wie stark, also keine Ahnung, das gibt es keine Todesstrafe drauf, wird nicht akzeptiert, offiziell. Und das bedeutet, er kann seinen Partner nicht mitnehmen und deswegen hat er gesagt, die ITF als internationale Organisation und Fahnenhalter des Guten sollte sich dann mal überlegen, was sie sich für Venues aussucht. Und da gab es ganze Menge hin und her und andere Leute, die auch gesagt haben, wir sollten mal besser aufpassen, wo wir jetzt überall hinfahren und blablabla. Natürlich auch und gerade aus den USA. Und die haben jetzt natürlich gerade nach Trumps Amtsantritt, so nach den ersten Wochen, die haben massiv Gegenwind gekriegt. Weil die jetzt auch ganz klar sich anhören müssen, sagen, wir haben jetzt hier ein Problem.
Gegen Ihre Argumentation dafür?
Ne, die jetzt auch gesagt haben, wir müssen jetzt mal aufhören, diese US-Dinger zu besuchen. Wir haben jetzt Chicago, Chicago lässt sich nicht mehr absagen, das ist jetzt in 20 Tagen oder so was, Ende März. Aber die nächste, die dann kommen wird in 2018, war San Francisco geplant und San Francisco wird jetzt in Frage gestellt. Weil die Leute einfach sagen, das geht so nicht. Es gibt zum Beispiel Gründe, warum wir, also wir haben immer ein Problem in Asien. Ich kenne so ein bisschen den Prozess, weil ich ja teilweise auch an dieser Show mit Teilnehmer, wenn sozusagen, wenn Venues ausgeguckt werden, ob die suitable sind, also ob die brauchbar sind für uns. Und ich hatte mehrfach Diskussionen mit den Leuten, die das dann auch entscheiden, so was ist denn zum Beispiel mit Kuala Lumpur? Ist ja auch schön in der Mitte, ist ein bisschen vielleicht sogar günstiger als Singapur und so was. Sagen ja, Kuala Lumpur ist Malaysia, Malaysia erkennt Israel nicht an als Staat und deswegen können wir da nicht hin. Weil wir haben sehr viele Israelis, die, und das ist halt da ein Problem, die können da nicht ohne weiteres einreisen und bla und blub. Das ist sozusagen immer so ein Thema gewesen auch schon, dass man sagt, wir wollen irgendwo hin, wo uns möglichst wenige Leute da nerven. Und genau das schließt jetzt nach aktueller politischer Lage eben die USA mit aus. Okay, die offizielle Ansage ist eh immer gewesen, The Americas, also wird dreimal mehr gemacht, einmal in The Americas, wird eigentlich Nord- und Südamerika einschließt. Oder aber auch die Problems, da gibt es jetzt nicht so viele Plätze, wo man das machen kann, also so Länder jedenfalls. Genau. Das heißt, The Americas wird sich jetzt auf Kanada beziehen oder sie versuchen halt jetzt doch nochmal Südamerika zu machen. Wir haben Südamerika Anfang letzten Jahres gemacht in Buenos Aires und das war nicht ohne. Na ja, wie das dann so ist. Das mag jetzt wie so ein blödes Klischee klingen, aber ich hab am eigenen Leib sozusagen miterleben dürfen, jetzt nicht direkt betroffen, aber sozusagen als direkt daneben stehen da, wie das so ist, so mit Bestechung und so und hin und her. Wir haben unser Equipment da hingeschickt, alles rechtzeitig und das steht dann da im Hafen rum oder am Flughafen sogar. Und dann steht da so ein Zollbeamter, der sagt, oh sie haben aber viele Kisten hier. Na das kann ja dauern. Und du denkst so, wäre ganz schön, wenn wir die Kisten jetzt mal hätten. Also ich will jetzt da nicht in Detail gehen, aber das war nicht ganz ohne. Und allein diese Geschichten da, unser Equipment da hinzukriegen, hat uns dreimal so viel Geld gekostet wie sonst.
Geht das auch noch für Mexiko?
Ich hab noch keine in Mexiko mitgemacht. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob überhaupt schon mal eine in Mexiko war. Wird jetzt allerdings durchaus interessant sein. Aber ich denke mal, Kanada ist sozusagen weit vorne.
Schon auch aus Prinzip.
Aus Prinzip bestimmt. Wie gesagt, wir brauchen aber auch eine Location, die passt. Also von der Größe her passt. Und die muss natürlich auch Bits haben. Und in Kanada waren wir schon ein paar Mal. Also Vancouver, Toronto, Montreal. Und so kannst du dann rotieren, wenn du willst. Und man kann auch durchaus nochmal nach Buenos Aires gehen. Müssen halt nur gucken, wo wir die Kohle, die extra Kohle, die man da so braucht, herkriegen. Aber das ist jetzt durchaus ein interessantes Thema. Und die Amis, die da mitdiskutieren, die schlucken das auch so ein bisschen. Die kommen auch mit so ein bisschen, da ist ja nicht so schlimm, blablabla, aber die anderen sagen, alter, wenn wir nicht nach Malaysia fahren können, wegen der fünf Israelis, wir sollen jetzt nach Amerika kommen. Wir haben deutlich mehr Muslime als fünf. Und die haben, selbst wenn sie jetzt nicht zu diesen sieben...
Also sie haben sicherlich doch mehr als fünf Israelis.
Ja, die sind sehr viele Doppelstaatler dabei. Aber wir haben, ja, selbst wenn wir jetzt sehr viele Muslime da haben, die jetzt nicht zu diesen sieben Staaten da gehören, du weißt da trotzdem nicht, was Customs & Border Patrol da anstellt. Da treibt der die schärfsten Blüten. Und das ist jetzt in der Tat eine lautstarke Diskussion, die da stattfindet.
Das heißt, ihr müsst ihr dann lieber so zwischen Deutschland und Kanada hin und her hoppen, ne?
Naja, wie gesagt, und Asien. Also einmal Amerika, einmal Europa und einmal Asien. Deswegen, Prag ist zum Beispiel sehr beliebt. Prag ist günstig, ist gut zu erreichen. Zeigt derzeit keinerlei Einreiseprobleme für irgendwelche anderen. Berlin ist sehr beliebt, auch. Letztes Jahr waren wir auch in Berlin. Da gibt es so ein paar Länder, wo es so Venues gibt, die auch nutzbar sind, die man da benutzen kann. In Asien ist es wie gesagt ein bisschen schwieriger auch. Nicht nur politisch, sondern auch da mal was zu finden. Aber naja, es wird spannend.
Ja, wollen wir noch beim Reisethema bleiben? Hast du was?
Ne, wüsste ich. Neu-Seeland war ich ja auch noch ein paar Minuten. Auch da relativ unproblematische Einreise, Ausreise und so.
Die sind auch cool. Ich war ja da auch mal, hab da ein bisschen zu lange Partys gemacht. Wenn nachts um drei ist, da macht alles dicht, egal wie viel Action ist. Drei ist auf jeden Fall, macht alles zu. Wir sind ins Auto gestiegen, war auch schon hell, also vier, fünf oder so dann. Dann kam ein Polizist im Auto gleich angepest, nachdem wir eingestiegen sind. Er ging ans Fenster und meinte gleich, ihr müsst mir gar nichts erzählen, das ist sowieso alles auf Video aufgenommen und ihr seid jetzt vorbei, Jungs. Weil wir wegen gesoffenen und Autofahren wollen. Also gerade ein Stück Meter losgefahren. Dann kam er und meinte, ich bräuchte gar nichts erzählen, das ist alles auf Video. Das war 1999 und ich finde, das war schon... Neuseeland.
Also in der Stadt oder in der Stadt?
Ja, also relativ.
Also auf jeden Fall nicht Auckland oder Wellington, sondern irgendwas kleineres. Nelson, irgendwas, was dann das Nächstgrößere...
Nelson hatte ich aber jetzt als relativ cool empfunden.
Ich bin mir jetzt auch nicht sicher, Christchurch, also nicht die Hauptstädte da oder die große hier in Auckland, sondern irgendwo ein bisschen kleiner.
Na Christchurch ist das größte auf der Südinsel.
Was heißt das? Sie sind da komplett videoüberwacht in der Stadt?
Hat er gesagt.
Was war das dann mit euch?
Ich musste dann pusten. Es war auch ein bisschen kritisch, aber erstens war ich über 27 und deswegen gibt es da andere Werte, weil man ja schon älter ist, warum auch immer das so ist. Zweitens, ich war Ausländer und dann war das okay. Das Schlimmste, wir hatten noch einen Neuseeländer hinten im Auto und der meinte, lasst doch die beiden Jungs da vorne, die sind hier Touris und aus Germany und so, wir wollen ja noch ein bisschen Spaß haben und hat die ganze Zeit auf diesen Polizisten eingedonnert. Der war auch betrunken, also das war das größte Problem eigentlich. Na ja, sprachlich, also nicht beleidigt, aber so ihm ordentlich Kontra gegeben und das war eigentlich das größte Problem. Na das ging dann gut, aber das war schon scary so mit diesem, wir haben euch am Sack und alles ist auf Video und wir müssten gar nichts erzählen.
Also als Nelson kann ich nur sagen, die sind so ein bisschen in so einem Welcome-Modus.
Was heißt denn hier als Nelson?
Nein, nein, die Stadt heißt Nelson. Nein, die Stadt heißt Nelson. Liegt am Nordwestende der, also liegt am Nordwesten der Südinsel und hat so ein bisschen so Welcome-Kultur, so freies WLAN für alle und du darfst auch mitten in der Stadt campen zum Beispiel, wenn du da einen Camper hast, der bestimmte Sachen mitbringt. Das finde ich eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache. Die Neuseeländer haben sich überlegt, sie zertifizieren mal so Camper, also so Autos, so Wohnmobile. Und wenn du da so ein Zertifikat hast, dass du self-contained bist, dass du sozusagen alles mitbringst und alles mitnimmst, dann darfst du auch dich irgendwo hinstellen, wo man sich normalerweise mit so Dingern nicht hinstellen kann, zum Beispiel eben auch in Städte an bestimmten Stellen oder auch in so einen Nationalpark kannst du dich dann auch da reinstellen und so. Das finde ich eigentlich mal ganz cool, da sind die relativ locker. Und mitten in Nelsen gibt es einen riesengroßen Parkplatz mit öffentlich zugänglichen Duschen und so weiter und so fort und freies W-Lan und alles so ein Blub und so. Also die stehen da auf Leute.
Bei denen ist es halt Touris, das ist halt ein Business bei denen, das muss man sagen, den Amis eher weniger, würde ich behaupten. Also eine Gesamtsumme weiß nicht, wie man sich das vergleichen kann, aber der Anteil auf jeden Fall in Neuseeland, was die an Einnahmen an Touris haben, ist deutlich größer als der Anteil, was die Amis an Touri-Einnahmen haben. Wenn man das prozentual betrachtet, im Absoluten ist es wahrscheinlich anders.
Ja gut, aber gerade jetzt im Hinblick auf internationale Events, diese Relevanz des Durchlauforts, wo die Welt zu Hause ist, UNO-Standort und so weiter, ich würde nicht sagen, dass das jetzt zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt akut gefährdet ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall überhaupt erst mal eine Debatte in diese Richtung gestartet worden. Das ist eigentlich für die USA schon ziemlich hart.
Vor allem, das löst sich ja so Dinge aus. Deshalb gibt es dann irgendwelche Kongresscenter in den USA, die werden jetzt dann weniger besucht, nehmen weniger ein, die Hotels in der Gegend auch. Dadurch bricht halt auch gleich so ein bisschen Infrastruktur zusammen und plötzlich, wenn Trump vielleicht mal wieder eines Tages weg ist und die Veranstaltungen dahin zurück wollen, sind die gar nicht mehr so richtig da, weil sich das so ein bisschen abgeflacht hat. Weißt du, weil dann sind die Hotels weniger geworden, das Kongresszent haben sie dann umgebaut, weil es hat sich nicht mehr gelohnt.
Ja, und man hat sich dann vielleicht auch woanders schon ganz gut arrangiert. Ach, in Berlin ist ja eigentlich auch ganz nett und der Döner schmeckt auch besser. Die können auch Englisch und so. Auf einmal wird die Welt entdeckt und das ist, glaube ich, eher das Problem, wenn die Leute erst mal merken, dass es eine Alternative gibt.
Wann ist denn die WWDC?
Die ist jetzt im Juni.
Aber nicht mehr in San Francisco. Sondern die haben sie nach San Jose runtergekarrt.
So wie früher.
Aber ist ausverkauft, ne?
Ist noch nicht so weit, kommt noch. Aber ist wieder losverfahren. Willst du hin?
Nee, ich frage mich nur, wie die das machen.
Das könnte für die ein echtes Problem werden.
Oh ja, das wird es bestimmt auch.
Also da muss man jetzt mal gucken, mit was sie jetzt nachlegen. Aber euer Meeting da in Chicago wird sicherlich schon mal ein interessanter Test werden, je nachdem, wie die Gesetzeslage zu dem Zeitpunkt ist.
Ja, kurzfristig aber werden die Teilnehmerzahlen gut im Auge behalten.
Ja, und die WWDC wird sicherlich, wenn es da Probleme gibt, auch so ein Vehikel sein, um das international zu thematisieren.
Ja, aber die werden wahrscheinlich ins Ausland gehen für ihre Veranstaltung.
Nein, aber es wird natürlich diese Debatte sozusagen nach oben bringen. Klar, die versuchen ja gerade, den Event möglichst nahe an sich heranzuholen. Wir sind ja jetzt auch in St.Rosé, das ist jetzt irgendwie so zwei Blocks weiter vom Spaceship. Ich hab mir das mal erflogen und so weiter.
Wir kennen das ja von dir.
Um die Ecke.
Genau, es ist wirklich um die Ecke. Ja, muss man sehen. Aber ich meine, wenn sie da jetzt eh keine neue Tastatur vorstellen, ist es eh egal. Wenn sie die Sache ja machen. Was uns zum Thema Max bringt, wir sollten ja über Max reden. Und ich übergebe mal an Huckel.
Huckel will auch noch mal seinen Senf abgeben.
Ja, genau. Also, Denis hat ja hier als erster mit so einem shiny Space Grayer auch bei dir, ne? MacBook Pro, den Aufriss.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt exakt die gleiche Kiste, ja?
Welches ist genau welche?
Also, 15 Zoll MacBook Pro, mit allem rechts unten bis auf SSD ist nur 1TB statt 2.
Nicht die Pavel-Version.
Aber halt dicke Grafikkarte, dicke CPU, Max-RAM, das alles. Alles, was man anknipsen kann, bis auf den Speicher halt.
Aber nur so als Zweitrechner, ne?
So als...
Da ist sie wieder, die moderne Dekadenz.
Ich hab auch nur mein Zweitrechner, mein Hauptrechner ist eigentlich mein Telefon, würde ich sagen.
Also, naja, anyway, ich hab den jetzt auf jeden Fall so von meinem Arbeitgeber gestellt bekommen, sonst, also, ich hätte auch mein 2012er Schlachtschiff auch noch weitergefahren, aber jetzt dachte ich mir, okay, ich spring mal in das Auge des Orkans oder Tornados, da ist ja eh immer am ruhigsten, ne. Und probier das jetzt mal aus und guck mal, wie schlimm das eigentlich so ist, ne. Naja, also, wir haben uns ja hier schon thematisch natürlich in den Sendungen davor sehr viel vorbereitet und irgendwie hattet ihr immer auch ein bisschen die Angst genommen und ich war ja so ein USB-C-Skeptiker und so weiter und ich dachte, naja, vielleicht ist ja auch gar nichts so schlimm, vielleicht haben die alle recht und es ist eigentlich ganz toll, ne. So, jetzt hab ich das also... Ich glaube erst... Letzte Woche irgendwann hab ich das bekommen. Also ich hab jetzt so eine Woche im Betrieb. Ich hab nicht einen Clean Install dieses Mal gemacht, weil ich mein altes Jahr vor kurzem als Clean Installed hatte, also Migration Assistant gestartet und dachte mir so, Migration Assistant, da geht's ja schon los, ne. Hast du jetzt so das Gerät so zu Hause?
Wovon hast du dann migriert?
Von meinem anderen MacBook Pro. Ich hab ja kein... Also es kommt ja... Genau, wir kommen jetzt über WLAN, genau. Da kommen wir nämlich schon zum ersten Punkt, also Auspack Experience, ja. Mach also diesen Karton dann auf, hebe den Deckel, MacBook Pro sieht ja echt shiny aus und so, dieses Base Grey ist ja schon irgendwie schick. Und wunderte mich erstmal, also zum einen, das Netzteil kommt ohne Verlängerungskabel daher, also es kommt nur mit diesem normalen Kleinstecker, das heißt, ich hatte direkt beim ICE, also als ich mit dem ICE zurückgefahren bin von so einem Event, wo ich dann dieses Notebook erhalten habe, hat es dann schön alles mal auf den Kopfhörern gebrummt, immer wenn ich die Hände vom Gerät genommen habe, weil halt kein Schoko-Stecker und so weiter. Da dachte ich mir auch so, ey, du klickst jetzt das rechts unten Gerät mit allen Belts und dann kommt nicht mal das Verleihungskabel mehr mit.
Ich weiß auch den Grund dafür, dass Paketwerte großgebracht sind. Ich glaube, das geht gar nicht ums Preis, das geht um die Optik, weil das ist so schön flach, der Karton.
Aber unter dem Karton ist noch so viel Platz. Anyway, es kommt ja auch kein Adapter mit, keiner, in Worten, keiner. Das heißt, ich sitze zu Hause, habe dieses Gerät, ich habe das Ladegerät, also das Netzteil halt und dann denke ich mir so Migration Assistant, alles klar, ah, wait a second, WLAN. Und dann geht es ja auch in diesen Peer-to-Peer-WLAN-Mode, das geht ja nicht über deine Base Station. Das hat dann halt, was weiß ich, zwei Stunden oder drei Stunden oder was auch immer halt gedauert. Ich habe es dann einfach beiseite gestellt, mein MacBook Pro benutzt in der Zwischenzeit und irgendwann war es dann fertig. Aber das war so die erste Experience irgendwie.
Hattest du den Eindruck, dass es jetzt über WLAN besonders langsam war? Weil ich meine, im Prinzip haben die ja relativ schnell Radio.
Ich habe die nebeneinander gestellt, das waren, er zeigt dir an, wie schnell es ist. Er meinte irgendwas 25 bis 30 Megabyte. Oder Megabyte waren das dann schon eher, ne?
Würde man jetzt mal so hoffen.
Ja, aber es hat halt, weiß was ich, drei Stunden oder so gedauert. Ich hatte, die SSD war so bei 350 Gigabyte. Geh ne Ahnung.
Ich hab das auch gemacht. Und per WLAN und das neue Gerät hat er schon hier 802.11ac und meine alten Geräte aber nicht. Dadurch war das sehr, sehr schnecken lahm. Und ich hab das dann abgebrochen, weil ich hatte mir wenigstens einen einzigen Adapter erst mal mitgekauft bei Apple, nämlich den C auf A hier, dieses neuen Euro-Teil, was da gerade billiger wurde. Weil ich dachte so, das brauchst du erst mal, damit überhaupt irgendwie wenigstens eine Sache, die du brauchst und die du anschließen kannst. Und da hatte ich dann von USB 3 nach SATA so einen Adapter. Den hatte ich schon. Und hab das dann da drüber gemacht und das flutschte dann auch einigermaßen.
Ich hab ja, ich war bei so einem Event von meinem neuen Arbeitgeber in Köln und da hat mir der Admin, der halt auch seinen Sitz da irgendwie in Köln hat, der hat mir dann zum Ende des Events dann einfach das Gerät noch so, ach hier übrigens, kannst du gleich mitnehmen, muss ich nicht verschicken und dann hatte ich halt keine Chance noch jetzt einen Adapter sozusagen zu kaufen. Naja und dann jetzt die letzten Tage habe ich so versucht, mich mal mit diesem Gerät so eben anzufreunden.
Nur mal kurz eine Nachfrage, aber die Migration lief einfach seitlich durch.
Die lief durch, ja, das kann man sagen. Immerhin.
Also ich meine andersrum wäre jetzt also schnell und Fehlermeldungen...
Wäre auch doof, döver gewesen.
Wäre deutlich döver gewesen.
So, also wo fangen wir an? Körsertasten, das Allerwichtigste. Also ich habe hier so ein paar Punkte aufgeschrieben. Also die Tastatur ist natürlich das erste, mit der ersten Berührungspunkt bei so einem neuen Gerät. Erstes Fazit ist, zu viel Klick für zu wenig Hub. Also ich finde, die ist mega laut dafür, dass sie wirklich nur so einen minimalen Hub hat. Also da könnte sie auch einfach wirklich viel gedämpfter sein, das wäre dann auch okay. Aber irgendwie, jetzt haben drei Kollegen im Büro diese Tastatur, ey, und das klackert wie, also es ist, als hätten die da so ein Schlachtschiff stehen. Es ist lauter, ne? Ja, es ist viel lauter. Deutlich. Dann, was ich wirklich nicht wahrhaben wollte, weil immer, wenn Denis von diesen Körsertasten erzählt hat, dachte ich mir, ja ey, mein letztes Problem sind die Körsertasten, aber es stimmt, die nerven mich so endärztdoll ab, ey. Das geht überhaupt gar nicht, klar. Also ich hatte ja auch keinen Adapter, ich konnte auch keine externe Tastatur mal so eben anschließen, ich hab keine Bluetooth-Tastatur und so weiter, nur das heißt, ich saß die ersten Tage und hab da drauf gehackt und dann, diese Körsertasten haben mich in den Wahnsinn getrieben.
Kann man die vielleicht so runterschweißen, dass man die so vorne mit so einem heißen Draht irgendwie so abscharbt oder so?
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich finde auch dadurch, also ich meine, die sind ja diese Hoch-Runter-Tasten, die sind ja im Prinzip noch sehr ähnlich, aber dadurch, dass die so flach sind, merkst du halt auch diese Eindellung? Ich weiß nicht, wo du bist.
Manchmal verwechselst du die Lücke zwischen den Körsertasten mit der Lücke, die zwischen der Shift-Taste ist und wenn du dann nach oben drücken willst, drückst du immer Shift und denkst, warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Und jetzt sagt dir einer im Chat, ich hab von dem Admin jetzt noch nachträglich ein Magic Keyboard geschickt bekommen und das Layout ist genau das gleiche, bekackte Layout mit den genau bekackten Körsertasten. Der einzige Vorteil ist, Escape-Taste. Was mich zum, also Tastatur, hab ich noch irgendwas hier? Nee, das wäre jetzt so der Tastatur. Ich werd mir jetzt tatsächlich so eine externe mit Numpad wieder und Kabel holen. Das ist einfach mein Layout da. Also auch von der ganzen spatialen Verteilung, sag ich mal. Dann kommt natürlich die Touchbar gleich als nächstes ins Spiel. Ich bin ja Wim-Hacker und hab dann auch gleich am nächsten Tag...
Warte mal, stopp! Du hast jetzt vor, dein Niggelnagel-512-Turbo-Laptop mit einer externen Tastatur USB-mäßig oder...
Ich hab immer, wenn ich im Büro war, hatte ich immer das Laptop hier auf so ein Sockelchen stehen neben dem großen Display und immer eine externe Tastatur und Mouse. Also das ist eigentlich der normale Modus. Ich hab halt nur jetzt das Magic Keyboard ausprobiert und dachte mir, naja, vielleicht ist ja ganz geil, aber ich mag halt nicht, dass bei diesen kleinen Tastaturen der Fn-Key halt auch links unten ist. Also ich hab mich so an dieses große Layout gewöhnt und die schönen großen Cursor-Tasten alles...
Achso, so ein Volles.
Ja, mit Numpad.
Da hab ich neulich das erste Mal wieder nach einer langen Zeit getippt und erst gemerkt, was das für eine unfassbare Umstellung ist, Cursor woanders zu haben und so. Klar, wenn man das dann täglich benutzt, gar kein Problem, aber die ja geradezu emotionale, ich würde sogar fast sagen, intime Bezug, die man zu seinen Cursor-Tasten hat, den macht man sich halt erst in dem Moment klar, wo es weg ist. Also der Trennungsschmerz setzt dann erst verspätet ein, aber dann halt auch so richtig.
Ich mein, ich...
Wie fehlt mir?
Ich komm halt mit dem, was Clemens auf seinem älteren Gerät hat, mit den Cursor-Tasten komm ich ja auch klar und das der FN Key links unten ist schon okay, aber wenn ich eine externe hab, dann hätt ich das gerne voll ausgebaut. Ich hab einen Kollegen, der auch die AirPods hat, der auch zuhört tatsächlich bei unserer Sendung, der hat so ein altes ADB Mac, wie hießen diese fette Mac, Apple Keyboard? Genau, und der hat sich dann so eine Adapterkette gebaut, um das dann an seinem Gerät bis zum heutigen Tag zu fahren.
Von USB-C nach USB-A, von USB-A auf ADB.
Wahrscheinlich, oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob er sogar noch einen USB-Port in seinem Gerät hat. Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber auf jeden Fall sieht das auch sehr classy aus, außer mit so einem fetten Schlachtschiff.
Das waren auch ordentliche Tastaturen, das muss man schon mal sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie damit wirklich durchkommen, weil eigentlich dürften sie nicht damit durchkommen, weil wenn sie damit durchkommen, dann weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, was ich mir noch für einen Computer kaufen soll. Also ich sitze diese Generation aus. Und wenn das jetzt noch drei Jahre dauert, das ist mir so scheißegal. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie irgendein Gerät auf den Markt bringen, was mich ausreichend anzieht, solange sie dieses Tastaturproblem nicht gefixt haben.
Ich muss noch sagen, dass das Gerät leichter ist. Das ist schon ganz geil. Dass es aber auch so klein ist, ist mir eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig. Es kann ruhig auch einen Millimeter höher sein, wenn sie dafür die Tastatur wieder ein bisschen besser machen. Aber Gewicht ist ja okay. Die müssen es aber nicht unbedingt so mega flach machen.
Wie gesagt, das ist einfach nicht geil. Und vor allen Dingen fühlt es sich auch nicht wie eine Verbesserung an. Du denkst halt eher die ganze Zeit so, ich kann mich bestimmt irgendwie dran gewöhnen. Es ist nicht so, ah ja, endlich. Es gab ja diese Generation von MacBook Pros, da zählt auch mein altes 2012er zu, da hast du schon im Vergleich das Gefühl, du klickst so in den Sumpf rein. Das macht so richtig so... Das ist bei diesen externen Tastaturen alles nicht und deswegen mag ich die auch viel lieber als die internen von dem alten MacBook Pro. Aber das hier wiederum ist jetzt extrem in die andere Richtung. Zu laut und zu viel Klick für zu wenig Hub. Jetzt aber zur Touchbar. Am nächsten Tag gleich losgehackt mit Wim und alles. Ich hab jetzt mal versucht, die Escape-Touch-Variante zu benutzen. Und bin relativ schnell dazu übergegangen, mir Capslock zu remappen. Wer auch immer von euch jetzt der große Capslock, du warst das, Tim, ging aber jetzt erstmal wirklich nicht mehr dieser Touchbar des Escape zu benutzen. Hätte das einen Taptic Engine direkt unter dem Fake Escape Key, vielleicht wär's okay. Aber ich muss jetzt sagen, diese Touchbar ist so nutzlos, also mein Zwischenfazit bisher ist Energieverschwendung, weil in diesem App- und Controls-Mode, ich weiß ja nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich bin halt oft so am Kontext switchen, Apps, Apfel-Tab-Wissen-Show oder Command-Tab, und dauernd ändern sich da die Icons, dann kommen Emojis, dann kommen deine Browser-Tabs in Bund und Facebook und Suggestions und hast ja nicht was. Jedes Mal, wenn ich so sitze und auf den großen Monitor gucke, sehe ich halt immer unten in meinem Blickfeld, wie sich da die Icons ändern. Ich gucke immer, ist jetzt irgendwas, muss ich da kurz hingucken oder nicht? Und dann, ich hab mich jetzt noch nicht einmal, außer bei YouTube-Videos, die sozusagen im Video rumskippen, ich hab jetzt bei keiner App irgendwie jetzt da so einen Button gedrückt, weil du musst halt trotzdem immer noch immer so gucken, was ist denn da jetzt eigentlich? Und in der Zeit hast du es auch mit der Maus geklickt oder was auch immer. Und ich werde wahrscheinlich jetzt demnächst dazu übergehen, die Touchpad vollständig immer auf diese Expanded Controls zu stellen. Also, dass gar nicht die Apps immer ihren Kontext da rein blubbern, sondern, dass du halt im Prinzip die ganzen Control-Keys dauerhafter Expanded hast. Das erscheint mir irgendwie sinnvoller, weil dieses immer erstmal diesen Control-Strip rechtsexpand um heller, dunkler, lauter, leiser und was auch immer zu machen nervt halt. Und was ich auch echt enttäuschend fand, du kannst sie ja kustomisieren, aber du kannst nur in diesen Control-Strip, in diesen kleinen, nur ein zusätzliches Icon mit rein machen.
Man kann maximal vier Dinger reinlegen.
Genau, und dann, ja, ok, jetzt hab ich einen Screen-Log da halt reingelegt.
Ich auch.
Aber...
Achso, ich hab Screen-Log reingepackt, weil es gibt ja keinen Shortcut mehr, oder?
Genau, aber der macht doch genau das.
Ja, ich hab halt keinen Screen-Saver, ich logge halt...
Direkt, achso, ja, das war gleich am Ende.
Anyway, also, das hätten die sich wirklich sparen können. Hätten die einen MacBook Pro 15 Zoll gemacht mit Function-Keys, so wie das 13 Zoll ja auch in der Variante ohne Touchbar ist, hätte ich das 1000 Mal lieber genommen.
Ja, ich inzwischen auch, glaube ich. Ich hab noch eine kurze Anmerkung. Per Twitter hat mir jemand gesendet, weil ich hab mich ja aufgeregt, dass diese vier Tasten, die man rechts in die Ecke legen kann, wenn man zwischen der App und dem normalen Kontroll geteilt haben will, dass bei den vier Tasten kein Lautstärke plus minus dabei ist, sondern nur halt so Lautstärke an sich. Da musst du aber erst mal raufdrücken, um dann hin und her zu sliden. Und ich hätte gerne so plus plus plus minus minus minus. Weil ich weiß schon, ich mach das immer so, das geht irgendwie besser als so rumsliden. Das ist irgendwie bekloppt. Und da meint der leider, da kann man irgendwie so eine P-List wieder irgendwo im OS finden und kann sich seine Tasten dann künstlich eintragen. Und dann gibt's die auch. Hab ich jetzt gerade nicht zur Hand. Vielleicht kann er das ja posten, wenn er heute zuhört oder im Chat oder wie auch immer. Oder wir finden das noch irgendwie raus. Gibt's auf jeden Fall was. Hab's aber noch nicht probiert, aber ich denke mal, es stimmt, weil es hört sich alles sehr plausibel an. Das Andere, was ich eigentlich hätte, man kann ja, es gibt ja diese drei Modus, dass du nur diese Controls da hast für laut und leise und so weiter, dann dass du nur die F-Tasten hast und dann dass diese Mischung zwischen den Controls und dem, was die Apps so macht, hast. Und man kann ja mit Funktion so zwischen zwei Modus hin und her schalten, aber zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt die F-Tasten bei den beiden nicht dabei hab, dann kommen die nicht, da müsstest du erst wieder in die System Preferences und da irgendwie, und vor allem du musst Fn auch immer festhalten, um dann irgendwie eine Taste zu benutzen. Warum kann man nicht einmal kurz Fn drücken und dann wechselt das da oben und ich drücke nochmal Fn und dann wechselt das da oben. So könnte man schön zwischen den Dingern hin und her steigern, warum muss ich es festhalten? Das will ich halt auch nicht.
Also, ja, das ist wirklich...
Und ich bin eigentlich auch, ich hab gedacht mit den App-Controls, ich lass das mal eine Weile an, damit ich auch lerne, was die Apps mir denn so anbieten und so. Aber bisher gibt's da eigentlich nichts, was irgendwie wirklich, wirklich praktisch ist. Und ich glaub, ich mach da demnächst auch mein normales Standard lauter, leise, heller, dunkler und dann wozu dann der ganze Aufwand?
Das Problem ist halt auch, du kriegst dann halt, weiß nicht, zum Beispiel bei Textes Wörter suggested oder Emojis, aber es sind halt auch immer fünf Emojis. Und dann fängst du da an, in dieser Leiste da rum zu scrollen, wohingegen nur, wenn du dieses Emoji-Menü aufmachst, halt alles gleich hast und dann einfach klickst und ist viel schneller. Also es gab halt einfach noch nichts, wo ich dachte, ach, ja, das ist ja immer eine richtig gute Sache jetzt. Das nächste Problem mit der Touchbar, und das haben jetzt auch so ein paar Kollegen mir schon bestätigt, also es gibt so Leute, die ihre Finger gerne, wenn sie nicht tippen und über was nachdenken, halt auch so über der Tastatur liegen haben oder auf den Tasten. Und halt auch gerade die Vim-User halt immer so auf der Escape-Taste so latent liegen haben, und das halt so eine Angewohnheit ist. Du musst sie jetzt richtig doll, schnell, hart abgewöhnen. Nicht nur Vim.
Ich will auch nochmal von mir weisen, dass das sozusagen nur so eine VI ist. Ich benutze Escape für den ganzen Tag, für alles. Insbesondere für das UI. Sorry, wenn es eine Taste gibt auf dem alten, ich nenne es jetzt mal, dem wahren Layout, wenn es da eine Taste gibt im deutschen Layout, jetzt muss man dazu sagen, die ich wirklich überdenkenswürdig finde, dann ist das die Carré Grad-Taste.
Oder bei US International, was ich jetzt hier habe, dieses Plus-Minus-Symbol und der Paragraph ist da links oben, brauch ich auch nie.
Genau, also diese Taste unter Escape, da kann man einfach eine Escape-Taste daraus machen. Und wenn man das macht, dann ist unter Umständen dieser Touchbar auch schon, dann kann man ihn einfach ignorieren.
Aber das Ding ist, man kann ihn ja nicht ganz abschalten, das verbraucht er trotzdem nur Strom.
Ich glaube, der Stromverbrauch, der ist wirklich zu vernachlässigen. Aber solange sie das halt mit den Cursor-Tasten nicht wieder auf die Reihe bekommen, ich meine, das war so eine Errungenschaft. Das hat jetzt 15 Jahre lang irgendwie...
Cursor-Tasten sind eine Errungenschaft?
Nee, das Layout, das Inverted Tee, da muss man ja auch erstmal drauf kommen. Wenn du überlegst, so alte Powerbooks und so, die hatten halt noch völlig obskure, so VT100-Style, so mit links, rechts, hoch, runter, so nebeneinander. Wo man sich auch immer gefragt hat, was das soll. Und dieses halbe Tastenhöhe, das war's einfach. Ja, und it's gone with the wind. Und das ist einfach ne Scheißidee. Und dieser Touchbar, also mich, mich macht, also ich bereue nichts, also ich bin in meiner Oppositionshaltung nur bestätigt worden bisher.
Dann mach ich mal Touchpad hier erstmal zu. Touchbar, ach nee genau, Touchpad ist das nächste. Das gleiche Problem, Leute, die ihre Flossen halt so die ganze Zeit auf dem Rechner so parken, wenn sie gerade auch nicht tippen, haben erstmal so das Problem auch gerade so Leute mit größeren Händen, dass du halt immer so mit ein bisschen so auf dieses Touchpad raufragst und wenn du dann deine Hand so leicht bewegst plötzlich so, gerade wenn du alle Touchgesten noch an hast, ja, also ich hab ja die meisten deaktiviert, so mit vier Fingern und von rechts und von links und wo du nicht alles rein swipen kannst. Und bei mir ist es so die ersten Tage dann immer passiert, dass ich meine Hände so da drauf liegen hab lassen, so wie das so ist, wenn man halt so kurz mal nachdenkt und so und dann bewegst du die so ununterbewusst oder unbewusst und dann fangen da sich irgendwelche Sachen an zu verschieben oder irgendwelche Sachen klappen aus und so und ich dachte mir so, Alter, wieso muss das so riesig sein, hier ist nirgends mehr Platz wo man die Hände packen kann ohne aus Versehen hier unwissentlich und ohne taktiles Feedback was auszulösen. Also ja und was ich auch nervig finde, ich mag diesen Lautsprecherklick nicht, also mir reicht das physische Klicken und du kannst bei dem externen kannst du ja glaube ich sagen, dass der leise sein soll, dieser Klick. Und das kannst du beim MacBook Pro nicht ausstellen, der klickt immer, also er macht immer dieses dieses, ich kann es gar nicht nachmachen, dieses bescheuerte Geräusch. Ist jetzt nicht mega laut, ja, also das würde mich bei Kollegen jetzt vielleicht nicht so nerven, im Gegensatz zur Tastatur, aber ich finde es irgendwie auch...
Na ich mache eh...
Du kannst aber die Stärke davon schon einstecken.
Die Stärke, ja, aber nicht den Klick ganz... Ich glaube bei dem externen...
Bist du kein Tap-to-Click?
Doch, aber ich brauch den Lautsprecher-Click halt nicht.
Nein, Tap-to-Click.
Ja, mach ich auch.
Da kommt der Lautsprecher nix auf?
Nee, da kommt er nicht, das stimmt schon. Aber manchmal drückt man halt drauf.
Aber was ich bis heute auch nicht... Sie haben ja wieder so viele Dinge rausgenommen, die ich mich so gewöhnt hatte. Also ich sehe ja ein, dass das für die meisten User nicht handlebar ist. Aber dieses... Wie hieß denn dieses Setting? Wenn man jetzt Drag und Drop machen will, da gab es eine Einstellung, die es jetzt nicht mehr gibt im Mac OS, dass du halt... Du machst so Tap, Tap und Hold und dann hast du dann so eine Einstellung, wo du Tap und Hold auf einem Icon oder so zum Beispiel und dann kannst du die Finger wieder von der Tastatur nehmen, dann ist das sozusagen wie gedrückte Taste und dann kannst du so in einzelnen Swipes dieses Icon durch die Gegend bewegen, solange bis es an der richtigen Stelle ist und wenn du es droppen willst, machst du nochmal ein Tap. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie das Setting hieß, das gab es mindestens bis vorletztes OS und das gibt es nicht mehr. Und das macht das Touchpad für mich wieder etwas dümmer und weil ich kann mit dem Modus, ich komme mit dem Modus klar. Und es gibt so Momente, ich will dann einfach wirklich so mit einer Hand völlig entspannen, so weißt du. Und natürlich, ich finde es auch immer geil, wenn so Leute mal kurz was an meinem Rechner machen und dann so nach drei Sekunden so was ist das denn hier? Hier verhält sich ja alles ganz anders. Dann lege ich mich so zurück, so Power-User. Du kannst mit dem Pferd halt nicht umgehen.
So jetzt sagt hier ein User, da gibt es bei seinem MacBook Pro 15, äh 2015, gibt es dieses Silent-Click-Feature. Und das gibt es halt... Genau, das gibt es halt nicht bei MacBook Pro 2016, 2017 mit dem letzten Sierra. Ist nicht da, dieses Checkbox.
Aber den Light-Click kannst du mal sehen. Den hast du ja gerade eingeschaltet, wie ich gerade gesehen hab, oder? Ja, dann muss er nicht so doll klicken und dann ist der Klick auch nicht so laut. Also sozusagen jetzt, die haben da der Druckstärke angepasst.
Aber er ist immer noch da und er ist nicht sehr signifikant leiser.
Aber du hast ihn auch immer auf Medium.
So, Touchpad ist im Wesentlichen... Es hätte auch kleiner sein können. Das ist mein eigentlich Hauptproblem, dass du da irgendwie immer so drübertatscht, wenn du das auch nicht willst. Dann das nächste Ding, was ich wirklich auch krass finde. Also dieses Netzteil, dass es halt kein Verlängerungskabel hat. Okay. Und jetzt willst du einen zweiten Netzteil haben. Ey, da fällst du ja echt ins Essen. Dieses Apple-Netzteil USB-C, das kommt halt nur, das Netzteil, da kommt kein USB-C-Ladekabel dazu. Das kostet 25 Euro extra. Also das Netzteil in sich kostet 89 Euro. Das USB-C-Ladekabel 25 Euro und die Verlängerung.
Warte mal, Ladekabel, wie soll man den laden, wenn da kein Ladekabel dabei ist? Warte mal, du kaufst den Rechner?
Also beim Rechner ist es dabei.
Wenn du einen Netzteil kaufst, ist es nicht dabei.
Ich rede vom zweiten Netzteil, was man ja vielleicht auch haben will. Ein Netzteil ohne Kabel.
Genau. Also ohne gar keinen Kabel, nicht mal Verlängerungskabel. Und das Verlängerungskabel kostet dann auch nochmal 25 Euro, sodass du für einen zweiten Netzteil bei sportlichen 139 Euro landest.
Wenn du halt wieder diesen dicken Strom-Schnuffi holst. Den Schuko.
Ich meine, das kann ich jetzt von meinen alten Netzteilen abbauen, der passt nicht.
Ich habe auch noch genug. Ich habe locker für 200 Euro diese Schuko-Stecker zu Hause.
Aber wenn hier noch so ein paar...
Die kriegst du wahrscheinlich in Kilo Ware auf Ebay, ne?
Also wenn noch ein paar Hörer so ein paar Schuko-Verlängerungskabel haben, schickt man hier als Spende noch so, als kriegst du hier so eine Vetroschleppe.
Zum Rumschleppen fand ich die schon immer sehr ungeeignet, aber wie du schon sagtest, ungeerdet, das kann natürlich hier keiner sehen.
Wir müssen unsere Hörer nochmal aufklären. Der kleine Mini-Stecker, der hat halt nur, wie heißt das?
Zwei Kontakte.
N und L.
Leiter und neutral, oder wie das heißt. Und der Schuko-Stecker, der hat auch noch das Erdungskabel dabei. Und dann hat man nicht so Audiobrom und überhaupt ist alles besser mit dem.
Und wenn du nur über das Gerät streichst, dann vibriert es auch nicht so komisch und so.
Kriegst keine gewischt und so. Aber das ist ohne Batterie, also einfach nur Batteriemodus besser. Und ich fange jetzt schon teilweise an, mit dem Rechner herumzurennen, ohne mein Netz mehr zu nehmen, weil ich weiß, es hält zehn Stunden, es ist voll, der Tag wird überlebt und ich muss mir da keinen Kopf machen. Das ist schon wirklich, das hatte ich vorher nicht.
Ja, also das wäre jetzt mal kurz zum Netzteil. Der nächste Punkt wäre jetzt ja auch...
Aber warte, noch eine Sache zum Netzteil. Was natürlich früher immer ein Problem war, dass das Kabel fest war am Netzteil. Das ging ja immer kaputt bei ganz vielen Leuten. Das ist ja da auseinander gedröselt. Das ist jetzt der Vorteil, man muss dann halt jetzt nur sich ein neues Kabel suchen, muss auch nicht das von Apple nehmen. Man kann auch ein anderes nehmen, wenn man das richtig erwischt. Und dann kann man das da wieder reinschlecken.
Also ein Netzteil, was quasi ein Drittel von dem Netzteil kostet. Ein Kabel, genau.
Jetzt musst du nur noch ein Kabel kaufen, was so viel kostet, wie das Netzteil auf einiger Zeit kostet.
Ja, also Netzteil muss man so hinnehmen, Akku.
Moment, und das ist natürlich auch, also abgesehen jetzt von dem Preis, finde ich das Modell gut. Also dass du sozusagen separat hast, dass du quasi auch sagen kannst, ich will ein längeres Kabel haben.
Ja, ja, das ist prinzipiell, aber ich finde halt so, für die Preise, die du so aufrufst, und für das, was du für so ein Gerät auch bezahlst, so ein Verlängerungskabel könnten sie schon spendieren, oder auch mal noch ein extra USB-C- auf Lightning-Kabel, oder irgendwas, weißt du, was man so im Alltag mal gebrauchen kann, wenn man sein iPhone anstöpseln will. Könnte ja passieren, ne?
Wenn jetzt einer in den Laden geht und dieses Laptop kauft und sich das iPhone 7 dazu holt, muss er noch ein Kabel extra kaufen, weil das Kabel was dabei ist, ist wirklich unnötig für ihn.
Achso, das kannst du nicht benutzen, um dein iPhone 7...
Das alte USB, das geht ja in das USB-C-Stacker, gehen ja nicht rein.
Das Magic Keyboard, gerade frisch von Apple bestellt, kommt auch noch mit einem alten USB-Stecker. Und ohne...
Ich würde sagen, das ist die Übergangsphase, dass sie sagen, wir bieten dann dieses andere Kabel schon mal mit, wenn man das in einer Kombi kauft. Irgendwie soll es sich da mal was einfallen lassen, aber nur so ein bisschen die Preise für die Adapter zu senken, war ein bisschen lame. Was man noch sagen muss, wenn wir noch bei dem Netz da sind, weil ist alles gar nicht so einfach. Wenn man jetzt losrennt und sich ein Netz erholt und noch ein passendes Kabel dazu, dann kann sein, dass man das falsche Kabel erwischt, weil das dann nur für 3 Ampere ausgelegt ist. Weil das sind ja Smart Cables eigentlich oder irgendwie so. Die haben ja noch so eine Kodierung drin. Und dann lädt das Ding halt auch nur mit 60 Watt und nicht mit 90. Und du wunderst dich dann, warum dein 15 Zoll irgendwie nicht ordentlich mehr lädt, wie mit deinem anderen Kabel. Also da gibt es Unterschiede.
Das hab ich ja auch dann festgestellt, als ich das Gerät dann so auspackte und dann auf Amazon schon mal so nach Kabeln guckte, meinte der Kollege, ja, aber pass auf, also es gibt die Ladekabel und die Datenkabel. Und dann, wo ich dachte, was, hab ich bei der Freak Show wahrscheinlich nicht aufgepasst? Das wurde mir bestimmt schon besprochen, aber da dachte ich auch, ich dachte, das ist jetzt alles eins, außer der Null. Na ja, anyway, Akku. Kann ich kurz noch was dazu sagen, weil es zum Netzteil ja auch passt. Also die bis zu zehn Stunden hab ich bisher noch nicht erreicht. Also da muss man wirklich nur schwarze Terminals aufhaben oder nur mannpage lesen, keine Ahnung. Also sobald man so ein paar YouTube-Videos dann noch mal hin und war, also zwei hab ich an dem einen Tag geguckt, oder drei. Ich hab den ganzen Tag im Büro quasi gehackt, also nur Vim, Terminal, ab und zu mal gebraust, so Doku nachgucken, dann mit Go halt compile, das geht ja relativ schnell. Zwischendurch hab ich noch mal zwei, drei YouTube-Videos geguckt und es hat dann gerade so auf den letzten Drücker quasi einen Arbeitstag durchgehalten. Also im Vergleich zum Vorgerät, auf jeden Fall eine mega Verbesserung, aber ich hab relativ wenig gemacht und dann waren es halt sieben Stunden ein bisschen. Also wie man auf zehn kommt, ist mir ehrlich gesagt noch ein bisschen schleierhaft.
Hatt ich am Anfang auch, hatte dann aber aus vielen anderen Gründen einen Clean install gemacht und seitdem war das Problem behoben.
Deine Migration hat es verkackt.
Na, Scheiße. Jetzt kommen wir zum Hauptteil, also des ganzen Spaßes, also wirklich dieses USB-C-Ghetto als solches, ne? Weil ich irgendwie doch nicht dachte, dass es so schlimm ist, wie es ist. Muss mal kurz überlegen, wo ich da am besten anfange. Also... Kritikpunkt Nummer eins. Wenn jetzt Apple schon sagt, gut, wir machen jetzt USB-C und sie haben ja das normale MacBook mit nur einem USB-C-Port, das gibt's ja jetzt auch schon ein Weilchen. Und es gibt von Apple halt einfach keine ordentlichen Adapter. Also wenn Apple wenigstens sagen würde, pass mal auf, hier jetzt USB-C und hier ist mal von uns die saubere, sündhaft teure, aber Adapter-Hardware, die ihr so haben wollt, fine. Aber es gibt ja von Apple so gut wie nichts an Adaptern, was man wirklich haben will. Also es gibt das USB-C, USB-A Schnuffi, das hast du auch, oder hast du einen Third-Party? USB-C auf A. Den Apple Schnuffi. So, von Apple gibt es ja keinen Ethernet-Adapter, da gibt es nur den von Belkin.
Ja, nicht nur, es gibt schon andere.
Ja, es gibt schon andere, aber...
Achso, bei Apple gibt es nur den von Belkin, ja, okay.
Der von Belkin habe ich dann irgendwie ein bisschen gelesen, der wird wohl ganz warm, muss man noch ein Firmware-Update einspielen, damit er irgendwie richtig spielt und so. Und die Reviews, wenn du die Adapter-Reviews auf den Apple Store-Webseiten mal anguckst oder auch überall eigentlich, die sind auch teilweise wirklich sehr schlecht. Also von 1-2 Sterne so in dem Bereich. Naja, habe ich mal nach anderen Ethernet-Adaptern geguckt, die sind dann ganz oft so, dass sie von Thunderbolt halt auf USB 3 erstmal übersetzen und dann die alten Chipsets benutzen, also nicht wirklich Thunderbolt machen und halt wohl auch sehr viel Wärme produzieren dabei. Dann gibt es welche, die sind nicht EFI-kompatibel. Das heißt, du könntest halt im Zweifel, ich meine, das ist jetzt ein seltenes Szenario, dass du ein Netboot machst oder irgendwas so, ne? EFI-Stage mit Netzwerk machst, aber du könntest ja zum Beispiel über das Internet restorieren oder so, ne? Da müsstest du dann halt Treiber installieren, also ganz furchtbar alles. Ich habe jetzt einen gefunden, der ist ganz vielversprechend. Den werde ich mir mal bestellen. Der wird laut Review, ist ja dann nämlich auch EFI-kompatibel. Pack ich mal gleich den Link hier in die Show-Notes.
Also EFI meinten Kompatibilität mit der Firmware, mit dem BIOS quasi.
Das ist schon bevor der Treiberhof ist, dass das EFI schon mit ihm sprechen kann.
Dass das Ding einfach nicht irgendwie Software-Support im OS braucht, sondern einfach schon von der Hardware selber her supportet ist.
16,90.
Das ist da wiederum geil, ne? Also die Preise.
Ja, wenn es denn was taugt. Das andere Problem ist halt, du hast halt wirklich so jetzt diese ganze, weil halt die ganze Welt jetzt USB-C macht, hast du halt auch die ganze Welt China-Plaste, RAM, USB-C, Adapter, Zubehör. Und du musst halt, wenn du dir die Amazon-Reviews durchliest, du musst da dreimal lesen und auch wirklich alle lesen, weil da kommen Leute mit Problemen daher, da glaubst du gar nicht. Ich hab's auch im Büro live erlebt, da haben ja diverse Leute diese Adapter-Taschen. Und dann ist es halt so, du willst jetzt irgendwas mal anschließen und ausprobieren, dann geht der Adapter einfach nicht. Hat aber gestern noch funktioniert. Guck mal bei mir, bei mir geht er jetzt auch nicht mehr. Gestern hat er noch funktioniert. Cluster weg, nächster. Das ist jetzt schon ein paar Mal so vorgekommen. Nächstes Problem war Display anschließen. Denn es gibt halt, das Problem ist zweifaltig. Mindestens, also erstens gibt's ja jetzt so 4K-Displays, die nur alten HDMI-Standard unterstützen, sodass du über HDMI keine 60Hz, sondern nur 30 bekommst. Auf der anderen Seite gibt's HDMI Thunderbolt-Adapter, die auch wiederum nur das ältere HDMI implementieren und dann auch von der Adapter-Seite aus nur 30Hz bei 4K liefern. Das heißt, du musst halt ganz genau hingucken, welchen Adapter und zu welchem Display. Und mein Tipp, das hat sich jetzt im Büro auch etabliert, einfach USB-C zu Display-Port. Weil Display-Port-Adapter in der Regel alle das mit dem 60Hz und 4K wunderbar hinkriegen. Und bisher waren die Display-Port-Adapter die, wo es auf Anhieb funktionierte, mit Display über USB-C-Randadapter.
Also nochmal, wie ist die Kette? USB-C-Port von deinem MacBook, da ein Adapter, der auf Display-Port geht und dann?
Und dann die meisten Displays heutiger Bauart haben ja einen Display-Port.
Achso, und wenn du aber wirklich dann nur über HDMI reingehen kannst, bräuchst du eigentlich noch ein Display?
Naja, dann, ich setze dieses HDMI jetzt aus.
Ich meine, ich wundere mich ohnehin mit diesem HDMI 2.0, das ist ja schon länger.
Beziehungsweise dieses 4K-HDMI setze ich aus. Ich werde mir noch einen HDMI-Adapter besorgen, für die Uni vielleicht dann auch und so, weil die haben ja auch einen HDMI-Kabel am Beamer.
Was für ein Bildschirm hast du denn?
Zuhause habe ich ja diesen Dell Ultrasharp. Da ist das jetzt kein Problem, weil der nicht 4K hat. Im Office gibt es jetzt überall 4K-Displays. Das sind in der Regel Dell-Displays.
Die 60Hz können? Und die auch HDMI 2.0 haben, angeblich?
Ja, da bin ich mir nicht bei allen sicher. Das sind nicht alles die gleichen. Also ich glaube, einige sind genau von der ersten Kategorie, wo das Display HDMI-seitig sozusagen nicht 60Hz bei 4K kann. Aber wenn ein Display Display-Port hat, das ist der Punkt, dann geht das in der Regel halt immer. Also ich habe jetzt noch kein Display gefunden, wo es nicht ging.
Woran kannst du feststellen, dass es dann 60Hz sind?
Wo steht das? Ja, wir haben jetzt immer auf dem Monitor selber geguckt, wenn du da das Menü aufmust. Ein bisschen geiler. Ja, aber da steht es halt sofort. Ich weiß nicht, ob es im Systemreport auch stehen würde. Naja, auf jeden Fall, also diese Adapter-Hölle ist real. Und zwar echt zu Ausmaßen, die ich gar nicht für möglich gehalten hätte. Docs haben alle irgendwie mindestens zwei Sachen, die dann immer gleichzeitig scheiße sind, sodass man die nicht haben will. Zum Beispiel eben ein HDMI-Pod, der nicht 60Hz bei 4K kann, oder kein Ethernet oder nur... Also es gibt irgendwie immer irgendwas, was nicht so stimmt. Und ja, ich hab mir jetzt tatsächlich so erstmal einen ARC Hub pre-ordert. Das schien mir jetzt der einzige Hub zu sein, der mir...
Ein was?
ARC Hub heißt der. Ist in den Show Notes auch verlinkt. Achso, ich kann erstmal auch den Display-Port-Adapter auch noch verlinken, der funktioniert, den ich empfehlen kann für alle USB-C...
Das ist aber Display-Port und nicht Mini-Display-Port, ja?
Genau. Es gibt aber Display-Port zu Mini-Display-Port, oder es gibt auch einen Adapter, also... Ne, du weißt schon. So und das ARC, den ARC Hub, den hast du da unten, ganz unten der letzte. Kann ich auch nochmal in die Show Notes packen. Der ist jetzt pre-ordert, ist halt auch sozusagen in the making noch. Sie wollen, glaube ich, März ausliefern. Genau, das hat man letztes Mal schon erwähnt. Das fand ich jetzt erstmal so das Charmantes, auch wenn das von den Ports her halt auch nicht alles hat. Das hat zum Beispiel kein Ethernet. Aber jetzt kommt noch der finale Punkt zu diesem USB-C von meiner Seite. Und zwar finde ich den Port an sich wirklich nicht so überzeugend. Und zwar liegt das daran, dass ich jetzt diverse Sachen da schon reingestöpselt hatte. Das Apple-Ladekabel, das sitzt sehr gut, muss man sagen, aber alles andere, was ich so reingesteckt hatte, labberte, schnackte, komisch oder nicht richtig. Und gerade wenn man so das Notebook auf einem Podest stehen hat, damit das so in ergonomischer Höhe ist, so am Arbeitsplatz in dem Display, und dann bammeln da links und rechts die Adapterketten runter, dann sieht man einfach, wie diese USB-Stecker sich alle so schön nach unten biegen und man hat die ganze Zeit echt so Sorge, dass sich jetzt diese Stecker da verbiegen. Und deswegen hab ich mir auch diesen A-Cup geholt, weil der ja mit einem Kabel angeschlossen wird und nicht so wie die anderen Docs so direkt am Gerät so kleben. Einfach um diese Zugentlastung sozusagen zu haben, dass jetzt nur ein Kabel auf den Tisch geht und da dann die ganzen anderen Kabel dranhängen, weil wirklich das ist wie so ein Flügel hängen lassen, sieht das dann aus. Und gerade dieses Display-Kabel, Display-Portkabel, das ist halt in der Regel sind Display-Kabel relativ fett und schwer. Dann hast du diesen Adapter da noch dran. Also ich muss sagen, so vom Gefühl her, aber wie gesagt, ist jetzt nicht ganz fair. Also der Lightning-Port, der fühlt sich für mich schöner an, aber da sind die Kabel natürlich auch alle von Apple. Das Ladekabel von Apple, das sitzt eigentlich auch ziemlich gut, oder? Also das schnackt ja. Alles klar, super.
Also nicht ganz das Schlimme, aber es wird schon ein bisschen, am Anfang war es bei mir relativ schwer. Ich dachte, das hält aber richtig gut, aber das wird ein bisschen weniger mit der Zeit.
Also ich fände diesen Port einfach physikalisch wenig überzeugend. Also gerade auf meinem Arbeitsplatz ist jetzt erstmal alles sicher und da läuft auch keiner dran vorbei und zuckt mal am Kabel. Aber MagSafe gibt es jetzt auch nicht mehr. Wenn mal irgendwie du aus Versehen noch so irgendwas dranbammeln hast und ein Gerät oder das Kabel gezogen wird, da hätte ich jetzt auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr Sorgen, dass da irgendwelche Ports oder irgendwelche Stecker flöten gehen quasi bei Flöten. Also Fazit.
Könnte irgendwann mal gut werden.
Nee, also ich muss sagen, der letzte Rechner, wo ich so dachte, ah geil, das ist ein Upgrade, war halt mein 2012er MacBook Pro, weil das hat alles, was schon vorher geil war, noch mal besser gemacht. Schneller, höher, weiter, fluffiger, toller. Und das ist jetzt ja hier so ein Wechsel von allem. Ich hab jetzt eine andere Tastatur, ich hab ein anderes Display, ich hab komplett andere Ports, ich hab ein anderes Touchpad. Und es fühlt sich nicht wie ein Upgrade an. Also das, was gut ist, das sind die einzigen Punkte, die mir so einfallen, ist es leichter, das Display ist toller. Was hatten wir vorhin noch?
Lautsprecher.
Lautsprecher tatsächlich sind Presser, aber es sind immer noch Notebook-Lautsprecher, aber es hat Bass, also es bummert schon ordentlich.
Na ja, aber guck mal, wenn du jetzt ein paar Jahre in die Zukunft guckst, dann ist ja so, dass du in ein paar Jahren, oder in ein, zwei Jahren deine Displays ja nicht mit 1000 Adaptern anschließt, sondern mit so einem ganz dünnen, wie das Ladekabel zum letzten, mit so einem ganz dünnen Kabel.
Das Ladekabel vom letzten ist doch nicht dünn.
Ja, aber relativ zu den Displaykabeln schon. Oder zu allen anderen Sachen von früher. Dann hast du da ein relativ dünnes Kabel zum Display und dann hängt da auch nix durch und ist auch nix schwer. Das dauert halt ne Weile.
Ja, dieser Traum ist ja durchaus valide immer noch. Aber es dauert, genau. Und der zweite Punkt, der mir jetzt halt so klar geworden ist, durch diese Massenflut-Altina-Plaster-Adaptern. Also weil Apple halt selber nicht ordentliche Sachen bauen will. Das wäre das Beste, wenn Apple jetzt das Apple-Doc bauen würde und alle halt in die Fresse. Aber das machen sie ja nicht.
Das könntest du eh nicht bezahlen.
Ja, mein Arbeitgeber. Dann wär ja gut, aber die machen nicht mal einen Ethernet-Adapter, die machen nicht mal einen ordentlichen Thunderbolt 2-Adapter. Die machen nicht.
Ja, Thunderbolt 2 haben sie schon.
Aber der funktionierte doch nicht mit Displays, oder was war das Problem da?
Naja, der macht halt Thunderbolt 2. Der alte Thunderbolt 2-Port an den Rechnern hatte noch ein bisschen mehr gemacht. Bei dem Adapter kommt aber nur Thunderbolt 2 raus und nicht diese anderen Sachen. Also nur weil der Slecker passt, heißt nicht, dass es geht.
Die Transition endet nie. Sie hätten ja alles dafür tun können, um das so smooth wie möglich zu machen, und Sie haben nichts getan eigentlich. Auch dieser AV-Adapter, das ist wirklich das Beste, was Ihnen eingefallen ist. Wo ein USB-A, ein HDMI oder VGA wahlweise und ein weiterer Display, einen USB-C-Port.
Das ist halt von einem alten MacBook, weil der ja nur einen Port hatte, der musste ja weiter geladen werden und brauchte ein USB und braucht halt das Display.
Also ich hab hier auf deinem Drobo diesen tollen Stiftung-Warn-Test gar nicht mal so geil, oder nicht so geil, Note 6. Also eine Note 6 würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil es ist ja immer noch ein funktionierender Computer. Aber es ist nicht so geil. Nicht so geil wie man so denkt, wenn man 2016 rechts unten klickt und alles anmacht und so.
Ja, was soll ich dazu noch sagen?
Das beste für mich... Also sie könnten die Situation verbessern, mit der Option, die Touchbar wegzulassen bei der nächsten Generation, also wie bei 13 Zoll MacBook Pro.
Das wird nicht passieren. Die haben einen Wahnsinns-Marketing-Tanz gemacht und haben jetzt sogar Microsoft dazu überredet, dass sie das in ihre komische Office Suite damit einhacken.
Ist egal, wenn die Leute das nicht wollen.
Ja, as if Apple would care.
Haben sie einen 13 Zoll mit der Tastatur rausgebracht oder nicht? Daran werden sie sehen, wie die Nachfrage ist. Und ich wäre nicht so überrascht.
Erstmal werden die Leute doch alle dieses Touchbar kaufen, weil es halt geil ist. Die Frage ist, wie lange das so durchhält und ob sich das jetzt mehr so rumspricht, dass man das nicht haben will.
Das ist ja nicht geil.
Das ist die Leute, aber wir kaufen nicht.
Die hören aber alle Freak Show.
Munze und Propaganda, da funktioniert ja auch noch. Also ich hab jetzt noch keinen gehört, der gesagt hat, ey Touchbar, das musst du haben, das ist jetzt wie so von Festsplatte auf SSD. Wie konnten wir vorher ohne Touchbar arbeiten?
Die schaun eher beschämt auf den Teppich. Ja, mit Touchbar, ich dachte so, wenn schon, denn schon. Ich wollte ja eigentlich auch das Große haben.
Das gab es ja nicht ohne.
Das ist die Begeisterung.
Und diesen Spruch, den hab ich bisher am meisten gehört, das Große gibt es ja nicht ohne Touchbar.
Genau.
Ja, das ist schon irgendwie nicht so geil halt. Nicht so geil. Gut.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, greife ich doch mal die Vorlage auf. Und berichte mal von meiner neuen Hardware, die ich auch letzte Woche bekommen habe. Und zwar letzten Montag schlug das glaube ich bei mir auf. Meine Bestellung der AirPods tauchte auf. Und ich hab ja schon vor einigen Sendungen so meine Gesamtüberlegungen zum Thema Bluetooth dargelegt und auch meine Ausgangsbasis formuliert, die sich im Prinzip zusammenfasst mit ich bin der Meinung, dass On-Ear mir am besten passt. Dass das sozusagen das ist, was ich eigentlich haben will. Und im Prinzip Over-Ear als zweite Option sehe, was ich glaube ich damals noch nicht erwähnt habe, weil das im Kontext von Bluetooth nicht so relevant war oder zumindest mir nicht so relevant erschienen ist. Dass ich auch für meine Earpods eine Killer-Anwendung eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit habe, denn die habe ich halt benutzt, um Podcasts zum Anschlafen zu hören. Oder im Bett oder was auch immer. Also im Liegen, sagen wir es mal so. Weil das geht halt irgendwie nicht mit den großen Kopfhörern. Das ging allerdings mit diesen Earpods relativ gut, weil die das Ohr halt brauchbar füllen, ohne jetzt zu drücken und auf dem Kissen geht das irgendwie alles schon. Naja, dann hab ich ja lange überlegt und war schon so, mal gucken und was nehm ich denn jetzt? Und weiß schon, dass ich im Prinzip auch den Boses noch mal einen Testlauf geben müsste, was ich aber bisher noch nicht gemacht hab. Und hab mich ja dann für die Beats entschieden, die Solo 3, die dann verfügbar waren. Wo ich mir halt dachte, okay, Earpods sind jetzt sowieso noch nicht zu haben. Ich will eigentlich On-Ear haben. Das ist On-Ear. Und nach den ersten kleinen Häubrigkeiten, die ich ja hier schon mal dokumentiert habe, mit diesen merkwürdigen Übersteuerungen, wenn man dann diese Soundoptimierung auf dem iPhone eingeschaltet lässt, ja, funktionierten die im Prinzip relativ okay. Es sind keine schlechten Kopfhörer. Das kann man jetzt wirklich nicht sagen. Und sie haben ja auch vor allem das andere Feature, dass man da halt noch ein Kabel anschließen kann, was für mich jetzt nicht ganz unwichtig ist, weil ich halt zum Schneiden von beiden Podcasts brauche ich einfach Kabelverbindungen. Wegen Latenz und wenn es irgendwie knistert, dann will ich einfach wissen, dass es jetzt in der Aufnahme ist und nicht gerade over the air kam. Das würde mich wahnsinnig machen. Also ist Wireless einfach auf immer und ewig raus. Es muss kabelgebunden sein, um da einfach sicher zu sein, was die Quelle ist für irgendeine Störung. Ich bin unzufrieden mit der Passform gewesen und dann bin ich so ein bisschen in Schwanken gekommen und dachte mir so, vielleicht passen ja diese AirPods auch irgendwie in dein Flow. Dann habe ich die Dinge einfach mal bestellt und jetzt kamen sie halt irgendwie an. Wo sind sie denn? In einer Hosentasche, wo sie hingehören. Das ist zum Beispiel schon mal Feature A. Also erstmal vielleicht zum Industrial Design. Atemberaubend! Also das finde ich wirklich grandios, dass es Apple at its best, diese Idee, diese Dinger, gleich mit so einer Tragetasche zu liefern und diese Tragetasche selber ist halt auch gleichzeitig noch ein Backup-Akku. Grandios!
Kurzer Nebenbemerkung, noch fällt mir gerade ein, haben wir glaube ich noch nicht erwähnt. Beim iPhone 7 ist diese geile Aufnahmetasche für den Kopfhörer nicht mehr dabei.
Bist du jetzt das Thema komplett wechseln? Spar dir das doch einfach.
Nee, nee, ich wollte das nur mal sagen.
Master of Disaster. Master of Tim-Blutgrinscher.
Das bist du doch.
Habt ihr das schon mal benutzt? Also habt ihr schon mal AirPods in der Hand gehabt?
Echt?
Also im Ohr gehabt?
Nee, im Ohr hatte ich sie nicht.
Nee, aber so ein Zahnseiteding hab ich auch zuhause.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus, ne? Na gut, also wer es nicht weiß, die Dinger sind ja schwer zu kriegen. Man hat halt so dieses Böckschen, ich geb euch das gleich. Ich geb's euch mal rum, halte das mal neben dein Telefon. Anlock mal dein Telefon. Anlock dein Telefon. So, und jetzt mach mal diesen Deckel auf von dem Teil. Schnapp. So, und jetzt kommt das Ding halt hoch. Genau, jetzt kannst du die halt...
Soll ich connecten?
Was hat er jetzt angezeigt? Jetzt hat er nur den Produkt, sozusagen.
Nee, der kann nur connect klicken.
Aber er sagt jetzt noch nicht Batterielade-Zustand.
Nee, das noch nicht. Er sagt, dass es nicht meine sind, die es aber connecten könnte.
Ja, connecten wir nicht. Ich zeig dir mal kurz, wie das auf meinem iPhone aussieht. So, weil wenn ich die halt hier aufklappe...
Clemens, guck mal! Das war der Wahnsinn jetzt.
Dann hab ich hier den Vorführeffekt.
Da passiert genau nichts.
So, dann kommen sie jetzt hoch, ne? Zeigt mir also auch nochmal mit so einem kleinen Fenster, was von unten nach oben kommt und zeigt mir den Ladezustand der Earbuds an und den Ladezustand dieses Akkuparks. Und das ist halt einfach schon mal geil, dass du in dem Tragegerät auch immer noch den Nachlade-Dings hast. Und dadurch ist einfach das Thema kein Strom in deinen Kopfhörern irgendwie weg. Weil du hast sie nicht die ganze Zeit im Ohr. Du benutzt sie vielleicht mal. Ich hab so drei, vier Stunden, hab ich glaube ich, mal mit den Dingern irgendwie vorm Rechner gesessen, die ganze Zeit irgendwelche YouTube-Videos reingeladen, Podcasts gehört, auch regelmäßig zwischen iPhone und Mac hin und her geschaltet, alles wunderbar. So, und dann beschließt du halt, jetzt musst du denen ja nicht die ganze Zeit so in den Ohren stecken haben. Mir ist übrigens noch nie rausgefallen. Also mit Einschränkungen. Also sie sind mir noch nie...
Noch nie, aber mit Einschränkungen?
Na sie fallen mir aus dem linken Ohr raus, wenn ich liege. Weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen hält diese Form dieser Dinger in meinem linken Ohr schlechter als im rechten. Das merke ich zwar auch, wenn ich sie so trage, aber es ist dann nicht so schlecht, dass sie wirklich rausfallen. Im Gegensatz zu den Kabeldingern, die dann immer wirklich links rausgefallen sind, tatsächlich. Das heißt der Klang ist irgendwie auch besser, weil sie noch ein bisschen besser sitzen, weil da einfach kein Kabel dran zieht. Ich musste es immer ein bisschen justieren am linken Ohr, aber es ist nicht so wie bei den Kabelteilen, dass der Klang dadurch wirklich schlechter wird für mich. Your mileage may vary, also sehe das schon. Es gibt Ohren, für die dieser Formfakt überhaupt nicht passt. Wenn es aber so ist, wie Apple sagt, dass sie da halt quasi mal so den Querschnitt genommen haben von allen Ohren, die irgendwie lieber dran sind auf dem Bäumenwand, kann es halt sehr gut sein, dass sie eben bei den allermeisten auch okay halten. Aber grundsätzlich halten die schon mal. Was ich nicht gemacht habe, ist jetzt irgendwie laufen, also rennen habe ich nicht gemacht. Und ich glaube, da wäre dann auch irgendwie Ende Gelände. Ja, also das ist, muss man einfach vorweg sagen, das Industrial Design im Sinne von, wie es kommt, wie man das hier einpackt, wie man es rausnimmt, wie man es reintut, wie es sich meldet. Klappst auf, nimmst den einen raus, setz den Ohr, bevor du die Hand an dem zweiten hast, macht das Ding schon blumm in deinem Ohr, du merkst, hat sie aktiviert, er merkt, er ist in einem Ohr, also Infrarot-Sensor hat irgendwie Wärme festgestellt. Der Sound könnte dann schon laufen, während du doch den zweiten dann hinterherwürfst, wenn du den ins Ohr reinsteckst, dann ist halt auch Ton drauf. Ja, dann hast du halt diese kleinen Nice Tees, nimmst das Ding raus, dann macht's Stopp. Soweit, alles gut. Lädt auch relativ schnell, also wenn du die Dinger leer, ich hab's noch nie leer gehabt, aber schon ein paar Stunden lang gehört, steckst die rein, machst eine halbe Stunde irgendwas anderes, holst die raus, nehmen wir mal 100 Prozent. Also die sind immer irgendwie geladen, sind immer da, sind immer benutzbar. Laden vor dem Akku-Pack selber geht eigentlich auch ganz gut, habe ich jetzt nicht so getimt, wie lange das dauert, weil ich das auch noch nie so richtig auf Null hatte. Aber da steckst du halt einfach Lightning ran, das ist so ein bisschen wie so eine Tastatur oder so ein Trackpad. Ist halt relativ wenig Akku, steckst sie rein, aber das ist enorm, mit wie wenig Akku, die überhaupt so lange hinkommen und doch ganz passabel funktionieren. Zur Audioqualität. Also ich finde, die Audioqualität ist gut. Ziemlich gut sogar. Für sie jetzt nicht als mega und grandios, und du hast jetzt auch nicht so diesen Bass oder so, aber es klingt besser als die normalen Earpods, deutlich. Und es ist okay. Also es ist so, man hat jetzt nicht so das Gefühl, sofort was besseres aufsetzen zu müssen. Es ist eine gute Qualität. Was nicht heißt, dass es keine Aussetzer gibt. Also ich hatte jetzt so in den 10 Tagen mehrere Phasen, wo es auch mal flaky ist. Also erstmal ist es natürlich das reine Reichweitenproblem. Man tendiert ja dann dazu, sich auch mal weiter zu entfernen, als man das halt mit Kabel macht. Laptop steht irgendwie auf dem Tisch, gehst mal irgendwie durch die Wohnung und im Klo merkst du dann so nach drei Wänden ist dann halt auch mit Bluetooth irgendwann... klar, gut, da können die Dinger jetzt irgendwie auch nichts dran machen. Das ist jetzt auch nicht viel schlechter oder besser als mit anderen Kopfhörern auch. Das sind etwa dasselbe. Also an der Stelle ist einfach Bluetooth die Grenze. Aber ich hab's halt auch manchmal, dass mal einer von den beiden kurz aussetzt, ich hab auch mal so Quirks drin und was ich auch etwas obskur finde, man merkt so richtig, wenn du, was weiß ich, wenn du zum Beispiel iPhone verbunden bist, pausiert hast und dann startest du mal wieder irgendwas neu und man merkt so richtig, wie so eine Software-Initialisierung, den Geräten sagt, jetzt kommt wieder Sound. Weil es macht so ganz kurz in den Dingern so, also nicht so ein, kein Stech.
Das ist nicht so einfach diesen Sound nachzumachen.
Das ist wirklich nicht so einfach, diesen Sound nachzumachen. Sogar für mich nicht. Also es fällt mir sogar schon schwer, mich selber nachzumachen. Es ist so ein ganz kleines, fast unhörbares Zischen. Und es ist da. Und es stört nicht, aber du merkst es. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich da mehr drüber ärgern soll oder mir drüber freuen soll, weil auf der einen Seite hat es so ein bisschen was so wie ich kann hören, was die Festplatte macht, wenn ich mein Brot drauflegen kann. Du hast so ein bisschen Kontakt zum Protokoll und nicht nur so zum Payload.
Man kann sich die Sache noch schönreden.
Nicht so schönreden kann man sich dann halt so die Ausfälle. Ich hab so den Eindruck, dass wir noch ein paar Firmware-Updates sehen werden. Diese Dinger werden noch besser werden müssen. Aber sie sind auf jeden Fall schon mal ziemlich cool. Was ist nicht so schön? Wenn du die Default-Mäßigkeit einstellst, perrst und in Betrieb nimmst, dann hast du ja die Möglichkeit, durch so ein Doppeltipp auf eins von den beiden Teilen Serie zu aktivieren. Interessiert mich natürlich ein Scheiß. Gott sei Dank gibt es so ein Setting, und zwar, komischerweise verborgen, im Bluetooth-Setup. Das ist auch so ein bisschen obskur. Sie bemühen sich irgendwie bei den Dingern, Bluetooth eigentlich komplett rauszunehmen. Du perrst die ohne irgendwie Bluetooth-Menü, du schaltest die dann immer um im Audio-Menü und wunderst dich, warum gibt es denn keinen Eintrag für die Dinger in den Settings, zum Beispiel. Gibt es aber, aber halt in Bluetooth musst du die Devices aussuchen auf dieses Info-i und dann hast du da noch Settings. Und da kannst du dann halt umschalten, was beim Doppel-Tab passiert. Drei Möglichkeiten, entweder Siri, der Default, gar nichts, was ein bisschen okay, kann man machen, oder Start-Stop. Das habe ich natürlich genommen. Und das heißt, das ist die einzige Remote-Funktion, die diese Dinger eigentlich haben. Was sie ja nicht haben, ist Lautstärke. Und das war ja auch eigentlich auf meiner Kriterienliste relativ weit oben. Und da kann ich mir jetzt noch kein abschließendes Urteil erlauben, wie sehr mich das eigentlich stört. Bisher würde ich sagen, es hat mir schon ein paar Mal gefehlt, aber es war bisher noch nicht dramatisch.
Warum machen die nicht so links tappen lauter und rechts tappen leiser oder wie so was?
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Also grundsätzlich muss man erstmal sagen, Doppel-Tab ist schon das Minimum. Also ein einfacher Tab wäre die Katastrophe, weil du ab und zu schon mal hin greifst und fast die Dingale anfasst.
Ja, aber wenn die Lautstärke geändert wäre, wäre das nicht so mega dramatisch. Dann machen sie es halt in kleinen Stufen.
Du meinst, bei einem normalen Tab?
Ja, ich finde, das würde gehen. Wenn du es rausnimmst, ist es auch nicht so schlimm, wenn du es gerade um eine Stufe leiser machst. Vor allem merkt er dann eh, dass du es rausgenommen hast, weil er macht ja dann aus und dann kann er die Lautstärke auch gleich wieder anpassen.
Ist auf jeden Fall schwierig, wenn du viel Komplexität hinzufügst. Irgendwas, finde ich, müssen sie machen. Man könnte auch überlegen, und auch das ist kritisch, ich sage auch gleich warum, zwischen links und rechts halt zu unterscheiden. Also dass irgendwie rechts Double Tap was anderes macht als links Double Tap oder so.
Das ist zu kompliziert für Apple User. Links und rechts ist eh so ein Thema.
Was auch vorstellbar wäre, ein Triple Tap noch zu machen.
Warum nicht mit dem rechten Ringfinger am linken Ohr kratzen?
Irgendwann sind da Kameras drin und dann macht man so Zeichen an der Seite.
Du musst erst mal die dreckige Hipster mit absetzen.
Bevor wir das verbessern, sage ich erst mal was wirklich, wirklich geil ist. Und wo ich auch sagen muss, das ist immer ganz davon abgesehen, dass die Dinger an sich schon so ein Living the Future Moment sind. Also finde ich schon. Also kommst du mit diesen Dinger in Kontakt und wenn du dieses Kleppchen aufmachst, da kommt schon so ein bisschen Fairy Dust raus. Also es ist schon so, die Zukunft ist da und hat ein Päckchen vorbeigebracht.
Aber die Zukunft ist weiß.
Die Zukunft hat Noise Cancelling. Ich weiß nicht, warum man in 2016 immer noch Dinger rausbringt, die das nicht drin haben.
Ist eine andere Zukunft hier.
Ist eine alternative Zukunft.
Auch die muss es geben. Ist ja noch ein bisschen Winter. Das heißt, Mütze, Handschuhe. So ist man draußen. Am besten noch eine Kapuze. Dann, was weiß ich, regnet es auch noch. Noch mal extra Kapuze drauf. Taschen. Du bist irgendwie belegt mit Zeug, mit Klamotten, mit Kram. Und dann willst du, dass der Podcast anhält, den du gerade hast, weil du möchtest gerne Interaktion mit Supermarkt, Mitarbeitern, Menschen, die du auf der Straße triffst, was auch immer. Oder du willst auch einfach gerade mal einen Break. Und dann, alles was ich machen muss, ist, mit meinen bepolsterten Handschuhen an meinen bepolsterten Kopf zu klopfen, Pop-Pop zu machen. Durch die Mützen durch, durch alle Handschuhe durch. Einfach nur, um einfach eine Bewegung auf diesem Teil zu machen. Und es ist stopp.
Und schon kriegst du von dem Gegenüber einen in die Fresse, weil der glaubt, du hast ihm einen Vogel gezeigt.
Das merkt keiner. Also du kannst so dezent einfach mal kurz irgendwie, du musst ja nicht mit der flachen Hand dir irgendwie gegen den Kopf hauen, sondern es reicht ja wirklich mit einem Finger an der richtigen Stelle, was auch problemlos zu treffen ist, kurz TAP TAP zu machen und es ist Pause. Mit einer vertretbaren niedrigen Latenz. Also es ist nicht so instantan klar, weil Bluetooth hin und her und irgendwas muss noch ein bisschen. Und das ist Gold. Also das ist wirklich Gold. Also das ist auch so der erste Moment, wo ich mir gesagt habe, okay, ich kann die Lautstärke nicht machen, aber ich kann die Dinger mit Handschuhen unter einer Mütze bedienen. In ihrer aller, aller wichtigsten Funktion, nämlich Stopp.
Und Start auch.
Genau, und Start auch.
Die wichtigste Funktion, Kaffee ran.
Naja, und halt auch Anruf annehmen, Anruf auflegen und so weiter. Das ist ja sozusagen damit auch gleich gekoppelt. Also das ist schon grandios. Und das hat bisher noch kein Remote in irgendeiner Form geschafft. Also Handschuhe, da war bisher immer Ende und hier geht es. Und dadurch, dass die Dinger auch überhaupt nicht groß auffallen, gerade wenn du noch eine Mütze drüber hast, die kannst du dir auch noch so weit ins Gesicht ziehen, dass die Dinger gar nicht mehr zu sehen sind. Niemand merkt, dass du überhaupt welche aufhast. Was auch eine ganz andere Filigranität ermöglicht. So im Umgang mit Menschen, was weiß ich, bist halt so im Supermarkt, hörst eigentlich die ganze Zeit irgendwas, Tapp Tapp, wo finde ich denn das Salz, ja da und da, Tapp Tapp, weiter, ohne dass die Leute dich groß anstarren. Weil wenn du mit so großen Kopfhörern irgendwie hast, wo du dann, was weiß ich, vielleicht irgendeine Tasse hast, mit der du so Mikrofonen durchschalten, dass du mit deiner Außenwelt kommunizieren kannst, aber du siehst ja immer noch so aus, als ob, ja. Also das finde ich wirklich gut. Das hat mich ein bisschen ins Befeuert.
Ich finde die Kopfhörer sollten in Space Gray rauskommen.
Lass mich nochmal kurz bei den AirPods bleiben. Lautstärke, Regeln, da müssen, da sollten sie eine Lösung finden. Wenn man jetzt gerade keine Handschuhe an hat und wenn man bereit ist sozusagen, so full Monty zu gehen und alles hat, also auch eine Apple Watch, dann hast du ja immer noch so die Option, die Apple Watch für die Lautstärke zu benutzen. Es geht, richtig geil finde ich es nicht, aber es geht. Also wenn du weißt, dass ich bis jetzt spazieren, wechselne Lautstärkeverhältnisse, weil große Straße und dann wieder leise, du musst irgendwie changieren.
Dann könnten sie sich die Kopfhörer eigentlich automatisch anpassen.
Erstens das, die könnten das nämlich vor allem, weil sie ja die ganze Zeit zwei Mikrofone am Start haben und wenn die quasi in Relation zu Außengeräuschen machen, wäre super. Noise cancellation, weiß ich nicht, ob das mit den Dingern überhaupt realistisch ist.
Ja, vor allen Dingen isolieren die ja nicht die Außenwelt so richtig.
Das sind so die beiden Sachen, die ich auch sehe. Bei der Apple Watch kannst du ja tatsächlich dieses Audio-Control einstellen. Das musst du natürlich erstmal auswählen und aktivieren und dann suchst du das irgendwie und wo habe ich denn das eigentlich? Das sehe ich zum Beispiel gerade wieder nicht. Dann kannst du aber die Lautstärke einfach über die Krone regeln. Ja, also und eine letzte Sache noch. Dieses iCloud-Syncing und das Umschalten zwischen den Rechnern funktioniert auf den AirPods tadellos. Also da hatte ich gar kein Problem, während ich bei meinen Beats, die ja angeblich mit derselben Hardware und im Zweifelsfall auch mit derselben Software arbeiten, nach wie vor das Problem habe, dass sie die ganze Zeit von den Geräten verschwinden. Also man würde ja meinen, das ist die selbe Experience, ist sie aber nicht. Keine Ahnung warum, vielleicht muss ich meine Beats nochmal komplett abmelden, Clean installen, nochmal neu, was weiß ich, vielleicht, ich weiß auch gar nicht. Wie ist das mit Firmware-Updates bei Beats? Läuft das irgendwie über den Apple-Kanal jetzt oder nicht? Oder ist das so eine andere Marke, dass es das da nicht gibt? Wo kriegt die dann her? Weiß ich nicht, muss ich noch mal gucken. Bei den AirPods hat es ja angeblich ein Firmware-Update gegeben. So ein stilles, was überhaupt nirgendswo so richtig angezeigt wird. Ich habe versucht herauszufinden, ob das bei mir installiert ist, habe aber keine Möglichkeit gefunden, das anzuzeigen, was denn überhaupt die Firmware-Version ist. Vielleicht mache ich irgendwas falsch. Ach, warte mal, ich könnte noch mal in diesen Bluetooth-Setting, von dem ich gerade sprach, schauen.
Sieht man wahrscheinlich, ob die bei Apple das so komplett versteckt hat vor den Leuten.
Wo ist denn jetzt hier dieses Setting wieder hin? Ich verstehe das alles nicht, ist mir unklar. Was wollte ich jetzt gerade erzählen? Beats, genau. Also iCloud Syncing, das funktioniert relativ gut. Daumen hoch, sage ich. Ist ein geiles Produkt. Und kann man halt auch super mit einschlafen. Und jetzt habe ich nicht mehr diesen Medienbruch, dass ich irgendwie meine Kopfhörer wechseln muss, nur weil ich ins Bett gehe. Sondern man kann die Dinger sozusagen einfach die ganze Zeit da haben. Und das ist auch absurd.
Und, wo waren sie am nächsten Morgen?
Na, die liegen dann halt irgendwo in deinem Kissen oder so. Aber das ist auch nicht so das Problem, die findest du schon wieder. Also bisher habe ich sie immer wieder gefunden.
Du hast sie jeden Tag benutzt.
Ich habe sie jetzt ziemlich viel benutzt, ja. Aber auch gar nicht so sehr aus dem ich habe die jetzt, jetzt sind sie neu, jetzt muss ich sie benutzen. Sondern es war so angenehm, die Dinge zu benutzen, dass ich das einfach ganz automatisch gemacht habe. Ich dachte schon, ich setze die anderen nicht auf. Jetzt habe ich mal heute...
Bist du auch schon oft durch die Straßen gelaufen, nur mit einem drin so?
Aber es geht, ne? Ja, nein, vielleicht.
Dann könnte man erstmal einen leer spielen und dann den anderen leer spielen. Zum Beispiel einen Podcast hören, da braucht man ja kein Stereo und dann hat man so ein Ohr frei für die Außenwelt.
Keine Ahnung. Hast du was schlecht abgemischtes, hörst du nichts? So würde man sie jetzt nicht benutzen. Weil vor allem dieses Rausnehmen und wieder reintun, das ist irgendwie so easy. Und das passt auch problemlos oben in diese Jeans-Taschen, also zumindest in die meisten. Hier gibt es einen Tipp, wo es angeblich sein soll. Das hatte ich schon mal gelesen, aber ich finde dieses Setting nicht.
Settings General baut AirPods ganz unten. Ach, du hast Deutsch, ja?
Ja, ich habe Deutsch und im Deutschen... Ja.
Tim, wie weit ist es denn gekommen mit euch?
Ich auch. Ich habe das vor Jahren mal umgestellt, weil es eine dusselige Abgabe, irgendeine Navigations-Ab, die wieder mit nicht klar kam, dass ich sie gerne in einer anderen Sprache haben möchte.
Inklusive Siri und Apple Maps? Aber die hatten das Problem auch.
Was, Navigon? Egal, so ein Ding. Und dann fing es immer an, mir irgendwelche deutschen Straßennamen in Englisch vorzulesen.
Ja, macht mein Siri bis heute.
Ja, das konnte ich denn nicht ab. Und inzwischen haben sie das gefixt, aber jetzt habe ich mich dran gewöhnt und dann ist es auch gut.
Hier sagt noch einer, wenn du einen Airpod im Ohr hast, dann stellt es automatisch auf Mono, also nichts mit hier schlecht abgemacht.
Ah, okay, gut, naja, das ist doch schon mal ein Feature. Ja, dieser Tipp mit Einstellungen, allgemein Info, AirPods, bei mir taucht das nicht auf. Ich habe diesen Eintrag nicht.
Das ist ja im Deutschen auch nicht ganz unten.
Oder ist das nur, wenn du die Klappe auf hast und dein AirPods gepaert sind?
Ach, das kann sein, dass die, das kann ich mal machen.
Das soll ich auch alles erzählen.
Ja, wirklich. Na ja, es gibt da viele Dinge, die man da, das muss ich erst mal simulieren, dass ich die im Ohr habe. Großmutter, warum hast du so große Ohren? Ich nehme die Dinger raus, es macht Stopp. Und weil mir dann gerade in dem Moment nichts Besseres einfiel, habe ich dann den einen in meine Hosentasche gesteckt. Da war es dann aber wieder so viel warm, dass es wieder angegangen ist. Da dachte ich mir so, das ist noch nicht so ganz durchdacht.
Und dann hast du die ganze Zeit auf deine Hose gehauen.
Ich habe es dann wieder rausgenommen, aber viel Schrank gelegt.
Das heißt, man sollte schon immer in dieses Ding packen und nicht in die Hosentasche, ja?
Immer in einen Corregataps-Behälter, genau.
Zahnseide, Mann, Zahnseide.
Das ist ja wie die dritten, wenn man Zahniusglas legt.
Alles klar, sie müssen aktiv sein, nur dann taucht das da auf.
Welche Firma-Version hast du?
351, das ist angeblich die aktuelle.
Aber es freut mich zu sehen, dass irgendwas mal wieder in dir einen kleinen Weg Begeisterung auslösen konnte. Also irgendwas von Apple.
Ja, das freut mich auch sehr. Ganz ehrlich, das freut mich sehr.
Das ist lange durch die Strecke gewesen.
Ja, aber es ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt nicht... Weißt du, die haben schon den Groove.
Ich hab ja hier meinen Motorradhelmen hier. Ich werd die nachher nach der Sendung mal anprobieren und mit Motorradhelmen so aufsetzen, mal checken, wie das so geht.
Ja, ich hab das Leute schon mit...
Ja, da haben schon Leute gesagt, dass sie das gemacht haben und so weiter, weißt du, eigener Erfahrung ist ja immer noch mal eine andere Sache.
Ja, genau. Ich würde jetzt mal aus dem... Also ich weiß nicht, wie das mit Lautstärke ist, inwiefern die sich gegen so Motormarkt...
Wenn man sich aufs Ohr kloppt, aber ansonsten...
Ja, ne, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gehen.
Mal probieren, mal probieren. Setz dich so einfach nur für Navi-Shit, wäre das schon ganz nett.
Aber da kannst du halt die Watch nehmen, ne?
Ja, als wenn ich eine Watch hätte.
Und dann so mit der Nase die Watch bedienen.
Das Problem ist, dass man mit der Apple Watch, da braucht man ja eigentlich, wenn du auf Motorrad sitzt, brauchst du ja zwei Hände, weil du musst erstens die Watch so zu dir zeigen und mit der anderen Hand musst du sie bedienen. Das heißt, ich müsste dann freihändig fahren.
Kannst du nicht oder was?
Doch, doch, das geht schon. Aber erstens ist es nicht erlaubt und zweitens ist das auch der Unfallgefährdung. Also das macht es nicht besser so richtig.
Ja, ne, ist da ja so dieser Siri-Bedarf an der Stelle. Ja, aber so Hey Siri sagen geht natürlich auch nicht mit den Earpods, ne?
Jetzt sind wieder tausend Hörer gerade betroffen.
Das muss man ausprobieren, aber so grundsätzlich würde es mich mal interessieren.
Also ich glaube nicht, Hey Siri geht nicht mit den AirPods.
Ja, aber ich will Siri eh nicht benutzen. Okay, Google.
Ja, manch ja gerade, das würde da vielleicht sinnvoll sein.
Ja, wer weiß, vielleicht.
Hey Siri, wie viele Stunden habe ich noch zu leben? Ist mein Organspendeausweis noch gültig?
Also wenn du sagst, Hey Siri, und jetzt bei den Hörern überall die Siris anspringen, dann sag auch immer gleich noch, okay Google, damit die Android-User auch was dazu davon haben.
Genau, Hey Siri, Hallo Alexa.
Das ist Alexa.
Nein, diese Amazon Echo.
Und Cortana müssen wir natürlich auch noch erwähnen.
Ach ja, Cortana, der ganze Mädels-Wildwuchster.
Da gab es doch dieses geile Ding, was jemand mal gemacht hat.
Wo dann auch so Sachen gestellt wurden.
Nee, mit irgendwelchen Kalendereinträgen. Wo Kalendereinträge gemacht hat, der immer dann den jeweils anderen ausgeholt hat. Dann hatte der Telefon da hingelegt, dann hatte er immer so irgendwie, Hey Siri, was hab ich heute zu tun? Und dann, ah, schon geht mein Telefon an. Und Siri kam dann irgendwie mit einem Kalendereintrag, der dann irgendwie Google wieder aufrief, oder Alexa oder so. Und dann haben die sich gegenseitig mal vollgequatscht. Das fand ich irgendwie sehr nett.
Ja, beim Hörer ist jetzt auch gerade die Uhr angesprungen, super.
Ihr seid so Opfer.
Ja, das Siri hab ich auf dem MacBook Pro jetzt ja auch nicht aktiviert.
Fand ich übrigens grad schön, da gab's ja so ein Artikel, wo sich mal jemand, wie ich finde auch zu Recht, darüber markiert hat, dass diese ganzen Assistenten, ja eigentlich überall...
Nicht überall.
In Holland nicht, in den arabischen Ländern auch nicht.
Nur bei Siri ist das so. Bei Alexa, bei Anna, alles andere sind Mädels, und nur bei Siri kann Siri auch ein Mann sein. Ich hab mich dann gefragt, ob Siri eigentlich auch ein Name für Männer ist irgendwo, also das Indische, oder? Siri ist doch ein indischer Name, ne?
Ich glaub, es gibt keine Buchstabenkombinationen unter sechs Buchstaben, die nicht schon irgendwie belegt ist.
Ja, aber so als Vorname... Warte mal, ich guck mal kurz hier. Siri ist weiblicher Vorname.
Ihr sagt ja, der Siri ist kein rein weiblicher Vorname.
Aber ohne Quelle.
Ja, ist er. Ja, streitet euch her.
Hier, spiel mal das Ding bitte. Spiel mal das Ding. Ja, dieses Infinite Looping Siri Alexa. Und wenn mein Spannchen vor unseren Leibhörern passiert.
Ja, das heißt, Siri ist eine skandinavische Nebenform von Sigrid oder eine Variante des finnischen weiblichen Vornamens Siro. Okay, also nix Indien. Wie komm ich denn auf Indien? Finnisch.
Hast du letztens einen Siri-Winderloh gegessen?
Leute, die Siri heißen, Bekannte sind tatsächlich Norwegen, Schweden, Finnland, Amerika, Österreich, Deutsch, Sirinase.
Gibt ja auch ein Land-Siri-Namen, ne?
Suri-Namen heißt das. Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es schon so, dass diese ganzen Assistants so auf das Mädchen dient machen und zumindest ist es halt bei Siri nicht nur konfigurierbar, sondern auch der Default. Also Arabien war das? Wo war das noch? Also arabische Länder?
Ich glaube sogar auch Holland und Frankreich oder Belgien oder so, da war noch irgendwie ein Land.
Ich weiß es gerade nicht.
Clemens, wir haben unsere Hörer völlig fertig gemacht.
Die Leute wissen, was sie da zu Hause haben.
Das Infinite Loop ist doch uralt, oder?
Redest du jetzt mal mit Dreien, glaube ich?
Ja, gut, wenn du möchtest, spiele ich das mal kurz ein.
Hier ist das nächste Event. Hier ist das nächste Event.
Bleibt das so? Oder kommt da noch irgendwie eine andere?
Warte noch, ich meinte doch eigentlich eine andere. Geh doch mal hin zum Ende. Das ist die neue Variante mit drei von den Dingern.
Ich meine mal, wenn ihr bis zum Ende nur dasselbe tun, aber wenn da nicht irgendwas ist, dass ihr richtig durcheinander kommt, ich spule mal kurz vor.
Ja, aber noch viel weiter glaube ich.
Noch weiter? Also wenn es hier noch nicht spannend ist.
Reicht.
Deine Note von heute sagt, Alexa, sag mir, ob ich meine 3 Uhr Abwesendung habe.
Entschuldigung, ich kann die Antwort nicht auf die Frage stellen. Okay, das sind verschiedene Outtakes am Ende noch. Gut, jetzt vermute mal niemand von uns hat sich ein Amazon Echo gekauft oder hat auch nur erwogen, sowas zu kaufen.
Ich weiß nicht mal genau, was das ist.
Die wollen ja jetzt tatsächlich manche Hotels da komplett ihre ganzen Zimmer damit ausstatten und darüber quasi die Fernsteuerung für alles mögliche, so mit Fernseher an und Jalousie hoch und runter und so. Das wird ein totales Desaster. Das wird echt so ein Desaster. Und ich hab auch schon mehrfach...
Mit Hotels im Boot.
Ja, und vor allem, die reagieren halt mittlerweile auch schon auf Botschaften in der Werbung. Das heißt, die Leute lassen ihren Fernseher laufen. Ja, und dann ist die Werbung halt so, dass da Sachen gesagt werden, die dann diese Alexa-Dinger dazu bringen, irgendwas zu kaufen. Also das ist natürlich die geilste Form von Werbung überhaupt, dass du einfach nur noch in den Raum sagen musst, was die ganzen Fernbedienungen zu tun haben.
Die Story war, dass sich irgendein kleines Mädchen über das Alexa von ihren Eltern irgendetwas bestellt hat, irgendeine teure Puppe oder sonst irgendwas. Und das landete dann in den Nachrichten, und der Nachrichtensprecher hatte dann sozusagen nochmal nachgesagt, was die Kleine, die Kleine hat bloß gesagt, hier, order mir eine so und so Puppe, Alexa, order mir eine so und so Puppe. Und bei all den Leuten, wo der Fernseher lief, die so ein Ding zu Hause hatten, das hat dann ein bisschen Ärger gegeben.
Ja genau, das ist das moderne Design, also muss ich gar nicht mehr groß Gedanken darüber machen, was die Leute dazu motivieren könnten, selber was zu kaufen, sondern man gibt einfach direkt die Voice Commands aus dem Fernseher heraus und fertig ist. Alexa, spende 100 Euro an die Freak Show!
Ja!
Bist du sicher?
Sofort?
Ja monatlich!
Das wird wirklich noch, das wird ein totales Ziel.
Aber du kannst jetzt wirklich sowas machen wie hey Siri, mach nen Kalendereintrag für jede Woche, der Freak Show, 10 Euro überweisen und jetzt werden die Leute immerhin erinnert. Eine ganz neue Form des Telemarketing.
Wie heißt das? Seit iOS 10.2.1 lässt sich die Qualität der Siri-Stimme unter Bedienungshilfen, Sprachausgabe, Stimmen verbessern. Warum ist das denn nicht an sich schon gut? Das mach ich mal. Bedienungshilfen, das ist allgemein. Macht man ja so selten. Bedienungshilfen.
Ja, aber wir kommen ja alle langsam in das Alter.
Sprachausgabe, Stimmen, naja. Ach so, verbessern. Man kann dann eine andere Stimme auswählen.
Du musst dann runterladen.
Siri weiblich. Ah, es gibt Siri weiblich und Siri weiblich erweitert.
Kann dann auch Schimpfwörter.
Was heißt denn das? Siri weiblich erweitert.
Da werden halt 30 Gigabyte Sample-Daten auf dein Vorn geladen und hört sich's richtig gut an.
197 Megabyte, das mach ich mal.
Siri Extended Extreme Pro.
Oh man, bist du denn auch weiblich erweitert? Gut, wollen wir ein neues Thema steuern?
Ja, mach mal den Jingle an hier.
Oh Moment, ich ahn's ja schon.
Tim, my Mac.
Na, was gibt's denn heute Schönes?
Ich hab letztens einen großzügigen Spender irgendwie gehabt, der hat mir eine neue CPU gegeben für meinen Mac Pro. Und zwar hatte ich vorher, ich hab ja nur das Single-Modell, du hast ja hier so einen Dual-Slot, wie heißen die Dinger? Xeon. Ich hab ja nur so einen Single-Xeon-Rechner. Und da gehören die Intel Xeons rein, die vorne mit einem W anfangen, weil die Ws sind billiger, weil die sind irgendwie so, dass die halt auch nur in so einen Single-Slot-Rechner reingehen. Die haben sozusagen keinen Support für Multi-CPU-Rechner. Und von diesem W 3680, den ich hab, hab ich jetzt aber einen X 5690 bekommen. Das heißt, das ist also eigentlich eine CPU, die für mehrere Slots da sind. Aber auch, weil es nicht hinten eine 80 ist, sondern eine 90, hat es dann noch mal 133 Megahertz mehr. Alles erst mal noch nicht so spannend, außer dass es jetzt wirklich besser geht in diesem Sockel nicht. Aber mit dieser normalen CPU, die ich vorher hatte, und ich glaube, Pockel hat die auch, W 3680, kannst du maximal, hab ich getestet, 48 Gigabyte in dein Rechner stecken. Und zwar hast du zwar vier Slots, die kann man auch mit 4 x 8 Gigabyte belegen, dann hat man 24, aber wenn man 4 x 16 reinsteckt, weil RAM hab ich auch bekommen, wenn man 4 x 16 Gigabyte reinsteckt, dann bootet die Kiste nicht mehr, dann bleibt da gleich kurz nach dem Anfang irgendwie hängen und dann geht irgendwie nichts. Und bei 3 x 16 tut alles. Kann man sich auch erklären, und zwar diese W-Reihe an CPU, die hat irgendwie 36-Bit-Adress-Range. Und 36-Bit kann man sich ja ausrechnen, 32-Bit sind 4 Gigabyte und dann mal doppelt, mal doppelt, mal doppelt, sind 36, sind eigentlich 64 da, die CPU aber irgendwie nur so Triple-Channel kann und so weiter, ist egal. Jedenfalls, 64 geht auf jeden Fall nicht. Aber dann diese x5690-CPU, das ist ja aus diesen Multi-CPU-Dingens, das sind so CPUs, die tatsächlich so bis 288 Gigabyte können oder sowas. Danach hab ich die in meinen Single-Slot-Rechner reingesteckt, ging erstmal alles, dann wieder das vierte 16-Gigabyte-Modul reingesteckt, was vorher mit der alten CPU nicht geklappt hat, zack und das ging, 64 Gigabyte. Das heißt also, wenn jemand einen Single-Slot rechnet und mal richtig fett Speicher braucht, dann muss er sich diese xCPU besorgen, die kosten inzwischen eigentlich auch nicht mehr viel mehr als diese W-Dinger, weil aus den ganzen Servern, die jetzt abgebaut werden, das sind sowieso alles X-Prozessoren und diese Ws gibt es eigentlich gar nicht so viele, glaube ich. Na dieser 5690 hat halt 3,46 Gigahertz, 5680 hat halt 3,33 Gigahertz, genauso wie die 3680. Also 3680, 5680 sind eigentlich gleich, außer dass halt das X immer dieses Multi-CPU unterstützt und mehr RAM.
Ja, sag mal, man hat nicht so viel Zahlen.
Ja klar, 133 MHz.
Ja, aber es hängt doch nicht nur von Megahertz ab, ich meine, davon sind wir wirklich schon weit entfernt.
Ja, aber das ist der einzige Unterschied an diesen CPU. Ist ja die gleiche Reihe, das gleiche alles, außer dass sie mit mehr Takt klarkommen.
Okay, das heißt, das war jetzt wie viel mehr?
133.
133 was mehr?
Mit dieser CPU könnte man in einen Single-Slot, der eigentlich nur 48 könnte, könnte man sozusagen, wo alle sagen, das ist das Maximum, was diese Kiste kann, es stimmt nicht ganz, das ist nur, wenn man nicht die richtige CPU hat, wenn man diese X-Reihe da reinsetzt, dann könnte man auch 64 machen.
Wie ist das bei meinem Teil?
Na du hast ja einen Dual-Slot-Rechner. Du musst schon X-CPUs haben, weil sonst würde das halt nicht gehen. Weil da braucht man X halt auf jeden Fall für.
Was hab ich denn für eine?
Ob es da steht, steht es da. Warte, ich muss schnell gucken. Im About My Mac steht es auf jeden Fall nicht, wie das Ding genau heißt. Aber in dem anderen steht es auch nicht. Da steht das. Du musst das Geekbench aufmachen. Da steht das.
Steht am Terminal auch.
Oder da vielleicht auch irgendwo.
Aber hier, die X-CPU hat ein better price value als die W-CPU.
Ja, dann ist das aber nur, weil die Preise da gerade komisch sind und so.
Der Xeon X ist bei 233 Dollar und die W bei 350. Also ne, das ist ja der Neupass wahrscheinlich.
Die W ist eigentlich die schlechtere CPU.
Also ich hab ein Intel Xeon E...
5520. Ja, das E ist aber auch von dieser X-Reihe nur so ne Stromspaulern, so ne... so ne Economy-Version. Ich weiß nicht wofür das E genau steht, aber es ist so ne kleinere. Das ist nicht so rechts unten, das ist mehr so links oben. Außerdem hast du halt die 55er-Reihe noch. Du willst eigentlich die 56er-Reihe haben, weil die kann schnelleren Speicher unterstützen und die hat auch schon Hardware-Support für AES und so weiter. Also du willst da eigentlich zwei schickere CPUs reinmachen. Aber zu dem Thema kommen wir gleich erst, da sind wir noch nicht. Da hab ich auch noch was.
Also du hast E5520. Ich bin hier nämlich gerade bei dem...
Also wenn ich nämlich mal hier wirklich irgendwie so nennenswerten Vorteil hätte...
Der grätscht da gerade die ganze Zeit.
Der grätscht, ja.
Das ist reine Rache.
Ja okay, aber ich bin ja noch nicht fertig.
Also deine CPUs auf jeden Fall schnecken langsam.
Wie war das mit dem iPhone 7?
Ja, da ist jetzt, und zwar ist für die Kopfhörer dieses Plastedöse nicht mehr dabei. Funktioniert, ne?
War da jemals ein Plastedöse?
Ja, wo man das so reitecks aufgibt, hat es einen durchsichtigen Deckel und beim 7er ist das einfach nicht mehr.
Also die Xeons.
Dein ist schlecht.
Auf jeden Fall. Kommen wir aber gleich zu, machen wir langsam. Was ich noch festgestellt habe, ich hab mal geguckt, was will man jetzt eigentlich für eine Speicherkonfiguration in seinem Rechner haben? Also was ist schnell? Früher war es ja so, wenn man zwei Module hat, dann kann er dualmäßig zugreifen, dann ist er flotter und so. Bei diesem Xeons, die wir jetzt hier haben, die können Triple Channel, das heißt, wenn du drei Stück reinsetzt, das ist schneller als zwei oder eine, weil das kann er optimal auf drei Speichermodule. Wenn ich drei was reinsetze? Dann kann er auf drei gleichzeitig zugreifen, dann ist das richtig flott. Aber wenn du das vierte Modul reinsetzt, das vierte ist dann wieder Single Speed, auf das vierte kann er nur alleine zugreifen und dann kriegst du bei diesen Benchmarks immer nur so eine Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit. Das heißt, wenn du das optimalst an Memory Bandwidth aus deinem Rechner rausholen willst, dann willst du eigentlich drei Speichermodule haben. Davon mal abgesehen, wenn du die richtige Menge schon hast. Also Bandwidth ist nicht so entscheidend, wenn du nicht genug speicherst. Also man sollte nicht Speicher opfern, nur um das Perfekte zu kriegen.
Was heißt drei Module? Das Ding hat doch irgendwie...
Vier.
Vier Slots. Du hast zweimal vier, weil du ja zwei CPUs hast. Das hat pro CPU vier Slots.
So.
Und weil der edle Spender, weil der richtig großzügig war, habe ich hier für Huckel dreimal acht Gigabyte und für dich sechs Mal. Ich war richtig fies.
Warte mal, sechs Mal acht?
48.
Und du hast nur 32, hast du mir mal gesagt. Ich hätte auch vier Mal acht mitbringen können, also für dich zweimal vier Mal acht, aber dann wäre das Bandwagon nicht so gut gewesen und ich habe jetzt einfach mal gedacht, wir machen das jetzt mal richtig. Und wir müssen bedenken, mehr Speicher, also Speicher verbraucht auch richtig Strom, also einfach sinnlos jetzt irgendwie die Kiste mit Speicher vollzuhauen macht nicht so Sinn. Und deine 32 Giga, hast du schon mal ausgenutzt? Komplett?
Ja, vielleicht etwas übertrieben, aber ich meine, wenn ich bei meinen Freunden auf dem Spielplatz sagen kann, dass ich jetzt 48 GB habe, kann ich natürlich...
Erstmal haben wir ein Stück mit weg sein. Und wenn es nur so nebenbei 48 G sind, fehlen aktuellen Server ein Schiss.
Das sind ja keine Server, das sind Desktop Stations.
Die steht aber bei dir an deinem Desk.
Aber Tim, du hast immer noch die Gammel-CPUs. Wir sind ja noch nicht fertig.
Wir sind ja noch nicht fertig. Heute holt er gleich die CPUs aus der Tasche.
Nee, leider nicht.
Ich sehe jetzt schon Weihnachten.
Aber also für deine CPU zum Beispiel.
Wie geil, guck mal, wie Tim sich über alte Hardware freuen kann.
Hör auf diesen Podcast!
Dann weißt du, was du zu tun hast.
Das ist wirklich geil, oder? Das Problem an diesem Speicher ist, für dich zumindest, deine CPU kann den gar nicht. Die kann den schon, aber nur mit 1033 Mhz Modus, oder wie auch immer das heißt. Die neuere CPU kann aber 1033. Die kann diesen Speicher viel, viel schneller ansprechen, weil der Memory-Controller nämlich in der CPU drin ist.
Derzeit habe ich 1066.
Oder war es 1066, genau. Wenn du die CPU wechselst und eine richtige reinmachst, dann wird auch dein Speicher gleich schneller, weil der den dann ansprechen kann, so wie sich das gehört. Das ist nämlich schneller Speicher. So, und jetzt kommt's, pass auf. Du hast ja hier von der Hardware her einen 4,1. Das sind zwar bei BIOS auf 5.1 aufgerüstet, aber der 4.1 wurde halt mit einem CPU-Board ausgeliefert, wo Xeons drin sind, die keinen Head-Spreader mehr haben.
Head-Spreader wollte ich gerade sagen.
Bei den 5.1er ist das schon mit Head-Spreader. Die können einfach die CPU rausnehmen, sich die Neue reinsetzen, weil Intel verkauft die immer mit Head-Spreader. Das geht bei dem 4.1er nicht. Aber jetzt habe ich letztens so ein Video gesehen.
Der packt.
Schlegst du ihm immer in den Magen, und dann gibt's oben noch mal Leckerlein. Genau, Zuckerbrot und Peitsche.
Die Probleme erklären und dann die Lösung dazu. So, da gibt's so einen Typen. Also es gibt so Services, wo man sich irgendwie die CPU hinschicken kann. Und dann machen die da wie auch immer im Ofen oder wie auch immer diesen Metalldeckel da abkriegen, weil der muss halt weg. Muss man halt viel Geld bezahlen dafür, dass die das machen. Und deswegen rüsten viele ihren alten 4.1er nicht auf, weil man kriegt diese CPUs nicht so einfach, außer man zahlt richtig viel Geld. So und jetzt gibt's so ein Video. Hab ich jetzt leider mir gar nicht gemerkt, wo das ist, aber ich erzähl die Story einfach, weil man braucht das Video nicht. Da gibt's so einen Typen, der packt die CPU in einen Schraubstock. Und zwar auf der einen Seite mit der Plastikkante und auf der anderen Seite aber mit der Kante von diesem Heat-Spreader. Sodass er sozusagen seitwärts auf der CPU verschoben wird. Und der ist festgelötet. Und da gibt er so Druck drauf, bis das Teil bang macht und der Heat-Spreader einfach so wegfliegt. Die CPU könnte eventuell auch wegfliegen, aber da macht man halt ein Handtuch drum, dass das nicht passiert.
Das wäre so ein CPU-Spreader im Zweifelsfall.
Das ist ja nicht so schlimm, weil die CPU, das Die ist ja auf diesem Stück Platin oder Hartplastik oder was auch. Ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Ja, irgendwie so ein hartes Zeug. Das kann sein, dass das ein bisschen Druck abkriegt, aber das kommt ja auf dem Die selbst eigentlich gar nicht an, dieser Druck. So. Und damit kann man halt prima diesen Heat-Spreader von dieser CPU runterkriegen. Dann macht man einmal bang, bang und der hat das gemacht, hat das in sein Rechen eingebaut, bang, hat funktioniert und alles war super. Das heißt, du kannst dir jetzt, ich hab ein bisschen geforscht, du kannst dir entweder zweimal diese rechts unten CPU kaufen, diese X5690. Hoke, weißt du noch in dem Laden, was hast du bezahlt bei diesem MacFactory?
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Gar nicht mehr?
Aber für die W waren es sehr wenig.
Die W sind ja billig, die X kostet halt ein bisschen. Also die ganz rechts unten wird ein bisschen teuer, aber ich hab mal geguckt, du könntest dir also locker für so um die 100 Euro 2 X56 irgendwas CPUs holen, die dann auch ersten 6 Cores haben, weil deine haben jeweils nur 4 Cores. Die unterstützen den schnellen RAM. Du würdest AES Hardware Support kriegen und noch mehr Megahertz als deine lahmen Dinger da haben. Und das alles wahrscheinlich für so um die 200 Euro. Dann hättest du da wirklich eine Turbo-Rakete unter deinem Tisch.
Und das auch noch mal mit Hyperthreading. Das heißt ich hab so 224 Cores.
Hier, Tim, klick mal auf den Link da. Das ist der Laden in Berlin, wo ich die 10PU gekauft hab. Und da siehst du, was die gerade so aufrufen. Die machen natürlich jetzt auch nicht die aller eBay-Xten-Preise dafür. Aber es fängt Economy Class an für die 2,0 noch irgendwas. Aber wenn du weiter runter scrollst, kriegst du die Top-of-the-Line-Modelle. Die sind dann allerdings...
Ja, die kosten aber schon ein bisschen. Das kriegt man auch billiger hin. Vor allem diesen 5690, das geht besser. Mein Favorit ist ja eigentlich hier so ein bisschen diese hier.
Ich meine, wir reden hier von dem Unterschied von 3,3 auf 3,46 Gigahertz. Da verdoppelt sich fast der Preis.
Der kam ein Jahr später als die anderen. Dann haben sie es nochmal nachgeschoben bei Intel. Der hat auch schon über 3 Gigahertz, aber es hat halt auch nur 95 Watt TDP. Die haben da alle 130. Also der wird auch nicht ganz so heiß und verbraucht nicht so viel Strom. Die ist so ein bisschen besser. Deswegen finde ich den nicht schlecht.
Wir reden von dem X 5675 in diesem Fall.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen mit dem Preis übertrieben. Wärst du bei 280 Euro?
280 Euro für 1,6 Gigahertz mehr Wumms insgesamt.
Mehr RAM.
Und der Prozessor ist auch schneller als der, den ich habe, nicht nur weil er höher getaktet ist. Oder ist er eigentlich immer noch dieselbe?
Das kann ich dir nicht so genau sagen, wie das im Vergleich mit gleicher Megahertz aussieht. Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Aber er hat ja 6 Cores, du hast ja nur 4.
Also CPU Bench sagt auf jeden Fall, die sind deutlich schneller als deine. Und du hast keine Spar-CPU.
Wie gesagt, dein Speicher wird automatisch schneller, weil der halt den mit 333 Takten kann. Du hast AES und Hardware. Das heißt, wenn du da Krypto-Platte hast, zum Beispiel, dann wird deine CPU ordentlich entlastet. Da verbraucht er fast gar nichts mehr an CPU, wenn du auf deine Platte zugreifst. Und all so ein Zeug.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob unsere CPUs überhaupt noch supported sind mit dem nächsten Mac OS. Habt ihr ganze Spaß?
Ja, deine Kiste ja. Hast du jetzt eigentlich da Sierra? Ok, weil wir ja schon das 5.1.er BIOS da eingespielt haben.
Genau, das geht.
Weil es da sein kann, also auch wegen der CPU.
Eigentlich müssen sie die Mac Pros noch für die nächsten zehn Jahre supporten, solange sie keine neuen Rechner mehr in dem Segment vorstellen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was sie da so vorhaben. Das war auf jeden Fall immer, dass man diesen Heatspreader nicht so easy wegkriegt. Das war immer so ein Problem für den 4-1er, den aufzurüsten. Beim 5-1er, die hatten Glück, da haben die das schon bei Apple nicht mehr gemacht, aber bei dem schon.
Mein Lieblings-Bastelschraubstock ist ja auch von Proxxon, den kannst du dir dann gleich dazuklicken.
Und der meinte, man muss das möglichst, da gibt es auch Video-Zugehörer, kann man irgendwie suchen, aber du musst das wirklich so einspannen, dass die Kraft von dem Schraubstock wirklich, also der Chip darf nicht so schräg, natürlich im Schraubstock, wirklich gerade so, dass die Kraft wirklich von der Seite kommt.
Diese Maßnahmen muss ich jetzt noch machen. Heat-Sprayler.
Dieser Metalldeckel, den du hier siehst auf der CPU, der muss da runter. Da drunter ist eigentlich nur so eine kleine Dive-Fläche, wo diese so richtig aalglatt und spiegelig ist. Und das ist einfach nur ein Metalldeckel. Und der muss weg, weil Apple den 4i halt ohne diesen Deckel... Die haben die CPU ohne Deckel verbaut, haben die sich von Intel so geben lassen, weil dann nämlich auch die Kühlung ein bisschen besser ist, wenn man das ohne diesen Deckel macht, wenn man da direkt drauf geht. Der normale User, der macht aber vielleicht zu viel kaputt oder wie auch immer, der will da eine größere Fläche haben oder was auch immer, warum die das machen.
Bei der neuen CPU muss ich den Deckel von der CPU abschlagen, wenn ich den da reinbaue, was genau?
Damit dann die Hits hängst und alles da passt.
Weil deine CPUs, die haben den schon weg sozusagen und damit du das eins zu eins tauschen kannst, ohne dass du irgendwie das...
Ja, aber an welcher Stelle tausche ich denn die CPU? Also ich ziehe wirklich nur die CPU raus und sitze die auf dasselbe Board.
Genau.
Die Dinger kommen jetzt nicht mit Trägerboard oder so.
Du kriegst nur die CPUs so, wie die da auf diesem Bild ist. Also ja, Tim hat jetzt hier das Bild davon von MacFactory. Aber du machst diesen Heat-Spreader ab, baust bei dir den Kühlkörper ab von deinem CPU-Board. Oder ja, das ist ein, sind das zwei. Bei dir sind das zwei große Kühlkörper, du baust die irgendwie ab. Machst du da mit so einem Hebel, machst du diesen Deckel da auf, nimmst die CPU raus, steckst sie neu rein, machst den Deckel wieder zu, sauber machen, Kühlpaste drauf.
Also der CPU tauscht an sich, wenn du den Heat-Spreader mal entfernt hast, der ist dann super trivial.
Hat Huckel auch gemacht, hat wie lange gedauert? Viertelstunde, oder?
Weniger.
Wie hast du das Ding da abgemacht?
Naja, bei den Single-Core ist das auch nicht. Also ist nur der 4-1-er Dual-Slot, die haben das Problem, alle anderen nicht. Deswegen ist der Tipp ja auch sozusagen eigentlich speziell für dich.
Du musst jetzt durch. Diese reife Prüfung musst du über dich hergehen lassen.
Achso, Jungs, ich hätte gerne eure 4-Gigabyte-Module zurück, ne? Wir sammeln die und kommt in die Kiste.
Ja, ich kann die ja jetzt noch nicht reinstecken.
Ne, doch, die gehen schon. Die werden nur nicht ausgenutzt von dem schnelleren Speed. Die laufen dann auf 1000, was hast du gesagt, 66.
Aber wenn ich die da jetzt reinstecke, dann hab ich auch erst mal nur 32 Gigabyte.
Ne, du hast ja X-CPUs, die können schon noch mehr. Das ist nur diese W-Dinger.
Ich hab da 48, aber es wird nicht schneller auf sie zugegriffen, aber ich hab dann mehr RAM.
Ähm, was, teig mal noch mal hier das Workiflow. Wie war da noch, um was? Nee, ne? Ähm, ja hier, das gibt auch, das hab ich auch gesehen, so ein drei, ja ne drei Stunden waren es nicht, aber so eine Stunde, so ein Video von so zwei Japanern, die so ein Gerät vorführen, wo du deine CPU halt reinsetzt und von der Seite so ein Ding kommt und den Heatspreader halt so wegdrückt. Das hat eine Stunde haben die dieses Device vorgeführt. Das war unglaublich, die haben so eine Art Mini-Konferenz gemacht, da saßen auch so 20 Zuschauer, das war wirklich witzig, aber also die haben sich da ausgelassen an diesem Thema.
Und die anderen haben es einfach mit dem Schraubstock gemacht, geil.
Ja, das ist ja auch so eine Art Schraubstock, nur dass die halt sich so ein gefrästes Aluteil machen und so weit, wo alles ein bisschen vorbereitet ist.
Ich meine, wenn aber jetzt bei diesen CPUs, was ist denn das, was da drauf ist? Das ist doch im Prinzip auch ein Hitzeverteiler.
Ja, aber der ist ineffektiv, warum soll man noch eine Stufe dazwischen machen, wenn man doch gleich zum Kühlkörper gehen könnte. Ich weiß nicht, warum die das, was die wahren Gründe beendet sind, warum die das machen.
Ja, aber was würde denn passieren, wenn ich das Ding jetzt nicht da abtrenne?
Nein, dann hast du einen Millimeter mehr zwischen CPU und Kühlkörper und der Kühlkörper wird halt perfekt da mit so einer Fassung, wird der da drauf gesetzt und wenn du den dann anziehst, dann haust du da einen Druck drauf, weil diese einen Millimeter da im Weg sind. Und da gibt's Leute, die machen das und wissen dann genau, ja, dann darfst du anstatt 10 Umdrehungen von der Schraube darfst du nur 6,3 und der andere sagt, nee, aber mach 6,8. Also dann hast du so einen Voodoo-Wert, an wie weit man die Schrauben jetzt anziehen darf und damit man das alles irgendwie nicht hat und so weiter und weil sonst auch die, also der Kühlkörper ist ja dann einen Millimeter höher und der hat ja so einen Steckverbinder, da ist ja ein Lüfter drin, ein Steckverbinder für den Lüfter, der ist dann auch nicht richtig drin, weil der ist ja dann auch einen Millimeter höher, dann sitzt das nicht so richtig und so weiter.
Also Tim macht den Heat-Spreader ab.
Er macht den Heat-Spreader ab und wenn das klappt, dann hast du für ewig Ruhe und dann ist alles richtig. Wenn das schief geht, ist halt Risiko. Aber ich hab so ein Forum gelesen, da haben alle gesagt, ja das war so easy und das ist viel Druck, die man da anwirkt. Man macht es halt sprengen, man muss so ein Handtuch drum machen, damit die CPU nicht wegfliegt, weil das löst sich ja dann. Aber das ist irgendwie ganz easy und da hat kein einziger geschrieben, er hat sich seine CPU geschrottet. Also alle sagen, ja, voll easy, geiler Tipp und funktioniert. Du siehst da nichts, außer dass du einen Typen und eine CPU da reinlegst und ich drehe, du denkst, oh meine Fresse, der gibt aber ganz schön Druck und du immer machst halt so springen und dann gibt er den Tipp, dass man das halt festhalten soll.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich habe kürzlich den Schraubstock als wertvolles Werkzeug im Arsenal kennengelernt für auch andere Tätigkeiten, wo man sonst irgendwie nicht genau weiß, wie man jetzt gerade viel Druck auf sowas applizieren kann.
Ja und vor allem kannst du wirklich fein dosieren durch den Hebeln, einfach immer ein bisschen mehr und dich übertreiben schön langsam. Nichts mal so machen, sondern schon immer mehr geben, bis es halt immer so bing!
Und dir ins Auge pflegt und du erblindest.
Und man kann bestimmt noch, kommt die nächste bestimmt auch, dann kommen Tipps so von Leuten, ja, wenn du das mit dem Föhn noch schön warm machst, dann geht es ein bisschen besser und so und ich denke mal, Wärme könnte ein bisschen helfen. Ich würde jetzt nicht gleich mit dem Heizföhn draufhalten, weil dann kannst du es ja gleich ablöten, aber...
Ein bisschen Chili-Sauce drauf machen.
Und was einer noch meinte, was nicht schlecht wäre, ist, wenn man erst mal mit einer schrottigen CPU übt. Das heißt, du könntest mit deiner Alten, könntest du erst mal üben.
Aber bei der Alten ist ja kein Deckel drauf.
Ja, das stimmt bei ihm nicht, ja, hast recht.
Du könntest meine Alte haben.
Ja, oder meine Alte.
Zum Headspreaden des Heatspreaders.
Ich hab glaub ich eine W3540 noch oder sowas.
Heatspreader Splatter Movie.
Oder du kaufst dir hier so ein Gerät, aber das kostet wahrscheinlich auch richtig Geld und machst das damit.
Schraubstock. Live aus der Medie-Ebene.
Ich meine, für irgendwas muss ja die Wall-of-Schul-Zeit gut gewesen sein. Mit Schraubstocken kannst du umgehen. Gut, damit können wir jetzt aber das Segment erstmal beschließen.
Ne, zeigst du nochmal das Workiflow, was hab ich da geschrieben? Speicher, Zipoo, Treppelspeed haben wir gesagt. Ja, alles fertig.
Na super. So, jetzt können wir Clemens ja nochmal ausgraben.
Wir sind weit hinter. Ich wollte nochmal wieder meine übliche halbjährliche, dreivierteljährliche Auskratzerrei vorbringen.
Warum haben wir dafür noch keinen Jingle?
Ja, weil mir geht das echt auf den Sack, dass Apple immer mehr kaputt macht. Also nochmal, das ist eine Sache, wenn Apple sagt, wir machen mal was Neues, wir machen hier ein Beta-Programm und dann nehmen da Leute teil und dann gehen da Sachen nicht, das finde ich vollkommen legitim. Was ich echt scheiße finde, ist, dass Apple immer häufiger dazu greift, irgendetwas wegzumachen, was sie so haben, von ihrem, egal, ob das Hardware ist, Software, Schnittstellen, sonst irgendwas, um nicht zu sagen, ja hier ist der neue Scheiß, aber er ist leider auch noch nicht ganz ausgegoren. Ok, das sahen sie nicht, aber das finden sofort die ersten User aus. Und Apple hat so in letzter Zeit so ein paar Sachen gebracht, hat, benutzt irgendjemand von euch diese komische TV-App? TV-App? Die sie jetzt... Nee, die jetzt für IOS drauf ist, statt der Video-App. Früher gab es unter IOS eine Video-App.
Wie was?
Ja, jetzt gibt es eine TV-App.
Die auf dem iPhone?
Wirklich? Offensichtlich benutzt du sie nicht. Versteh ich auch, weil sie ist komplett unbenutzbar. Schon das Video-Ding... Moment, Moment, Moment. Das Video-Ding war grenzwertig.
Ich hab ja nach wie vor Videos, ich weiß nicht, wovon du redest.
Ja, Video gibt's nicht mehr. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht hab ich ja neuere iOS als alle anderen.
Nur kommen da keine Videos hoch, sondern da will irgendwas mit meinem...
Die Ab heißt jetzt TV.
Was? Was ist denn an deinem iOS anders als an meinem?
Ich weiß nicht, ich mach kein Beta und kein Blub, kein Lalalala, vielleicht hast du ja wieder neuen Scheiß drauf, das wir wieder weggemacht haben. Ich dachte TV gäb's nur auf Apple TV. Ich hab hier ein ganz normales, 10-2-1 hab ich.
Hab ich nicht.
Ich versuchte gerade zu erklären, aber ich hab das auch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wo du das her hast. Vielleicht spielt ihr ja keine Sachen aus dem iTunes Store ab, aber ich lade Sachen aus dem iTunes Store ab.
Nicht aus dem iPhone auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ah, ich benutze, mein Telefon steht auf Nordamerikanisch, damit das Apple Pay funktioniert. Kann jetzt sein, dass das deswegen nicht bei euch? Okay, oder ist das deswegen?
Ziemlich wahrscheinlich sogar.
Er spricht zwar Deutsch mit mir und alles, aber steht sozusagen in der Region, in der Region steht es auf Nordamerika. Jedenfalls ist dort die Video-Up weg. Die war auch schon scheiße, aber jetzt diese TV-Up ist wirklich der letzte Dreck. Und ich gucke ja, gibt's ja schon seit Monaten oder Jahren immer wieder zu, gibt's so bestimmte Fernsehserien, die ich gucke. Die gucke ich halt über iTunes, iTunes Store. Und auch das war schon immer, ja, so die alte Video-Up hast du noch drauf, ja, auch das war immer grenzwertig, allein von der Usability, dass man jetzt einfach mal so nächste Folge gucken geht ja nicht, ne? Du musst ja dann immer wieder zurück in den iTunes Store und dann musst du eben wieder die Serie suchen und dann, nein, du willst nicht die Season One gucken, sondern in der Season 7 und dann guckst du hinten, ach ja, wir stehen ja schon wieder auf HD, also schaltest du wieder um auf SD und lädst dir dann das Ding, also klickst das an und wenn du Glück hast, kannst du dann das Ding irgendwann spielen auf der Video-Up. Das ist aber jetzt noch kaputter geworden mit dieser TV-Up. Also das geht so gar nicht. Sagt andauernd, kann nicht, will nicht, kennt die Folgen nicht mehr und also wirklich katastrophal. Ich verstehe nicht, wie Apple damit auch nur einen Cent machen kann. Hatten wir ja schon mal diese Thema auch, dass ich nicht verstehe, warum dieses iTunes von Mal zu Mal immer schlechter wird, obwohl sie angeblich mit den Medien so viel Geld verdienen, die sie da drunter haben. Okay, das will ich jetzt nicht mal wiederholen, aber wie gesagt, TV-Up, das wird auch euch wiederfahren. Keine Ahnung, das ist jetzt nicht so ein Thema, das ist ewig.
Kann uns erstmal noch nicht passieren.
Na ja, das wird...
Ich kauf auch überhaupt nichts im iTunes-Store, weil dann kann ich halt die Videos nicht angucken.
Ja, auch das schlägst vom Prinzip in dieselbe Kerbe. Ich kann mir die angucken, allerdings nur mit Schmerzen.
Ich hab das einmal gemacht, weil ich hier in der Metaebene auf dem Beamer was angucken wollte. Und dann weißt du auch schon, was passiert ist?
Ja, der sagt, dein Beamer ist aber nicht Copyright. Tralala, komplett, fuck you und geh weg.
Dann hab ich gesagt...
Ich hatte letztens den Fall, ich hab mir einen Film ausgeliehen, weil ich dachte, okay, ich probier's mal wieder.
Ja, so alle paar Jahre.
Alle paar Jahre, man kann's ja mal wieder probieren. Film war da, gab's in Englisch. Super gab's wahlweise sogar mit Subtitles. Klick also auf Line. Auf Line, also Rent.
Nicht Löwe, sondern...
Und denk mir so, ach, Moment, jetzt hab ich es aber auf meinem Mac Pro geliehen, aber es hat ja noch nicht runtergeladen. Kann ich jetzt ja einfach auf dem MacBook Pro angucken, ne? Ja, nee, geht aber nicht. Du kannst das nur auf dem Gerät gucken, wo du es ausgeliehen hast, obwohl du überall mit deiner Apple ID eingeloggt bist und alles in SYNC, ne? Alles klar, was hab ich wieder gemacht? Dann doch der Torrent gestartet, weil bezahlt hab ich jetzt ja einmal offiziell die Strafgebühr quasi für den Versuch. Und jetzt hab ich mich auch nicht schlecht gefühlt, dann das Torrent anzuwerfen, um den Film schneller, höher, weiter, besser dann in gewünschten Formaten auf gewünschten Geräten anzuschauen.
Ja, ist eine uralte Story, wahrscheinlich auch total langweilig für unsere Zuhörer, aber trotzdem, einmal im Jahr muss man es immer wieder sagen, das Problem ist immer noch da und das geht nicht weg, das wird immer schlimmer. Und was mich jetzt auch echt wieder geärgert hat, ist, ich hab jetzt aus dem Urlaub sehr viel fotografiert mit dem iPhone, das hat eigentlich recht gut funktioniert, auch so diese Chairing und man beamt das dann mal rüber, über diesen Air-Drop oder so auf ein anderes Ding oder auf ein Pad, weil ich war jetzt im Urlaub eigentlich nur mit Telefon und Pad unterwegs, das ist eigentlich alles so ganz okay. Auch die Photo-Up unter iOS ist einigermaßen brauchbar, also es erzeugt keine schweren Schmerzen. Hingegen die Photo-Up, die einem ja zwangsweise unter OSX auf oder Mac OS aufgedrückt wurde, wo einfach mal von einem Tag aufs andere der Detail-Foto getötet wurde, jetzt hast du diese tolle Photo-Up, auch die ist ein unglaublicher Dreck. Ich hab dann mal so versucht jetzt nach dieser Reise mal meinem Vater so eine kleine Diashow zu präsentieren, wie man das so früher machte, so Leinwand aus dem Keller gekramt, Bima aus irgendeiner Firma mitgenommen, machen jetzt mal so ein bisschen Essen dazu und dann Tele-Gebäck-Ständer und so. Und jetzt machen wir mal so den Horror, den man so früher mal so hatte, Leute kommen aus dem Urlaub wieder und zeigen Dias und so. Boah, war das scheiße auf dem Mac aus! Dann machst du ja mal plötzlich Bilder, die auf dem Kopf stehen, dann machst du einmal links, einmal rechts, steht das richtig rum. Oder auch nicht, oder dann hast du drei Viertel von dem Bild, die sind dann überlagert von der einen Hälfte des Bildes. Du kriegst auch keine Diashow hin, die nicht, die keine Musik spielt. Geht nicht. Okay, jetzt kommen wir die Schlaumer, die sagen, ich kann dir ja ein Musikstück reinladen, was aus einer Minute Silence besteht. Aber ich weiß, dass es alle Dinge gibt, um dazu umzugehen. Am Ende des Tages hab ich es auf meinem iPad mit dem HDMI-Adapter vom iPad gezeigt. Und jetzt will ich nicht sagen, oh, das ist eine schlimme Software. Mich daran sehr erregt ist, das hat alles mal funktioniert. iPhoto war eine relativ brauchbare Software, mit der man all diese Sachen machen konnte und das einfach auch gut funktioniert hat. So Vollbild zum Beispiel, allein mit diesem Fotoprogramm mal eine Vollbilddarstellung zu machen, war schon so ein Film. Und das hat alles funktioniert in der iPhoto und das wird halt einfach den Leuten unter der Nase weggepfiffen. Und ja, wir schneiden jetzt hier einen alten Zopf ab und vielleicht irgendwann wachsen mal wieder Haare. Und das kommt so häufig vor bei Apple, dass mich das echt ärgert jetzt inzwischen. Ich spreche jetzt voll im Anwendermodus. Ich bin jetzt nicht der Nerd, der sich das immer irgendwie wieder hinfixed.
Man muss nur den Heatspreader absprengen.
Das sind so Sachen. Und dann guckt mal halt doch mal, schon allein irgendwie aus DAFGE, mal rechts und mal links und stellt fest, ach guck mal, andere Betriebssysteme können ja inzwischen auch Fotos darstellen. Die ziehen alle einfach an Apple vorbei und seit und nur mit so simplen Sachen wie Stabilität. Dass das einfach geht. Jetzt ohne Flick Flack, ohne Gesichtserkennung mit Emoticon-Generierung. Das ist nicht, was Apple da für einen Scheiß macht. Aber einfach diese Grundfunktionalitäten, die gehen dann einfach. Ich hatte jetzt in Neuseeland einen Nexus 5X dabei. So ein Feldwald- und Wiesen-Entreue-Telefon von Google. Funktioniert tadellos zuverlässig. Batterie hält dreimal so lange wie die von meinem 6S. Geile Display und Kosten drittel. Wie gesagt, Kosten sind mir normalerweise egal, weil ich habe mein iPhone lieb, aber ähnlich wie du, wo du sagst, du sitzt das jetzt aus, so eine Generation. Also ich hab momentan keinen Bock auf iPhone 7 oder 8 oder 9.
Aber das 6S hat doch auch so ein, gibt's da nicht gerade so ein Batterieaustauschprogramm?
Ja, mir ist es bisher in der Kälte noch nicht ausgegangen. Deswegen hatte ich jetzt bisher noch keinen Andrang, da hinzugehen. Trotzdem, das finde ich halt einfach denn auch, ja. Ich prangere das an, dass die Qualität da nachlässt, dass die Software Qualität nachlässt und dass sie halt immer wieder dieses Spiel machen, mit wir schneiden was ab und irgendwann wachsen mal wieder Haare dazu. Ich meine, es wäre okay gewesen, wenn sie sagen, wir haben jetzt dieses Fotoprogramm, das ist kompatibel oder sieht kompatibler aus zudem unter IOS. Das geben wir euch jetzt mal und in zwei Jahren schießen wir dann mal iPhoto weg. Aber dieses brutale Abschneiden der Zöpfe war irgendwann mal lustig, aber wird jetzt zunehmend annoying.
Also zum Thema Fotokutzen?
Das ist meine Cursatasten sozusagen.
Ich fand iPhoto auch schon immer unwürdig. Also das ist zum Beispiel ein Programm auf dem Windows. Ich hab ja eine Zeit lang so ein Gamer-Computer in Schulzeiten gehabt, dass ich mir nicht einen neuen Mac leisten konnte. Und da hatte ich dann dieses, hieß es tatsächlich, AC-DC. Das war so Foto-Betrachtungs- und irgendwie Katalogisiersoftware, wie ich das mir vorgestellt hab. Das hat performt ohne Ende, da kommt auch diese ganze Adobe Bridge und was auch immer Kram einfach nicht ran. Und dieses Tool hätte ich eigentlich gerne. Aber gibt es ja nicht auf dem Mac, glaube ich. Vielleicht gibt es das mittlerweile auf dem Mac, wer weiß. Ich benutze auf dem Mac immer Image-Capture, weil da kriegst du auch die RAWs runter und nicht nur die, die die Foto-App kennt oder so. Du kannst sagen, wo die hingehen, ob die gelöscht werden, soll man importieren oder nicht.
Man kann auch aus dem iPhone RAWs runterladen?
Also, Moment, jetzt bin ich, Moment, ich glaube auch beim iPhone, aber auch von anderen Kameras.
Aber das iPhone erzeugt doch gar keine RAWs.
Nicht?
Nee, das würde ja Speicherkosten, bis der Arzt kommt. Wenn du die nicht mit den iPhone-Foto-Tools runterladen kannst, das wäre ja Speichernutzung.
Ich bin mir grad nicht sicher, ob es bei dem...
Doch, die iPhones, also die iPhone 7 definitiv. Da gibt's doch jetzt explizit RAW sogar zum... Also da gibt's RAW, da war was mit RAW.
Wie auch immer, du kannst halt... Ich hatte das auch schon mit anderen Kameras, dass die Foto-App mir nur die JPEGs irgendwie runtergeladen hat beziehungsweise du nicht gesehen hast, sind das jetzt RAWs oder wo sind die?
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin später dann auch umgestiegen von iPhoto auf Aperture, weil ich eben solche Sachen haben wollte. Aber das ist ja auch genau so.
Deswegen Image-Capture benutze ich seit eh und hier, um die Fotos erstmal runde zu laden und dahin zu speichern, wo ich sie gerne hätte und welche und was damit danach passieren soll auf dem Device und dann halt ja Preview oder... Also so die richtigen Pur-Mens-Fotobetrachtungs-Mittelweise, mit diesen iPhoto-Foto-Apps.
Fullscreen und wenn ich Leertast bedrücke oder Cursor rechts, bitte das nächste Bild. So simpel bitte, ja.
Ja, ich weiß, ich kenne diesen Schmerz.
Also das ist sozusagen meine Cursor-Taste. Und eben geht nicht darum, dass Apple das neu erfindet und dabei stolpert, sondern dass sie das alles schon mal konnten. Und dass sie das kaputt gemacht haben, aus irgendwelchen wusseligen politischen Marketinggründen. Das kann man mal machen, aber Apple macht das andauernd. Und ich hab auch überhaupt keine Lust auf diese neuen Laptops mit all euren Sorgen, die ihr da habt. Ich hab echte Sorgen. Mein MacBook Pro ist von 2010. Das läuft hervorragend. Und ich hab jetzt hier noch irgendwo mal ein altes RGR ab, das benutze ich jetzt auf Reisen. Aber wenn die Dinger kaputt gehen, dann hab ich ein echtes Problem.
Die gibt's noch lange gebraucht. Du kriegst diese Generation wirst du noch in zwei Jahren, noch in drei Jahren auf ebay bekommen.
Problem ist nur, du wirst teilweise die gar nicht mehr bespielen können, weil wenn du die denn gebraucht kriegst, dann haben die irgendeine Betriebssystemversion, die du aktuell nicht mehr benutzen kannst. Und die neuen kriegst du nicht mehr drauf, weil du dann irgendwelche Zwischenschritte brauchst, die du nicht hastet. Du kannst das alte nicht mehr runterladen, dann kannst du jetzt 10 oder 10 oder so was nicht mehr runterladen.
Den Fall hatte ich auch, aber das kann man lösen.
Ja, aber das ist halt ein Schmerz.
Das ist ein kleiner Schmerz, aber das ist ja nun ein überwindbarer Schmerz.
Ja, hoffen wir das mal. Aber ich finde das sehr ärgerlich. Insgesamt war ich immer so ein treuer Apple-Benutzer, weil ich jemand bin, der das gerne benutzen möchte. Also so anmachen und auf und zu klappen und geht einfach. Das war ja auch mal das große Argument von Apple. Aber das machen die zunehmend schwerer, weil sie immer mehr kaputt machen. Und zwar nicht deswegen, weil es die großen bösen Hacker kommen, die ihnen das Ding zerhacken oder sonst was. Das macht Apple selber. Apple zündet sich selber dort den Arsch an. Oder seinen Usern. Und das finde ich in zunehmendem Maße doch bedenklich. Und mit dem Telefon, wie gesagt, ich mag mein iPhone 6s sehr gern. Ich nutze das täglich, hab das andauernd in der Hand, wie wir alle. Mache da so meinen ganzen Kram damit. Aber wenn das aus irgendwelchen Gründen mal wegfällt, dann hab ich Sorgen.
Ja, das ist übrigens ein interessantes Nebenthema, weil ich hatte das nämlich neulich auch. Ich hatte einen, was war das? Das war ein iMac, Generation 2009.
Neun.
Sieben, glaube ich, oder acht. Acht, sieben, acht, sieben, eins von beiden. Auf jeden Fall maximale unterstützte US-Versionen ist die 10.11 gewesen.
Jetzt ist ja immerhin noch was. Da kommst du ja noch einigermaßen dran.
Ja, aber jetzt ist die Kiste platt. Also da war ein 10.5, glaube ich, drauf. 10.5 hatte noch keinen App Store. Also du konntest noch nicht mal überhaupt auf den App Store zugreifen, um zum Beispiel den Installer herunterzuladen.
Ja, du kannst jetzt eigentlich heutzutage nur noch, wenn du nicht selber als Image noch hast, kannst du nur mit Twitter rumbetteln, ob die noch jemand hat.
Naja, das wird ja noch ein bisschen komplizierter. So, und dann dachte ich so, okay, was machst du jetzt? Und dann war es für mich in dem Moment insofern einfach, als dass ich dann schon noch, ich weiß gar nicht, was hab ich gemacht, also ich hab definitiv noch eine Original 10.6 im Schrank, als Medium, hab aber in dem Moment einen Umweg über die Bucht gemacht. So, und jetzt muss ich gerade mal überlegen, und konnte das, glaube ich...
Solches einstellen, ich würde auf jeden Fall Betriebsteaminstallation aus der Bucht runterladen, sonst kann da schon schief gehen.
Und der Rechner war ja... na egal. Auf jeden Fall, also ich brauchte das ja sozusagen nur, um das eigentliche OS zu installieren. Und dann kam ich erstmal so mit Image, und ja, wie kriegst du das ran? Und den Installer vom Image so starten ging nicht, aber ging auf externer Platte, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Das heißt, ich hab das irgendwie auf meinem Rechner und dann den Rechner gemountet, überfallen war irgendwie sowas. Man vergisst ja die Details solcher Rettungsmaßnahmen dann immer, weil man so viel hintereinander ausprobiert und irgendwann geht's und geht mal schon wieder weiter und weiß gar nicht mehr so richtig, welches es eigentlich war. Aber ich glaub, das war der Weg. So, dann hatte ich dann 10.6 drauf mit Mac App Store. Dachte, hurra, alles super. Guten App Store starten und dann so El Capitan. Ja, El Capitan gibt's nicht mehr, weil wir haben jetzt Sierra. Ja, aber Sierra kann ich ja nicht installieren. Ja, es ist ja nicht meine Schuld, dass ihr Rechner nicht so... Also es gibt keinen Mechanismus, wo man einfach mal das... The latest and greatest OS runterladen kann für so ein scheiß Computer, auf dem es supported ist.
Ist halt nicht mehr supported. Der ganze Rechner, der ist halt... Wie nennt Apple das? Nee, Legacy? Nee, irgendwie nennen sie das. Wenn so sozusagen Hardware in einem Status ist, wo Apple sagt, das fassen wir nicht mehr mit der Zange an.
Das ist unsupported halt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, die haben da... Das hat noch einen anderen Namen. Das gibt... muss man... findet irgendjemand bestimmt raus. Aber Vintage. Vintage. Siehst du, so ein Trotzdampfrang. Doch, doch, Vintage. Stimmt so. Ich hab Kontakt mit einer Frau, die sehr lange im App Store, im Apple Store gearbeitet hat, als Genius und so.
Lautsprecher sind an?
Hier sind Lautsprecher?
Das weiß ich, was du gemeint hast. Ja, so. Jetzt weiß ich auch gar nicht mehr so ganz genau. Ich hab dann auch, glaub ich, so ein bisschen die Abkürzung genommen, weil ich, glaube ich, in meinem App Store-Account irgendwann das mal runtergeladen habe. Und deswegen taucht, glaube ich, El Capitan in den recent purchases auf. Und da konnte ich es dann an meinem Rechner runterladen und dann auf den anderen drauf kopieren, damit ich es dann da installieren konnte.
Aber das geht noch. Das heißt, sie haben es nicht komplett aus dem Store rausgenommen.
Ja gut, aber das ging jetzt nur mit einem anderen Account, bei dem das schon mal drin war. Aber du kannst es halt nicht danach suchen. Es ist da, aber du kannst es nicht, nicht, also du kannst es danach suchen, aber du findest es halt nicht. Also das ist auch so eine Sache, wo ich sagen muss, was soll denn das, wenn man noch nicht mal mehr in den OS einspielen kann?
Das heißt, es macht einen Gewinn von allen OSen, sich so ein USB-Stick zu machen, auch wenn man ihn gerade eigentlich gerade braucht, aber sollte man sich mal als Archiv anlegen, wenn man...
Und den dann bitte in sieben Jahren wiederfinden. Das ist glaube ich der größte Knaller.
So, jetzt kommt hier so ein Besserwisser im Chat und meint, ja, wenn ich El Capitan schon mal runtergeladen habe, bevor Sierra da war, dann kann ich das nochmal reinstallieren. Ja, aber das war ja von einem Account von jemanden, der halt ein halbes Jahr nachdem Sierra war, das erste Mal überhaupt über diesen Account was runtergeladen hat. So und hätte das dann mit einem anderen Account machen können, hätte ich auch machen können, keine Ahnung. Weiß man ja ganz genau, was so die Nummer war.
Es wäre schön, wenn Apple einen normalen Weg finden würde, ohne Hintertüren um ihre alten Hardware einen, die sagt, einen Ruhestand in Würde oder sowas zu gewähren.
Get the latest OS-Button und fertig! Ich meine, wo ist das fucking Problem?
Das Problem ist wahrscheinlich nicht mal, dass da Techniker oder selbst Politiker ein Problem sind, sondern wieder irgendwelche Lawyer. Die erzählen ihren Politikern wieder, pass mal auf, da gibt es jetzt User, die laden dann alte Betriebssysteme runter, was du ja nicht mehr mit Sicherheitsupdates versiehst.
Das ist nicht die Rechtsabteilung, das ist die fucking Marketingabteilung.
Nein, das ist auch die Rechtsabteilung. Du lädst ja dein Betriebssystem runter, für die sie keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr bereitstellen.
Tun sie, tun sie, nein, das tun sie noch. Das ist ein voll supportedes OS. Das ist das Letzte, was vom halben Jahr rauskommt. Da ist locker noch ein oder zwei Jahre Security-Updates wieder da.
Du hast jetzt Glück, dass du eine Hardware hast, wo noch Kapitan draufläuft. Was ist, wenn du jetzt eine Hardware hast, wo nur noch, was ist, ich, 10.8 draufläuft?
Gut, das ist ein anderer Fall, aber ich rede ja jetzt von etwas, was sehr wohl noch supportet.
Jetzt ist das latest OS für diese Hardware, forderst du gerade. Jetzt habe ich eine Hardware, wo nur noch 10.8 draufläuft.
Skip, skip, skip.
Ist nochmal eine andere Debatte. Jetzt, stör mich nicht beim Anpranger, nachdem du so schön angeprangert hast. Jetzt wird hier einfach weitergeprangert.
Genau.
Parallelpranger.
Ringpranger.
Ja, also wir sind, wir sind lange hinter PeekApple.
Und hier, wie auch ein Hörer im Chat richtig erwähnt, also USB-Stick ist das Falsche. Also die Images schön auf den Server legen, weil dein USB-Stick, der passt dann bei dem Gerät evtl. dann schon nicht mehr, was du dann in Zukunft nennst.
Na doch, ich will ja was retten von jetztem alter Hardware. Dann eher andersrum, weil ihr kriegt ja nämlich in 7 Jahren wahrscheinlich nur noch USB-Sticks mit USB-C. Und den kriegt der, da wird er nicht reingesteckt in das alte Ding.
Gut, also bei mir war das jetzt nur ein Convenience und Zeitproblem in dem Moment. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch bei Sierra so ist, hab ich noch nicht geguckt, aber normalerweise ist es so, dass diese Downloads, die man da macht, diese Installer, die man da runterlädt, enthalten in dem Package im Prinzip ein vollwertiges Image, was man sich auch brennen kann. Das heißt, das, was man eigentlich mal machen will, ist...
Da kommt ja nur so ein Mini-Installer und dann startest du den und dann kommt erst der Rest, oder? Weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Wie gesagt, ich hab nicht geguckt, aber das...
Und er löscht sich diese Sau, nachdem man ihn einmal benutzt hat oder schiebt sie zumindest irgendwo weg.
Das finde ich ja wiederum ganz sinnvoll eigentlich.
Ich kann das schon noch selber in die Tonne schmeißen. Wenn du zwei Rechner installierst und da nicht aufpasst, kannst du gleich nochmal runterladen.
Ja, aber bei den Leuten liegt das Ding dann immer rum und belegt 5 GB und fertig.
Und kurz das höhere Dingsbums-Himmer, das wir jetzt schon fast leer gefuttert haben.
Ja, ach ist schon fast leer.
Mach mal. Na die leckerste Sorte.
Der Grund, warum hier wieder so viel geschmatz wird, das ist wieder gelungene Eigenwerbung, aber du hast damit angefangen.
Das ist keine Eigenwerbung.
Das habt ihr jetzt schon alles leer gefressen, oder was? Nur die eine Sorte.
Das ist die beste Sorte, die du hast, deswegen hab ich dir schnell rüber geschoben, bevor die ganze auf ist.
Denis hat auch. Worum geht's? Ihr erinnert euch vor einiger Zeit, ich hatte ein Kollege von mir damals noch bei VUGA selbst angefangen Beef Jerky herzustellen. Und auch damals sind wir schon sein, also da hatte ich einfach Samples aus dem Büro mal mitgenommen. Und wir haben hier ganz eifrig gemampft. Und dann haben wir auch ganz viele Hörer das bestellt bei ihm direkt. Und er hat auch sich herzlich bedankt für das Featuring und so weiter. Und war total happy gewesen, dass so viele Leute da bei ihm bestellt hätten. Und jetzt hat er sich aber irgendwie, hat er eine Pause gemacht oder sich irgendwie da neue Geschäftsräume gesucht, wie auch immer. Jetzt ist er auf jeden Fall wieder im Business. Und er hat mir dann gleich auf Facebook geschrieben, hier, ey, ich mach jetzt wieder, also jetzt mach ich so richtig Beef Jerky. Also wirklich so Full-Time Beef Jerky all the way. Full Commitment. Ich kenn auch einen Kollegen, der ein Nachbar von ihm war und meinte, man hat das dann auch im ganzen Haus schon gerochen, wenn er da am Jerken war. Nichtsdestotrotz, er hat uns jetzt hier mal drei Tüten direkt in die Freak Show geschickt. Und die eine ist jetzt schon leer. Und das spricht auf jeden Fall dafür, dass das auch nach wie vor ziemlich gut schmeckt. Und ihr schreibt am besten rein, falls ihr da jetzt auch nochmal klickt, ich pack die URL hier mal in die Show Notes, nicht da in den Chat, verdammt in dem. Schreibt ihr noch rein, so für jede zehnte verkaufte Tüte über die Freak Show schickt ihr uns eine dann gratis hierher.
Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, wer meint doch, dass er schon zwei Jahre Pause gemacht hat, das ist schon ganz schön lange her. Ich hab da auch probiert und irgendwie dachte ich so trockenes Fleisch ist eigentlich eine geile Sache, probiert und hat mir überhaupt gar nicht gefallen. Weiß nicht, ob das so ein wasserlos war an dem Tag mit meinem Geschmacksnerven, aber vielleicht war es damals nicht so gut. Ich hab heute hier nochmal probiert, eigentlich schon, weil ich dachte, es müsste doch eigentlich gut schmecken, ich teste das sicherheitshalb nochmal und heute schmeckt es tatsächlich gut. Deswegen sind die Packungen auch schon leer.
Ja, die eine zumindest. Also, ist ja auch ein guter Proteinsnack für die Jogger und Fitness- und Unterwegsleute.
Wie lange würde das halten, wenn man das so trocken und offen liegen lässt? Schon lange, oder? Ich meine, haben die doch früher auch so gemacht oder nicht?
Steht gar nicht drauf, hat er nicht raufgestempelt, mindestens haltbar. Ach doch, 23.4.2017.
Okay, nicht so lange.
Naja, das ist Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum.
Und er macht jetzt halt auch nicht mit irgendwie krass Konservierungsstoffen rum, ne? Also wenn du diese abgepackten Beef Jerkies, die man in Europa kauft, das ist halt wirklich ranz.
Ja, Konservierungsstoffe drin und Zeug. Was er aber auch schreibt, ist, dass er hier, was macht er? Low Fat and Low Carb. Also Low Carb, keine Ahnung, aber Low Fat, ich meine, Fett ist doch der Geschmacksträger, das wäre doch geil, wenn das noch so richtig so... Ja, also, wer soll mal welche mit, mit, mit...
Richtig Fettkur.
Eine Full Monty, so eine Version machen.
Das ist der Punkt an dried. Also ganz groß drauf, dried meat.
Ja, aber trocken heißt ja, dass das Wasser da rausgezogen ist, das Fett kann da drin bleiben. Das soll ja nur halten.
Denis will Fettkur machen.
Keine Ahnung, ob das noch das selbe Produkt wäre.
Der muss ja nicht. Ja, wenn ihr jetzt sagt, das geht mit dem Fett nicht, das gehört da raus, dann okay, aber...
Weißt du, erst mal eine Reuspertaste ablehnen und dann die ganze Zeit den Hörern so ins Ohr reinzumanchen, das ist schon ziemlich schlecht. Also liebe Hörer, wenn ihr euch berechtigterweise bei dieser Sendung über dieses Verhalten eschofiert, möchte ich euch gleich darauf hinweisen, ich war es nicht.
Und jetzt beiß rein.
Nur mit Rolls-Royce-Taste mein Freund.
Wie kannst du gar nicht so lange, dein Daumen hat gar nicht so viel Muskel und so lange...
Ja, ja, bla bla bla.
Was ich sagen wollte...
Du bist doch irgendwie von der Nintendo 460 auch niedergekniet und bist doch in der Lage ein paar Nintendo-Buns mal für so lange zu drücken, wie du auf irgendeinem Schuhsohle rumkaust.
Aber dann haben wir gleich...
Moment, Moment, Moment. Wir haben uns jetzt unsere vorherläufige Wertung, also er hat uns drei Sorgen geschickt. Classic, Mezcal, Jalapeño, Beef Jerky und Sticky Ginger Teriyaki Beef Jerky. Unsere Hitliste ist so...
Wer, ich und Hucke, wir sind uns einig. Also Top schmeckt Classic.
Das was schon leer ist.
Dann Mezcal ist Platz Nummer 2.
Ja und Ginger Teriyaki ist so la la. Kann man schon mal essen, aber... Wobei ich trotzdem empfehlen würde, wenn man jetzt 3 oder 4 bestellt, man will nicht 3 oder 4 mal Classic bestellen, man will schon mit verschiedenen Tüten bestellen.
Schon ein guter Snack, den macht er ganz schön voll auf Dauer.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, das schmeckt so ein bisschen als ähm... als wenn der Gulasch irgendwie eine Woche rumstand und man dann den isst.
Aber ist eher auch gut, oder?
Ja, also so ein Gulasch. Schön durchgezogen, geil. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein coole Snack und der macht halt auch tatsächlich relativ satt. Das ist glaube ich relativ proletarisch. Proteinreich.
Also abgesehen davon, dass wahrscheinlich ab heute mir kein Mensch mehr glaubt, dass die Beta-Ebene nicht werbefinanziert ist.
Das ist wirklich jetzt nur für den lieben Kollegen, den ich kenne. Also die anderen kennen den ja nicht mal. Der muss jetzt eigentlich schon irgendwie für diese Transferleistung irgendwie dann auch ein paar Beef Jerky's überschneiden.
Ich überlege gerade, was diese Werbeeinblendung jetzt sozusagen eigentlich wert sein müsste. Aber ich finde...
Wir haben drei Beef Jerky Packungen bekommen. Dazu müssen wir Medien daten.
Also sollte irgendjemand deine Empfehlung in nennenswerter Zahl folgen, dann kann er ja hier mal eine Flatrate einführen.
Absolut. Ich werde ihn auch, er wird sich sicherlich bei mir melden. Das hat er letztens mal auch mal gemacht und dann werde ich schon anmoderieren, dass wir dann gerne hier noch...
Er hat ja auch geschrieben, als der Huckel das bei der letzten Sendung gemacht hat, dass es auch gut geholfen hätte, irgendwie sein Business zu starten. Ich glaube, Business hat er jetzt nicht geschrieben, aber er hat auf jeden Fall gleich Support, ordentlich und...
Ja, podcast wirken.
Also vielleicht...
Das hat anscheinend so gut gewirkt, dass er jetzt auch gleich hier extra nochmal hergeschrieben hat. Der ist ja noch in Berlin, oder?
Wir arbeiten jetzt ja nicht mehr zusammen. Ja, aber ich werde auf jeden Fall dann nächste Freak Show berichten, ob wir jetzt hier sozusagen einen offiziellen Freak Show Snack haben.
Was kostet eigentlich so eine Tüte, Türker?
Gute Frage. Beinahm.
Wie viel Gramm sind da drin? 50 Gramm, okay.
Also eine Tüte Classic kostet 5,95.
Was?
Echt?
Wow, das ist ja richtig teuer.
Das ist lecker Fleisch.
Also es ist kostenspiegig.
Was kostet eine Tüte von diesen Plaste M&Ms?
Ja, es ist mehr Gramm und kostet deutlich weniger. Muss man mal so sehen, ein 300 Gramm Steak wären 6 so eine Tüten vom Gewicht, das wäre dann 6 mal 6,36 Euro. Grammmäßig ist das so ein teurer Steak.
Die M&Ms, die ihr da vorhin hattet, die sind jetzt alle schon...
Jetzt sind sie weg, ich hab vorhin extra gefragt.
Jetzt ist auf jeden Fall der Werbeblock, für den wir kein Geld kriegen.
So, jetzt würde ich gerne wieder. Ich bin ja hier so ein Kind aus den 80ern, ich fang jetzt mal tief an, oder früh, und hab ja nach C64, den hatte ich nicht so lange, hat nicht so richtig funktioniert bei mir, hab ich mir einen Amiga geholt, das ist ein Rechner und 68.000, also wie die Macs ja auch zu der Zeit, und ich hab 68K Assembler gelernt. Und das ist so ein bisschen meine Plattform, wo ich mich auskenne. Du erinnerst dich? So, und irgendwie beschäftige ich mich in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen wieder damit und mach so ein bisschen rum und guck so und tu so. Und brauche es auch so rum. Und es gibt halt so Retro-Computer-Seiten, wo sich Leute halt, wahrscheinlich auch alles alte Opis, irgendwie halt mit Hardware von früher beschäftigen. Nö, es gibt auch junge Leute, die das machen. So, aber die halt so nicht alte Rechner nachbauen oder reparieren, das gibt es ja auch eine Menge, sondern die jetzt tatsächlich auch, weil irgendwie ist jetzt alles verstanden und man hat auch moderne Software, die einem dabei hilft und hier Software zum Platinen machen und alles, was es so gibt, ist alles heutzutage nicht mehr so teuer und man kann relativ easy, für jemand, der sich auskennt, kann man sich halt so einen Computer selber zusammenbauen, also mit eigenem Design und alles. Und das machen die halt auf diesen Seiten so. Da bieten die alle Reports an und ich hab mir jetzt mal eins ausgeguckt. Das Ding heißt KISS 68.030, also KISS für Keep it Simple and Stupid. Das Stupid lassen wir hinten mal weg eigentlich heutzutage, aber das sind halt relativ einfache Aufbau. Und ich dachte erst irgendwie, ich muss die Platinen mir hier selber machen lassen. Hätte mich jetzt auch gar nicht so doll abgeschreckt, aber noch viel einfacher. Man kann die bei denen bestellen. Dann klick mal da oben links, bei dem grünen links, links, näher, ja oder so. Das ist das, ja. So, das ist ein, das ist nicht ein SBC, was Single Board Computer heißt, sondern das ist ein EBC. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wofür E steht, Extended oder was auch immer. Aber das ist halt ein Board, was man in eine Backplane steckt und auf die Backplane kann man noch so Multifunction Cards irgendwie reinstecken. Also so ein bisschen so wie... VME-Bus oder sowas, ja genau. Wie damals halt Computer waren. Na ja, wissen ja vielleicht manche Hörer nicht. Deswegen sind es leider drei Boards. Das heißt, man muss einmal die Backplane machen, einmal das CPU-Board und einmal das Multifunction-Board, wo halt Timer, Serielle und Interrupt-Controller und so drauf ist. Und dann hast du halt einen Minicomputer. So und dann gibt es da so einen Typen, der noch auch irgendwie ganz flott dabei ist und sich da voll reinpopelt. Der hat schnell mal das aktuelle Linux da angepasst. Weil es gibt Linux mit 68K Support. Er musste halt nur diese Hardware, die es sonst nirgends auf der Welt gibt, musste halt ein bisschen anpassen, wo die Serielle ist, wie die Speicherstruktur ist und wie das mit den Interrupts ist und so. Und ja, das läuft. Der hat da ein Video, gibt es bei YouTube auch irgendwie. Oder auch auf der Seite ist das auch gewesen eigentlich, wenn man jetzt da bei Retro Computer oder Retro Brew Computer sucht. Und das sieht alles ganz schick und toll aus. Und ich dachte mir, ach, scheiß drauf. Ich order mal jetzt so ein Set und versuch das mal auch zu bauen.
Deswegen wolltest du die Eagle Lizenz haben oder was?
Deswegen, nee, der Eagle Lizenz, das ist noch andere Sachen. Und ja, also wenn da Leute Interesse haben, dass es auf jeden Fall oder überhaupt sich das mal so angucken wollen, dieses Retro Brew Computer, da sind auf jeden Fall die Jungs, die so alte Rechner machen. Die machen auch kleine 68.000 Rechner ohne die 30, also nur den normalen, der hat zwar keine MMU und kann dann kein Unix fahren, aber man kann ja auch irgendwelche Sachen fahren. Von diesem bekannten Linux und bei Freebies, da arbeitet auch dieser Alan Cox. Der hat irgendwie auch so einen...
Da müsstest du auch übrigens Dinge geben, die du ohne MMU fahren kannst, da hast du halt keine...
Du hast keine Memory Protection.
Da gibst der, da gibst bloß Ruth.
Genau. Das geht schon, aber so ein Unix will ja eigentlich schon Memory Protection, sonst fliegt der bei jedem Fehler alles um die Ohren.
Man darf es halt keine Fehler machen.
Darf ich jetzt mal gerade eine sehr zentrale Frage stellen dazu?
Weil es Spaß macht?
Weil es Spaß macht, das löten oder weil es Spaß macht, 68.000 Assembler umzuhaken? Alles, alles, alles. Was ich alle naselang immer mal wieder machen muss, jetzt auch demnächst mal wieder, ich benutze regelmäßig Emulatoren, um so alte Zeugs zu machen, oder?
Ja, das hab ich auch.
Also wenn du jetzt nur 68.000 Assembler hacken willst, da gibt es einfache Möglichkeiten.
Das mach ich ja schon, Emulator, das ist alles gar kein Ding. Das ist aber, das ist ja nicht so das wahre. Da gibt es dann diesen Forum, da basteln sie gerade einen neuen Board. Also sie wollen jetzt so den richtig 68.000er Computer basteln, da sind die auch schon voll dabei. Und dann meint er, naja, hier die ganzen Videochips und Ethernet-Controller und so. Und wenn wir dafür eh schon so FPGAs benutzen für die ganzen Steuerungen, weil früher waren das halt PALS und GALS und CPLDs, die sie benutzt haben, jetzt benutzen wir FPGAs für die ganze Steuerung der CPU. Und dann kommt natürlich auch die Idee, naja, jetzt gibt es ja auch schon 68K-Cores, so heißt das, dann kommt der ganze 68K-CPU in den FPGA rein und dann ist ja alles easy eigentlich. Aber das ist der Moment, wo ich dann keinen Bock mehr hätte, weil dann kann ich gleich wieder zum Emulator springen, dann brauch ich das alles nicht mehr. Also wenigstens die CPU sollte die Originale sein.
Darum ist mir sozusagen egal.
Aber ist ja dann auch, also du hast ja immer noch denselben Core, es ist ja Hardware.
Ja, aber ist es derselbe Core? Also ist es eins zu eins wirklich so?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, was das für eine Quelle ist, wo der Core herkommt, aber es handelt sich um Hardware. Emulatoren, die da oben sind, haben einfach ganz anderes Timingverhalten.
Das gefällt mir um wenigstens. Ich will den realen Scheiß haben.
Es gibt immer Leute, die kommen auf die Idee, da so Sachen zu reparieren, denn weil die Original-Designs sind immer irgendwo flawed.
Ja zum Beispiel, oder sie haben Fehler drin oder so.
Okay, also rein aus Kompatibilitätsgründen und Kontakt mit The Real Thing zu haben, versteht das auch, dass man so richtig...
Außerdem sieht man auch die Signale nicht mehr, weil das alles nur innerhalb des FPG ist und du hast dann keinen Einfluss mehr.
Genau, da wollte ich nämlich auch gerade nochmal eine zweite Antwort liefern für die Frage. Ich denke, wenn man sich jetzt damit auseinandersetzt, teilweise ist es ja vielleicht so ein bisschen Romantik.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ist okay, aber unter Garantie nicht das Einzige. Weil gerade auch diese Art und Weise einen Computer zu bauen, also überhaupt erst mal der Begriff. Backplane, ja was ist denn das? Backplane heißt, man hat einfach nur eine Platine, in der Slots sind, in der die Komponenten des Computers stecken, die über diese Backplane miteinander verbunden werden. Das heißt, die Backplane selber ist strunzend dumm.
Da ist kein einziges aktives Bauteil drauf. Nur Stecker.
Genau. Steht nichts anderes.
Keine Bufferkondensatoren?
Ich habe gesagt, keine aktiven Bauteile. Das ist ja kein Logic-Chip oder sowas.
Es ist keine Einheit in dem Computer selber. Es ist eine reine Brücke, um die eigentlichen aktiven Komponenten des Rechners zusammenzubringen. Es ist einfach eine praktische Art und Weise, einen Rechner zu bauen, die früher auch genau die Art und Weise war, wie alle Rechner gebaut waren. Also wenn man sich so alte Filme und Fotos anschaut von den Rechnern in den 70ern und auch in den 80ern auch. Hier so PDP, diese ganzen Mini-Computer und Großrechner und so weiter. Ja, warum waren denn das so große Schränke? Es waren halt große Schränke, weil das im Prinzip nichts anderes waren als Backplane in a Box. Und vorne hast du halt zack, zack, zack, zack, zack. Für jede 8 Kilobyte RAM hast du halt da nochmal so eine Pizzascheibe da reingeschoben. Und was weiß ich, und dann gab es halt einen oder zwei Scheiben für CPU und zwei Scheiben für eine Alu. Also das eine konnte irgendwie ein wenig addieren, das andere konnte vielleicht multiplizieren. Und also für jeden Scheiß, der heute natürlich auf dem kleinsten denkbaren Level voll integriert ist auf der aller tiefsten Ebene dieses Chips, waren das einfach mal einerseits separierte Elemente und darüber hinaus auch komplett diskret aufgebaut. Also eben mit so ganz normalen Logikgattern und so weiter. Das heißt, du hattest nicht diesen Universal-Chip, der einzige wirklich integrierte Chip, der eigentlich aus dieser Zeit dann hervorkam, war dann eben die CPU. Das war das große Novum mit dem Intel 8008 oder 8080, der im Prinzip der erste Mikroprozessor, also der erste Mikrocomputer war, ohne Chip. Also quasi alles das, was man vorher in Backplane, in verschiedenen Modulen teuer zusammenstecken musste, was allein deshalb schon so teuer war. Das war quasi dann die Revolution von Intel, dass sie gesagt haben, wir kennen jetzt die Sachen, die wir da brauchen, weil wir brauchen da eine Recheneinheit und wir brauchen da eine Adressierungslogik und keine Ahnung, was jetzt noch die drei, vier wichtigen Komponenten sind. Und das haben wir jetzt mal auf einem einzigen Chip zusammengebaut und jetzt brauchen wir diese Backplane nicht, weil die Backplane ist quasi Teil des Chips und damit läuft auch schon mal alles sprungsbar.
Du meinst der 88 war da der erste?
2008. Also der 808 war die 8-Bit. Also der 808 war der erste, doch genau. Genau. Na, Intel hat das im Prinzip losgetreten. Und dann kam halt der 8080. Jetzt muss ich aufpassen, dass ich nicht durcheinanderkomme.
Dann gab es noch eine 8088.
Genau, dann der 8088. Das war halt ihr erster großer richtiger Erfolg. Und der 8088 war halt die 8-Bit-Variante des 8086.
Intel war wie so mein Ding damals.
Ja, aber das ist halt der erste Prozessor des IBM Personalcomputers. Also der 8086.
Motorola hat einen schöneren Assembler.
Ja klar, also gar keine Frage. Also das war halt damals sozusagen RACE. Es gab halt die 8er Welt und es gab die 6er Welt. Und die 8er Welt war halt Z80 und dann eben auch Intel.
Das ist aber ein Tailog.
Ja, aber die haben viel gemeint.
Z80 gibt es bei diesem Retrobrew-Computer auch ganz viel. Also die CPM machen die auch ganz viel auf 68K, aber auch auf den Z80.
Also ich sag nicht, dass das dasselbe ist. Es ist definitiv nicht dasselbe. Aber die Z80, ich kann das jetzt nicht belegen, aber die Z80 Prozessordenke ist sehr verwandt. Auch mit der ganzen Intel 8080 Prozessordenke, also die Art und Weise, wie die CPUs gearbeitet haben und wie sich der Assembler schrieb und las, war mehr diese eine Gedankenwelt. Und das andere ist die sechser Welt. Das ist halt 6502, also MOS Technologies, womit der C64 geboren wurde. Und dann eben auch Motorola. Also Motorola hat ja den 6809, der so ähnlich war wie der 6502. Aus dem dann nochmal eine Null hinten dran, quasi die 68000er wurden und die hatten ihren Ansatz. Während die 80er Welt halt immer Low-Order gemacht hat, hat halt... Genau, und Big Engine war die sechser Welt sozusagen. Und das sind eigentlich so die beiden großen CPU-Pfade, die sich dann durch die 80er in die 90er entwickelt haben. Und dann wissen wir alle, wie es gekommen ist.
Auch für den halben Bereich gab es ja noch so was wie VEX und VEX-CPUs und so weiter. Aber da war ja für Otto Normalbürger das ja nicht erschwingend.
Das sind ja dann sozusagen die 60er, die sich in die 70er geschleppt haben. Und die neue CPU-Geschichte ist halt die 70er, die sich dann in die 80er anrichtet.
Wo wir gerade so schön im Oper erzählt vom Kriegmodus sind, während Huckel hier gerade unter den Tisch rutscht. Wir haben ja immer über die Emulator angesprochen und dass die dann eben Sachen anders oder besser gemacht haben oder sowas. Ich hab kurz nach der Wende, also noch Ende 89, Anfang 90 oder sowas, da hatte ich so Kontakt auch zu Leuten von der Akademie der Wissenschaften hier auch in Berlin in Adlershof. Und die haben immer so schöne Sachen. Es gab so ein Projekt innerhalb der Ostblock-Staaten, wir bauen jetzt mal Großrechner und dann so schön verteilt, Platten in Bulgarien, Speicher in Tschechien oder Tschechoslowakei damals, CPUs in Deutschland und so andere, Russen haben auch immer was beigesteuert und die jeweiligen Geheimdienste haben dann immer Dinge angeschleppt, so haben dann irgendwie mal drüben was abgestaubt, gekauft, geklaut, keine Ahnung wie auch immer und durften die halt eben auseinandernehmen. Und der Osten hat halt sehr viel nachgebaut, zum Beispiel ja eben der Z80, den gab's dann auch richtig zu kaufen. Hier hieß halt hier U880. War auch sehr schön, weil man nämlich die ganze Doku dafür in Ost-Berlin kaufen konnte für Ostmark. Musste ja eh zwangsumtausch halt ein bisschen Ostmark, konntest schön in den Buchladen gehen, konntest dir ein U880-Manual kaufen. Das war viel, viel warm, Faktor 50 billiger als das Original-Manual von Zylok. Und sie haben halt eben auch Sachen gefixt, also der eine hat mir erzählt, dass er sozusagen beim Nachbau von dem IBM 360 zeugs, also die Großrechner-CPUs oder sowas, die haben sich halt auseinander genommen zu gucken, wie das alles funktioniert und haben dabei die ganzen Bugs gefunden und haben die dann auch natürlich gleich gefixt. Also das Ding hatte so übliche Rechenfehler wo man mit der Software drum rumgehen musste. Also das wäre mal ganz spannend und zu gucken, ob es sozusagen dazu noch eine Dokumentation gibt oder ob das irgendjemand mal niedergeschrieben hat oder ob das mal ein Journalist recherchiert hat, was die damals da gemacht haben. Ich fand das jedenfalls sehr spannend. Sozusagen beim Klonen erst mal überhaupt diese Dinger zu reverse-ingenieren mit den damaligen Mitteln, vor allen Dingen mit denen, die man im Osblock hatte und dann eben auch noch die zu fixen on the fly.
Die Akademie der Wissenschaften, der DDR, in Berlin, das war ja auch der einzige Ort, wo Unix gemacht wurde in der DDR. Also es gab da genau einen Ort, wo Unix ankam. Nee, in Berlin, direkt da, wo jetzt das Außenministerium ist. Das heutige Außenministeriumsgebäude war ja früher die Akademie der Wissenschaften in Berlin.
Die hatten aber natürlich Labors, und traurig, und Peppa-Po in all möglichen Orten hier in Berlin. Und in der Altershof waren die Hardware-Frickler, glaube ich.
Okay, mag sein, aber die Software-Abteilung war da. Ich war da mal, deswegen weiß ich das jetzt zufällig.
Zu Ostseiten?
Ja, so gerade nach Wende. Genau, als wir da noch alle so rüber gelatscht sind und als wir die ersten Ostwesthacker...
Als wir Modemverbindungen sauer aufrechterhalten zwischen West- und Ostberlin, damit wir da mal Newsnetwork hinschicken konnten und so.
Ja, du weißt ja, der CTC hat es ja noch zu DDR-Zeiten geschafft, einen Kongress in Ostberlin zu organisieren. Damals den CoCon-Kongress. Vor der Wiedervereinigung noch.
Gerade so. Mit diesen FPGAs fällt mir noch ein, für diesen Amiga-Wohlleute immer noch voll viel Herzblut reinstecken. Da gab es immer diese Turbo-Card, wo die sich in 68.040 oder 68.030 in ihren 500er oder 1200er gesteckt haben. Und da gibt es auch Leute, die haben die letzte CPU von Motorola, weil er der 68.060, den ja auch Apple schon nicht mehr benutzt hat, weil da haben die ja schon zu PowerPC gewechselt. Aber diesen 68.060 haben die halt in FPGA nachgemacht. Nennen das Ding aber nicht 68.060, sondern die haben den so viel verbessert, dass sie ihn 68.080 nennen. Motorola ist ja eigentlich schon immer zwei Stufen gesprungen. Die Ungraden waren ja immer nur so leichte Verbesserungen. Und der ist halt noch mal viel besser als der 68.060. Und er taktet halt, weil es FPGAs sind, auch noch viel höher. Man kann das Spiel schon treiben, das ist dann aber nicht... Also es ist schon auch irgendwie retro, weil das der gleiche Assembler, aber es ist schon irgendwie was anderes. Und ich hätte wenigstens irgendwas, was noch von damals so ein bisschen echt ist, weil sonst kann ich wirklich alles durchsimulieren. Und wer Bock hat, 68.080 heißt irgendwie Apollo oder sowas. Ich weiß nicht so genau, muss man gucken. Gibt es einen Amiga 500, ist dann sowas von Rat denn schnell? Ja, dann könnt ihr jetzt endlich Doom spielen.
Das war einfach der Benchmark bei denen. Zweitwichtigste Frage an mich. Hat der einen Aufbau oder hat der irgendwie einen Netzwerkanschluss?
Na, da gibt es einen Typen, da gibt es ja die Backplane und ein Multifunction Board hat einen IDE-Anschluss und eine serielle, aber die benutzt er als Konsol. Er meinte, er will natürlich noch ein bisschen IP haben. Da hat er sich dieses Multifunction Board einfach noch mal gebaut.
Ein zweites, damit er eine zweite Serielle hat, hat auch Chips weglassen, weil die braucht er dann nicht mehr. Die zweite Serielle hat er gleich auch auf einen FTD-Chip gelegt, dass er nicht hier DB9 hat, sondern dass es gleich per USB zu ihm reinkommt. Das war dann auch so eine Serielle mit 1 MBit, was der Amiga, oder was, ein 68.030er...
Und da machen wir jetzt nochmal asynchroner PPP drauf, oder was?
Genau, das hat er dann da rauf gelegt. Und dann hat er sogar IPv4, IPv6 gehabt, hat einen SSH gestartet.
Wäre jetzt mal eine nächste Frage gewesen, weil wenn du jetzt gesagt hättest, IPv4 Only wäre ich jetzt raus gewesen, aber wenn da noch IPv6 drauf geht, dann ist ja gut.
Hat er das auch gezeigt, weiß ich gar nicht, aber warum soll das nicht gehen? Ich meine, das PPP, geht da alles drüber, oder?
Ja, wenn du da einen fertigen PPP-Stack, einen fertigen Linux-Stack reinmachst.
Ja, der hatte eine Vierer Linux oder so, und das war letztes Jahr, also vor, ja, ich weiß nicht, welches Linux da aktuell war. Und er meinte, er hat SSH gestartet, und wenn du das dem Demon startest, und da ist noch kein Host-Key da, oder Server-Key, oder wie immer der heißt, dann wird der erstmal generiert, ne?
Ja, das dauert.
Das hat ein bisschen gedauert, und das Login dauert auch so 15 Sekunden oder so bei SSH, also da wird's dann schon ein bisschen langsam, weil das sind die Sachen, die dann doch ein bisschen so CPU-Power brauchen. Aber sonst hat da eigentlich alles geflutscht, also die Festplatte ist noch ein bisschen langsam, weil die machen noch kein DMA, das ist alles noch so, wahrscheinlich Polling und so, seine Bytes da irgendwie abfragen, das weiß ich halt nicht genau, muss man sich dann mal angucken, wenn man das hat, aber ich denke mal...
Und einen alten Ethernet-Käfer sich zu suchen von vor 20 Jahren, und die da...
Ja, da sind die ja dabei. Einer baut, glaub ich gerade, ist ja eine Backplane, baut gerade so ein Multifunction-Bord, wo halt 4 USB-Slots drauf sind wohl. Ja, und dann machst du halt... Ja, du brauchst ja nur den USB-Treiber machen, und diese Ethernet-Dinger, das ist ja dann schon wieder alles in C geschrieben, die musst du dann ja nicht mehr portieren, weil das meiste ist alles in C geschrieben, da musst du gar nichts mehr machen.
Aber er kompiliert jetzt nicht auf der Kröte, ne? Er kompiliert, cross-kompiliert, auf einem ordentlichen Rechner, das dauert ja ewig.
Er hat cross-kompiliert, aber er meint auch, das Ding ist Self-hosting, also es kann auch seinen eigenen Kernel bauen, aber es dauert zwei Tage.
Na ja, wie früher halt, ne?
Ja, zwei Tage hat es nicht gedauert, aber es ist schon ordentlich. 68.088, ja. Das wiederum finde ich dann schon ganz geil, also das ist schon auch cool, aber ich wollte jetzt erstmal ein, wo halt ein Original Silicon drauf ist und nicht sowas, aber das ist schon, das ist schon auch ziemlich geil.
Und dann in der Semmler programmieren, ich meine, wenn da Linux drauf ist, dann nimmt man ja dann doch wieder einen C-Compiler, ist ja langweilig.
Naja, dann kannst du aber noch hingehen und gewisse Teile des Kernels, wo du denkst, hier könnte man ein bisschen Performance rausholen, weil in x86 haben die auch Assembler-Codes, so ist ja nicht. Also immer wenn das Performance-kritisch ist, dann machen die da Assembler. Also bestimmte Robiten, so OpenSSL zum Beispiel, sind Assembler, oder? Kann man machen, oder ist sogar so.
Ist für viele Plattformen, ja.
Und dann machst du halt für deine Plattformen, machst du einfach auch so ein Assembler-Blog. Was ich am schlimmsten finde, gerade für mich als 68k-Fan, die bei GCC, weil du musst das ja in den C-Code einbinden, die bei GCC haben halt nicht den Motorola-Assembler-Syntax, sondern die haben halt die AT&T-Syntax, wo immer so ein Prozentzeichen vor den Registernamen sind und irgendwie so andere Umstellungen. Und wenn ich so ein Code sehe, kriege ich halt das Wirken.
Das war einer der Gründe, warum ich auch eher aus der 6er-Fraktion war und die 8er-Fraktion irgendwie die Bösen waren.
Das kann ich mental sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Das waren eure Körsertasten früher.
Das waren unsere Körsertasten früher.
Ja, das ist schon so eine gewisse...
Stell dir vor, du hast ein Leben lang Erlang programmiert und dann kommt einer an und sagt, hier, das ist auch Erlang, aber unser Syntax ist jetzt ein bisschen anders, weil unser Erlang-Compiler ist ein anderer. Und dann musst du dich da umstellen.
Das ist überall ein Stern, wo bei dir Unterstrich ist, ist da ein Stern und so. Das ist so die mnemonische Prägung der Frühzeit.
Ich hab letztens auch so einen Artikel, das hatte irgendwie so einen Grund. Und wer ist schuld? Wie heißt der Guru? Stormin? Ja, der ist schuld, dass die AT&T-Syntax genommen wurde, weil die auch schon bei einem anderen braucht. Und er wollte das nicht zweimal machen oder irgendwie so. Und dann haben sie einfach das als Standard da damals genommen. Und seitdem ist das so, dass GCC AT&T-Syntax macht.
Ich finde, man kann Richard Stormen einfach an allem die Schuld geben.
Der nimmt sie auch.
Der macht auf jeden Fall den Eindruck, als wäre er schuldig.
So wie er auftritt.
Dann machen wir das nächste Thema gleich dran, weil es dauert nicht ganz so lange. Was ich dann bei der Forschung für dieses ganze Zeug irgendwie dann auch noch mitgefunden habe, weil ich mich viel mit 68k Zeug jetzt gerade beschäftige, wollte ich so ein bisschen auf dem Mac halt so ein bisschen in Schnell, nicht auf so einem alter Kiste oder mein Amiga ist eh nicht mehr so richtig funktionabel, 68k Code disassemblieren und so ein bisschen moderner. Und eigentlich der Disassembler ist ja dieser Ida Pro. Der kann irgendwie alles interaktiv. Da kannst du bei jeder, ja sag ich mal, Memory-Stelle sagen, ob es Code oder Object oder Text oder was auch immer, ist irgendeine Struktur und so. Und das ist eigentlich das geile Ding. Gibt es auch für OS X, aber ist eigentlich auch schweinemäßig teuer und das ist eher sowas für richtig, richtig Profis. Aber es gibt auf Mac auch ein Tool, das heißt Hopper. Kam gerade so vor ein paar, zwei, drei Monaten in der Version 4 neu raus. Und das ist so ein bisschen, der geht so in Richtung Ida Pro. Hat vielleicht weniger Features, hat dafür aber auch ist ein bisschen sehr, also er kann mit Objective-C kann er gut was anzeigen und jetzt geht es auch mit Swift los und so und auch interaktiv. Und der hat halt auch ein Plugin, was auch 68K disassemblieren kann. Es ist noch nicht ganz so gut und so weiter, aber es hat Zukunft. Nee, erzeugt er nicht. Na die Motorola. So wie sich das gehört. Genau, ohne Prozentzeichen vor den Registern und was die sonst noch bei AT&T für Änderungen haben. Und dann hier siehst du ja schon diese, wie heißt das, so Flowcharts, wie der Code so lang geht. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich geil. Und ich hab ja immer noch, hatte ich meine Sendung erwähnt, ja auch mein Disassembler, den ich immer noch code und bugfixe und schneller mache, einfach nur weil es Spaß macht. Und dann könnte ich mir meinen eigenen Code einmal in so einem Flowchart angucken, weil ich hab den halt, also das ist halt noch mal ein bisschen geiler als Source-Code, weil das so ein bisschen so 2D programmieren ist, ja. Aber der IDA Pro hat das sicherlich alles.
Jetzt die Frage, jetzt werfe ich mal was, jetzt werfe ich mal was in den Ring zum Thema 65002. A9, Hex A9.
Und hast du auch, hast du 68K Assembler gemacht?
Gib mir 5 Clemens.
Hast du 68K Assembler gemacht?
Ich hab, meine erste große Revelation, nachdem ich viel gemacht habe auf 65002, war sozusagen die 6809. Das war eine Offenbarung. Da hab ich ne Weile mit rumgemacht und dann, ach, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr, ob das 68.068.20 war oder so was. Ja, aber aus dieser Generation noch ganz early.
4E75, kennst du sowas noch?
Nee, hab ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Das war das RTS, das konnte man immer gut erkennen, wenn irgendwo 4E75 ist, dann wusstest du, da war der Blog zu Ende.
Aber was er ja gerade nicht verstanden. Hat, wenn man 8-Bit-CPUs programmiert hat in Assembler, das klingt gleich kompliziert, aber ist nicht im eigentlichen Sinne kompliziert, es ist nur einfach very, very basic, dann weiß man halt genau, welche Bit-Kombination im Speicher welcher Befehl ist, weil man muss da halt oft einfach seinen Code genauso lesen, weil so ein Fancy-Schmenzy, ich zeig dir mal, davon haben wir einfach feuchte Kinderträume gehabt.
Nicht mal!
Das war eine Farbanzeige, was du da eben zeigst.
Der hätte meine komplette Unterwäsche austauschen müssen morgens.
Wie viele Unterwäsche trinkst du denn?
Eine meistens gleichzeitig. Ich war bei dieser Gedanke gerade, es gäbe so ein Tool aus der Zukunft, in der wir ja gerade sind.
In der alternativen Zukunft.
Und ich könnte vor allem meinen alten, also ich hab noch ein einziges Stück Code im Zugriff, was ich selber mal programmiert habe auf 6502, was so richtig eine Running App war. Und die mir mal mit so...
Ich hab gute Nachrichten für dich, es gibt ein 6502-Plugin für diesen Hopper. Geil! Das Programm gibt es als Demo für eine halbe Stunde for free, du kannst es halt nur nicht speichern, aber du kannst dir das dann schon angucken. Ansonsten, der Preis ist aber schon auch ein bisschen happig, 100 Euro.
Aber hast du den Code hier im Zugriff, gleich auf deinem iCloud Drive, kann man das jetzt hier live und in Farbe angucken?
Ich hab das hier tatsächlich, müsste ich hier haben, ja. Hab ich doch schon mal erzählt, ich war doch mal Programmierer des Monats, vom Heiseverlag. Nee, Heiseverlag. Ich gehörte ja zu den Heise-Grupis.
Als Hanno Vorana, ja.
Hanno Vorana, keine große Überraschung. Und glaub, das hab ich aber schon ein paarmal erzählt hier. Also da gab's ja mal diese Input 64, das Diskettenmagazin, oder beziehungsweise startete als Kassettenmagazin.
Also... Damals in Klondalkeit, ne?
Für mich ist das noch so nah, aber das klingt wirklich wie... Also die haben halt einen Magazin auf einer Kassette rausgebracht.
Ja, ich erinnere mich.
Da waren Daten drauf.
Das musst du den Kindern erstmal erzählen, was eine Kassette ist.
Das wissen die schon. Das haben die alles im Museum schon mal gesehen.
Das heißt, man hatte einen C64-Homecomputer mit einem angeschlossenen Tapedeck, quasi. Die sogenannte Datasette. Man packte halt diese Kassette aus, steckte die da rein sagte dann halt auf dem Computer, tippte man halt den Basic-Befell Anführungsstriche Dollar Anführungsstriche Komma 4 Anführungsstriche Dollar Anführungsstriche Komma 4 Wenn ich das richtig erinnere, dann war das Tape, so, Return und dann sagt er Press Play on Tape. Dann drückst du halt auf Play auf dem Tape, weil, muss man ja machen, dann dreht sich halt diese Kassette und der C64 fing halt an, das Inhaltsverzeichnis da runterzuladen oder macht man Inhaltsverzeichnis? Inhaltsverzeichnis gab's glaube ich nur bei der Gabs glaube ich nur bei der Diskette, genau. Denkst du, hat man direkt irgendwas gelernt? Wie auch immer, man loote einfach von der Kassette direkt in den Speicher rein. Und führte das dann halt aus und der loot dann irgendwie auch nach und dann kam halt quasi so, das war im Prinzip, was sie gemacht haben, war eine Webseite. Wenn man das mal so sagen, also von der Experience her.
Das heißt, das Loot. Nicht eine Multimedia-CD-ROM?
Nee, das war eine Multimedia-Kassette.
Weil, war da nicht Multi und Media war eigentlich nicht Multimedia.
Na ja doch, das war halt mit Ton. Der Text war bunt. Das war bunt und das war mit Ton. Und das war ziemlich advanced. Und das muss ich sagen, das war ein extrem visionäres Projekt. Das wurde natürlich damals viel belächelt und so. Aber wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, wie sich das alles bis heute entwickelt hat. Die waren die aller... Die haben im Prinzip etwas geliefert. Das war damals nicht universell praktikabel. Aber das war im Endergebnis das, was heute eine Webseite ist. Bevor es überhaupt Netzwerke gab. Und das fand ich schon wirklich bemerkenswert. Und dann erschien das halt Monat um Monat. Da war immer so ein kleines Begleitheft dabei, so ein A5-Teil. Und dann haben sie halt Leute gesucht, die Software für den C64 machten, die sie dort dann eben verbreiten konnten. Weil darum ging es eigentlich im Wesentlichen. Du musstest halt deine Programme nicht mehr abtippen, sondern du hattest einen Datenträger direkt dabei. Das war revolutionär. Das war wirklich unglaublich. Und ja, da hab ich dann halt mal was programmiert.
Damals.
Damals, und dann war ich halt der Programmierer des Monats. Discmon1541. Die Revolution. Ja, ja, also es war ein... Entschuldigung, kein Disassembler. Ein Memory-Monitor. Also als Monitorprogramm bezeichnet man halt ein Programm, mit dem man in den Speicher gucken konnte. Und das visualisieren konnte. Und das Programm konnte das halt nicht nur von dem Computer, sondern von dem angeschlossenen Diskettenlaufwerk. Das Diskettenlaufwerk war genauso ein vollwertiger Computer wie die C64 auch. Das heißt, da war eine 650.02 CPU drin, oder 65.10, um genau zu sein.
Also ein bisschen weniger Speicher, nämlich nur zwei, aber 32 Kilobyte ROM.
Genau, so war's. Und ja, dann konnte man halt da Programme quasi in dem Festplattenteil, äh, Festplatten, in dem Diskettenlaufwerk laden und exekutieren. Womit ja dann übrigens auch so Kopierschutze äh, realisiert wurden, ne? Wo du grad Databacker sagst, also, da war ich dann immer fleißig dabei und hab so deren Kopierschütze umgangen, weil die halt da Code in der Floppy exekutiert haben.
Normalerweise hast du ja diesen Floppy-Controller, der hat ja auch so Kommandos gehabt und üblicherweise hat man so, weiß ich so, Read-Sektor oder so was gemacht. Und Freit-Sektor. Oder Block, weiß ich nicht, Sektor glaube ich. Es gab aber auch ein Kommando, mit dem konntest du den gesamten Track lesen. Und zwar mit allem Schmuddel, der da auch war, rechts und links, also mit all den Sektoren, die drauf war, mit all dem Scheiß, der zwischen den Sektoren drauf war und so weiter und so fort. Und das hab ich auch gerne benutzt, um zum Beispiel mal Kopie-Schütze-Disketten auszulesen und sie dann wieder herunterzuschreiben.
Aber das Problem war ja, dass der C64 zu langsam war, um den gesamten Track am Stück einzulesen und direkt auch zu übertragen, weil dafür hatten die nämlich einen Fehler in ihrem Serial-Shifter da und das ging nicht. Und deswegen konnte man gewisse Copy-Protections nicht einfach so aushebeln, wenn man nicht wusste, wo der Track anfängt, weil dann könnte sein, dass man zweimal die gleiche Stelle liest oder irgendwie so. Deswegen konnten diese ganzen Tools, die dann diesen so wie Speedos oder so, die das doch am Stück schnell genug übertragen konnten, weil sie da irgendwie keine Ahnung, was sie dann da gemacht haben, die konnten das dann erst. Also vorher war das ein Problem.
Die haben auch das Protokoll über die Schnittstelle dann ausgetauscht.
Und dann gab es ja auch diese Parallelenanschlüsse und dann konnten wir ja eh schnell genug einlesen und am Stück und direkt kopieren und Zeug und...
Ich hab das auf dem Atari gemacht, war ja nicht so die C64-Fraktion, sondern die Atari-Fraktion, aber wir waren ja vom Prinzip das ähnliche Grün.
Aber nicht die Atari, diese 520er, sondern nicht die 68k Atari, sondern die davor.
Den hab ich denn später 68.000 spiele, aber so 65.02 Zeit, diesen Atari 800 oder so. Der war auch so schön dokumentiert, das ist das, was mich an dem Ding fasziniert hat. Ich hab eigentlich mit der Hackerei angefangen auf ernsthaften Rechnern, über die ich so rankam, über Kontakte meines Vaters. Und dann hab ich irgendwann mal ein Manual in die Hand gedrückt gekriegt von dem Chefentwickler von Atari, so ein Inder, dessen Namen ich leider vergessen habe, für diesen Atari 800. Und da war ich so fasziniert davon, dass das sozusagen mein erster Computer, mein erster eigener Computer wurde. Aber die hatten auch so einen Floppy-Dreif, der über so eine seriöse Schnittstelle angedockt war an dem Ding. Auch mit 6510 und so, also sehr ähnlich. Und da hab ich mir dann ein eigenes Update EEPROM ausgelesen, was da drin war, oder das ROM ausgelesen, durch ein EEPROM ausgetauscht und da eben meinen eigenen Code dann auch reingemacht. Und dann konntest du halt eben, wenn du das Protokoll ein bisschen modifiziert hast, dann konntest du halt eben den kompletten Trick lesen.
Tim, suchst du deinen Sourcecode?
Nee, ich ähm... Nee, lasst euch von mir nicht...
Hm, ist schwer, wenn du da so machst.
Das war jetzt die Freak Show heute, vorm...
Nee, ich such gerade hier... Ich versuch hier gerade nochmal die Input 64, die entsprechende herauszusuchen. Ah, hier. Discmon 1541 PNG. Guck mal, so sah das aus. Ausgabe 885, genau, das war's.
Ja, wie ich schon sagte, 32 Jahre her.
So lange ist das her?
32 Jahre her?
Ja, vor 32 Jahren.
Was ich cool finde, ist, dass du den Scheiß noch hast. Ich hab den bestimmt auf irgendwelche Bombs oder Floppis im Keller bei meinem Vater zu Hause.
Ja, ja, ich auch. Ich hab tatsächlich auch das Original hier irgendwo. Deswegen hab ich gerade so um mich geguckt. Jetzt kriegst du aber gerade vom Verbrechen nicht...
Ich hab zu Hause einen Zoom-Floppy. Ich kann dir jede C64-Floppy 1A mit Nibbel kopieren, mit allen Bits, auch wenn die nicht dazu gehören. Kann ich dir das auslesen?
Auch ein Atari-Floppy?
Nein, das Image hab ich ja auch, aber das...
Außer, dass es bit-kompatibel ist. Das GFM und MFM und so weiter. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Mal schauen, dass die mal ausgraben, mal ganz tief in den Keller von meinem Vater reinsteigen, wenn er das nicht schon längst weggeschmissen hat. Schade wäre, aber...
Das Nibbel-Copy zieht wirklich unten halt bevor das wieder decoded wird, diese ganz untere Schicht, das zieht das da raus. Da gibt es fast keinen Kopierschutz, der dagegen noch was tun kann. Drei, drei. Zwei davon sind auf Parallel-Pod umgebaut. Also witzigerweise habe ich eine 1541-2, ich habe eine 1570 mit Parallel-Pod umgebaut und eine 1571 mit Parallel-Pod. Die originale 1541 in diesen Kasten habe ich gar nicht, aber ja. Man holt sich später die Sachen, die man früher geil fand. Und damals war halt die 1571 das rechts unten Floppy-Laufwerk.
Das war auch das Budget damals.
Auf jeden Fall. Und vor ein paar Jahren für 20 Euro auf Ebay oder 30, keine Ahnung. Und ja, umgebaut und funktioniert und ist wirklich geil.
Ich kann nur hoffen, dass da mehr Leute mal ihren Dachboden aufräumen und so.
Es gibt ja jedes Jahr hier das Vintage Computing Festival in Berlin. Das ist immer ganz witzig. Da bauen die alle ihr Zeug auf voll hier handaufgebaute Computer, dann alte Macs, alte Ataris, alte Rechner, die man nicht kennt und Zeug und selbst gebaute Computer so komplett. Also das ist wirklich immer interessant, was die da so für altes Zeug irgendwie immer wieder aufbauen.
Bei ITF war auch vorher ein paar Runden, das ist jetzt schon eine Weile her, war in Yokohama. Da haben auch irgendwelche Leute eine alte Sun ausgegraben. Und haben die dann wieder fit gemacht. Also wirklich, die mussten diverse Teile von reparieren und machen und tun. Und da war dann halt noch eben so ein early Sun aus drauf mit der ersten Version von Netscape Navigator. Also erste Netscape Version. Nee, das Ding hieß noch anders. Hieß das nicht Netscape? Der hieß doch anders dieser Browser. Mosaik. Mit dem Mosaik-Browser noch drauf. Und das haben sie da dann noch wieder ans ITF-Netz rangestöpselt und so. Und das ist schon krass zu sehen, wenn du versuchst, mit Mosaik heutige Webseiten aufzurufen. Na doch, man sieht zwischendurch ein paar Buchstaben, aber sonst war das ja so ein bisschen so.
Na ja, da hat sich einiges getan.
Jetzt sind wir wieder online. Gut, dass ich das sofort gemerkt habe.
Ein guter alter C64-Emulator.
Okay, wer die Antwort 17 Rätsel hat und die 10.000.
Also, ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz, ich werde das nachher noch ein bisschen zusammenschneiden, aber für diesen Kurzunterbrechungen, von der irgendwas übrig bleiben wird, kann ich noch kurz erklären, ich habe gerade den C64-Emulator gestartet und er hat sich irgendwie das ganze Audio gegriffen und Gott sei Dank habe ich das gerade in dem Moment auch gemerkt. Jetzt können wir wieder weitermachen. Ab jetzt ist es wieder okay und wir haben jetzt, es waren vielleicht so 10, 15 Sekunden, die da gerade verloren gegangen sind.
Den Chef hat es länger gemerkt.
Maximal eine halbe Minute.
Egal.
Wie auch immer.
Du wolltest jetzt was beitragen.
Ich muss jetzt kurz das Beatjerky in der Hamsterbank packen.
Hab es schon gekriegt unter der Kontrolle. Der Speichelfluss hoffentlich spielt mir keinen Streich.
Ich gebe das mal auf hier mit dem T-64. Wir machen das das nächste Mal.
Böse Falle. Ich hatte gerade in eurer Abwesenheit, liebe Hörer, davon gesprochen, dass ich mir dieses VR-Thema habe ich ja ausgesessen bisher und auch ignoriert und als unnötig empfunden. Und habe aber doch hin und wieder so geile 360° Videos auf YouTube gesehen, wo man halt selber den Blickwinkel aussuchen kann. Ja, ich muss doch mit dem Speichel ein bisschen aushalten. Und eine Freundin von mir, die hatte tatsächlich so eine Ricoh Teta S Kamera, mit der man das machen kann. Und die müsste man jetzt mal auf den Schirm holen. Die Freundin? Nee, die Kamera. Kannst du das schnell machen, Tim? Oder soll ich dir einen Link posten?
Ich bin schon dabei, du darfst es auch machen.
Ich schluck schnell das Beef Jerky runter.
Aber benutze doch deine Scheiß-Räuspertaste.
Ja, die Reuspertaste. Ist ja keine Beef Jerky-Taste.
Leute.
So, auf den Schirm. Das Schöne an dieser Kamera, oder das Witzige ist, man sieht ja das halt auf Anhieb erstmal nicht an. Die sieht sehr harmlos aus. Die hat auf beiden Seiten, sieht halt aus wie ein Telefon, schmales vielleicht, könnte man sagen, hat auf beiden Seiten so ein Fischei-Blobbel dran. Wenn jetzt hier Tim das nochmal auf dem Schirm, genau so sieht das dann aus. Auf jeder Seite gibt es so ein Fischei-Blobbel. Und ihr könntet jetzt mal, zum Beispiel, ich hab gestern im Fahrstuhl von unserem Proberaum, von der Band, hab ich mal ein 360-Grad-Foto gemacht, wo wir witzige Gesichter machen. Oder, naja, witzig in Anführungsstrichen, sag ich mal, ich schick mal einen Link dazu.
Also wir reden hier aber immer noch über Stills. 360-Grad-Stills.
Genau, also die macht Foto und Video. Ich pack mal hier grad einen Link in den Chat, da seht ihr jetzt mal hier die Bandkollegen in 360-Grad. Gibt auch ein schönes WordPress-Plugin, um da die Bilder direkt so mit so einem Viewer zu sehen. Und wenn ihr jetzt da draufklickt in den Show Notes und Tim kannst jetzt auch mal da drin rumdraggen. Du kannst halt hoch und runter und das macht halt wirklich nahtlos vollständig 360-Grad. Und wenn du jetzt ganz runter drehst, dann siehst du halt da, wo die Kamera gehalten wird, ist halt auch nur, naja, sagen wir so ein kleines Versatzstück. Aber der Rest ist wirklich perfekt nahtlos, ne? Und du kannst dir das jetzt halt auch in diesen Gyromode, wenn du es auf dem Telefon anguckst, dann kannst du da so drin rumwackeln und selber sozusagen dich in dieser Szene bewegen. Oder wenn du ein Video hast, ist es halt das Gleiche nur bewegt. Und es gibt halt so Videos, weiß nicht, die laufen eine Straße runter. Und während sie diese Straße runterlaufen, kannst du halt dir aber in eine ganz andere Richtung gucken. Also bist halt voll interaktiv quasi dabei. Und das ist schon eine sehr witzige Erfahrung. Und die Kamera kostet, glaube ich, so 300 Euro. Und du hast es jetzt hier gerade auf Fullscreen gehabt. Die Qualität ist auch vergleichsweise gut. Ja, das spiele ich gerade mit rum und das...
Und natürlich alle Fix-Fotos, bla, also Fix-Fokus. Einfach, das hältst du einfach nur hoch, drückst du auf den Knopf und tschüss.
Genau, und dann synthesizes die Images und du... Ich habe jetzt noch keine Videos gemacht, deswegen kann ich die euch jetzt noch nicht vorführen, aber...
Wartet nicht irgendwie jetzt mal eine blöde andere Frage, White Volcano, wartet nicht irgendwie... Was? Wartet nicht so, dass diese Bänden nicht mehr anders sind?
Ja, nee, wir haben die jetzt doch wieder noch, also die gibt's schon noch, aber auf Sparflamme und nicht so wahnsinnig aktiv. Also zumindest nicht bisher wahnsinnig öffentlich aktiv.
Na, jetzt schon.
Jetzt schon, genau, jetzt mit 360 Grad Fotos, ohne Instrumente im Fahrstuhl. Ja, aber ich finde die Kamera tatsächlich sehr spannend und versuche jetzt mal so die nächsten Zeit so ein bisschen damit rumzuspielen und zu gucken, ob man da irgendwie coole, also vielleicht auch Musikvideos halt machen kann oder halt dann selber dir aussuchen kannst, welche Hackfresse du jetzt dazu sehen willst.
Ist da eine Chance mal Bilder zu machen, wo man nicht selber als Depp unten mit draufkommt, der das Ding in die Luft hält, sondern sagt, wie sagt man, so ein Stativschraube unten und dann wo hin stellen?
Genau, es hat eine Stativschraube und üblicherweise halten die Leute das halt, und das ist jetzt einer der wenigen sinnvollen Anwendungen für so ein Selfie-Stick, weil damit kannst du sozusagen diese 360°-Kamera entweder weit über dir, weit vor dir, also dass du auch ordentlich mit drauf bist, halten und sozusagen damit dann eben auch deine Videosachen machen.
Das gehörte übrigens zu den größeren, muss ich jetzt an dieser Stelle mal wirklich einflächen, zu den richtig großen Annoyances meiner Reise sowohl nach Singapur, da ganz krass, überall voll, alle mit Selfie-Sticks. Geht ja total auf den Sack, weil die den auch immer in die Fresse halten. Wenn sie irgendwo alleine auf weiter Flur stehen, ist mir scheißegal, welche Stöcker die in die Luft oder sich gegenseitig an den Kopf halten. Aber im öffentlichen Bereich in so einer U-Bahn oder sonst immer mit einem Selfie-Stick rumzufotografieren, kann dir als Beistehender doch wirklich sehr auf den Keks gehen. Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, ist überhaupt diese Selfie-Nummer bei den Asiaten. Das waren vornehmlich Asiaten, wo ich das gesehen habe. Die sind total krass. Das Beste war, das haben wir jetzt nach der Reise erst entdeckt. Wir haben ein Foto gemacht, wo so eine ganze Gruppe von Leuten vor einem total hübschen Wasserfall steht und diesen Wasserfall fotografiert. Und rechts im Bild siehst du eine chinesische Mutter mit ihrer Tochter, die auch ihren Selfie-Stick hinhält. Und wenn du reinzooms in das Bild, was wir gemacht haben, siehst du, was die auf dem Display haben. Das heißt, du siehst, was die fotografiert haben. Und das ist sich selber. Das heißt, sie stehen da vor diesem Wasserfall, fotografieren aber nicht den Wasserfall, sondern fotografieren sich, wie sie auf den Wasserfall gucken. Oder so ein anderes Ding, was ich auch gesehen habe, wir waren noch auf so einem Gletscher auf der Südinsel. Und da gibt es so eine Führung, also da kommst du natürlich nur mit dem Führer da hoch, vernünftig. Und die Führerin hat dann so Sachen immer mal so gezeigt, ja und guck mal hier und da, diese Höhle, und die ist so und so entstanden, blabla blub. Und dann hat sie wieder was entdeckt und rief dann, das eine war so ein Mädchen mit in der Gruppe dabei, auch Chinesin, hier Sunny, komm mal und guck dir das mal an, das ist total schick. Und was macht diese Mädchen? Rennt da hin zu diesem Ding, aber guckt sich das nicht an, sondern dreht sich um und lächelt. Sozusagen wartet da drauf, dass sie von ihren Eltern vor diesem Loch abgelichtet wird. So wie so ein Pavloscher Hund, das fand ich echt krass. Das war wirklich, wir alle haben uns in dieser Gruppe angeguckt, so what the fuck. Aber das ist wirklich echt extrem. Normalerweise ist mir das egal, aber wenn sie dir überall rechts und links diese Selfie-Sticks entgegenstrecken, ist das doch ein bisschen nervig.
Im Chat meinte gerade jemand, das wäre das Deppenzepter. Den hab ich noch nicht gehört.
Kurze Anmerkung, ich steck da nicht so richtig tief drin, und das magst du dich auch über die Zeit verändert haben, aber gerade was die Japaner, die ja zuerst mit diesem Klick-Klick-Verhalten überhaupt aufgefallen sind, was zumindest damals, als das alles so richtig so losging, beziehungsweise als man als Europäer vermehrt diese Japaner wahrnahm, weil sie auf einmal da waren, alle mit ihren dicken Kameras und vor allem auch mal mit ihren unglaublich engen Zeitplänen, sich von Touristenattraktion zu Touristenattraktion Düsen liessen und das alles so im Schnelldurchlauf gemacht haben. Das hat halt unter anderem was damit zu tun, dass die eben so unfassbar wenig Urlaub haben, dass die ja eigentlich auch überhaupt selten mal aus ihrem Land rauskommen, geschweige denn aus ihrer Firma rauskommen, dass das normale Leben eigentlich in dieser Firma ist. Und dass dieser Urlaub, der vielleicht der eine Urlaub ist, nach Europa, wo sie dann all die Orte ihrer Träume und ihrer romantischen Verklärung von Europa sind. Rotenburg, Ob der Tauber, Heidelberg, Simon-Dach-Straße in Berlin. Das mag mittlerweile dazugekommen sein, aber vor allem halt diese top romantischen, klassischen Orte, die sie auch mit klassischer Musik und mit allem, was für sie Europa ist, verbinden. Das geht natürlich nicht nur für Europa, sondern auch für andere Orte. Am Anfang war es vor allem aber auch das. Klar, Paris, Eiffelturm, volles Programm. Dann sind sie aber so time constrained, dass sie in diesen sieben Tagen, die sie dann Urlaub haben, für sie ein unwiederbringbarer Moment in ihrem Leben ist, alles abklappern, sich quasi mit Druckbetankung durch dieses Europa durchpushen lassen und dann diese Zeit eigentlich nur dazu nutzen, diese Selbstversicherung und dann aber auch natürlich die Dokumentation für ihre Freunde zu liefern, dass sie da auch wirklich waren. Ja, klar. Und ich glaube, diese Selfie-Kultur ist dann sozusagen das Ganze dann nochmal hoch zwei. Dieses sich selbst versichern, ich war da, ich bin Teil davon, ich bin vielleicht jetzt auf einmal auch, das will ich nicht so sehr überhöhen, aber so, jetzt habe ich mich und meine kleine Existenz mit diesem großen Ding vermählt und auch ich stand da mal und war ein Teil davon. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht so weit psychologisch oder kulturell deuten, aber das muss man da glaube ich vielleicht so ein bisschen mit verstehen.
Meine Fingern dürfen die Leute sich oder andere Sachen fotografieren. Was bei Anjens Dicks eben ärgerlich ist, ist, dass die jetzt, dass die so, wie sagt man so, schön neudeutsch ubiquitös sind, bestimmten Gegenden, dass die teilweise gar nicht mal ohne fotografieren und die halten sich halt bei jeder Gelegenheit unter die Nase. Stehst du in der U-Bahn, dich kitzelt weiter am Ohr und nimm deinen scheiß Selfie-Stick da weg. Das ist so der Punkt, wo es dann langsam auch anfängt, mich zu betreffen.
Aber sie haben dich nicht im Schritt fotografiert oder so?
Das weißt du nicht.
Also mit diesen 360-Grad-Kameras, da geht ja noch viel mehr, dann weißt du ja eh nicht, was alles auf dem Bild ist. Also im Zweifel alles.
Genau, darauf wollt ihr jetzt auch nochmal kurz kommen. Also du hast jetzt diese Ricoh-Kamera beschrieben, das gibt's gerade von nahezu allen Herstellern. Das geht jetzt gerade los und insbesondere ist dieses Doppelfisch-Auge-Ding so the new thing, weil bis vor kurzem war 360-Grad-Video, das bedeutete noch, du hast so ein Rig und dann haust du dir deine zehn GoPros drauf, dann musst du danach diese ganzen synchronisierten Sachen wieder in irgendeiner aufwendigen Software zusammen machen. Das hat natürlich jetzt nicht so die hohe Auflösung, aber das ist natürlich viel, viel, viel praktischer und hat auch genau diesen...
Was hat nicht gleich O noch?
Das ist auch etwas, was glaube ich die Smartphones so schnell nicht nachliefern werden können.
Hier mein iPhone, iPhone 9 hat doppelt...
Ja, aber nicht Fisheye, nicht 180-Grad-Fisheye.
Ja, aber bestimmt nicht so zwei dicke, fette Fisheye-Teile, also das wird schon noch eine andere Nummer sein. Zumal du die Dinge ja auch anders halten musst und so weiter, also da ist schon noch...
Die Fisheye machen ja noch 180-Grad, dass es 360 zusammenkommt, oder wie?
Genau, oder ein bisschen mehr machen.
Ja, 185 oder so was. Und dadurch verschmilzt das dann eben, und wie gut das jetzt im Einzelnen ist, weiß ich nicht, diese chemischen...
Hast du jetzt eine Nikon, oder was?
Das ist die Nikon, das sind diese chemischen 360. Frag mich mal.
Also die Rico ist auf jeden Fall jetzt ja schon ein bisschen länger unterwegs, das war auch, glaube ich, einer so der Ersten, die so consumer-kompatible Preise aufgerufen haben und so.
Der Herr Amman hat gesagt, dass wir 500 Euro unten haben.
Ist ja nicht so teuer, tatsächlich. Also die Rico kostet, glaube ich, 300 und ein bisschen.
Was hieß die? Rico...
Rico Theta S da. Und die kann meines Wissens jetzt nicht 4K auf jeden Fall. Volsfären-Kamera, auch ein schöner Name eigentlich.
270 bis 350 Euro. Genau. Die hat dann so den Griff mit drin. Bei der Nikon hast du halt unten halt klassischen Stativanschluss und so.
Hast du da aber auch. Also ich hab die auch aufs Stativ geschraubt schon.
Ja, aber brauchst du auch. Also du musst es benutzen, wenn du es richtig halten willst, weil die Kamera selber ja nur das Teil ist, aber das hat den Vorteil, dass sie dann wiederum ein bisschen kompakter ist etc. Gut, keine Ahnung, da mag jetzt jeder seine eigenen Vorlieben haben. Welches Unternehmen hier besser ist. Und Nikon und Ricoh sind beileibe nicht die einzigen, also da gibt es noch mehr.
Also auch eine cooler, rechts, rechts musst du einfach mal hoch scrollen.
Ich schieße einfach mal hier nach 360 Grad Kamera.
Samsung.
Ja, Samsung macht das dann immer nur für Smartphone. Das ist natürlich nicht das, was ich will. Aber hier gibt es gleich eine ganze Reihe von mit mehr oder weniger bekannten Namen.
Der ganze Chinakram.
Also deklarierterweise der Neue heißt Scheiß, ja?
Naja, wie gesagt, ich sag mal, was heißt wie gesagt, also der Anwendungsfall ist jetzt, also er setzt nicht klassisch Foto oder klassisch Video. das, dass du dir den Blickwinkel selber aussuchen kannst oder, ne, das ist schon in gewissen Fällen eine interessante Komponente. Zum Beispiel, wie gesagt, ich würde mir jetzt für die Bandwäme im Proberaum jetzt sozusagen ein ganz einfaches Musikvideo machen, also ein Video von wir spielen jetzt mal einen Song zusammen, einfach das Ding in die Mitte stellen und dann kannst du halt da drin so selber gucken, wo du halt hingucken willst. Das find ich schon ganz witzig. Andererseits ist aber das Problem, wenn du das jetzt als Director wirklich dem Blickwinkel, dem Betrachter vorgeben willst, gibt's halt keine Editing-Software, ne, also null. Also nicht, dass ich wüsste, dass es irgendeinen 360° Video-Editor geben würde. Und das wär dann wirklich richtig cool, wenn du sozusagen die Experience, so jemand fährt irgendwie mit dem Fahrrad die Straße runter, hat das Ding auf dem Kopf, so, und du kannst dann irgendwie auf bestimmte Ereignisse sozusagen den User lenken. Aber auch als Entdeckungsreise. Genau, so ein bisschen will ich da jetzt mal ein bisschen kreativerweise mit rumspielen. Glücklicherweise musste ich die mir ja nicht kaufen, sondern konnte sie mir ausleihen, insofern sind da jetzt keine Probleme. Wenn ich hinterher herausfinden sollte, ist das doch gar nicht so geil. Aber von der Kamera, weil die haben eine extra App, wo du dann die Fotos übertragen kannst, das war mein Fall, wo ich versucht hatte, oder wo ich früher Fotos mit iMessage und E-Mail geschickt hätte. Und aus irgendeinem Grund hatte da AirDrop nicht... Ach genau, ich wollte AirDrop mit meinem Mac Pro probieren. Ich hab ja noch nicht dieses Bluetooth-Modul bekommen. Das hab ich jetzt schon bestellt.
Da geht das auch nicht.
Jetzt geht es aber, jetzt kann man hier AirDropen oder was?
Genau, aber ich konnte dann halt den iCloud Drive benutzen, weil das kann ja mein Mac Pro machen.
Mit deinem Laptop hier geht das super, glaubst du nicht.
Ich sag ja, das war mit dem Mac Pro, weil ich das...
Das ging eine... ein US lang ging das, nachdem ich das Bluetooth-Ding eingebaut hab. Aber irgendwie haben sie dann so einen Check eingebaut, dass wenn du zwar das richtige Bluetooth hast, aber dein Rechner doch zu alt ist oder nicht stimmt...
Und wenn du das originale Wi-Fi-Bluetooth-Modul einbaust?
Ist das das originale?
Nee, ist es nicht. Die haben doch da so einen...
Das ist schon eins noch besser, ja, aber das originale...
Odefakt ist Garamanga.
Mein Rechner.
Dein Rechner? Das heißt, jetzt geht hier auch AirDrop so hoch.
Ja, anyway, kann man mal auschecken.
Es kommt jetzt hier so ein...
Es kommt in kürze Meer.
So ein Schaf hier, so ein Neuseeländisches wahrscheinlich, ne? Die Kleinen das mal, aber es geht.
Weißt du, Vince, ich hab dir zuerst echt für einen Gerücht gehalten, dass die da unten so voll schafmäßig drauf sind. Weil der erste Teil einer Reise führte durch die Nordinseln und dann nach Norden von Auckland. Und das erste, was du da siehst, die ersten zwei Teile sind Kühe. Und dann denkst du, du bist doch hier verarscht, die müssen doch hier Schafe haben. Irgendwann kamen dann auch Schafe. Und was die übrigens auch machen, weil die auch so ein bisschen schräg, aber auch irgendwie wieder witzig finden, ist, die züchten dort, also die farmen dort auch Rotwild. Das heißt, du hast da plötzlich, siehst du so, oh, guck mal, ein Reh, oh, viele Rehe, oh, Hirsche, oh, dabei ist ja geil, oh, ist ja ein Zaun drumrum. Und plötzlich so, ah, okay, ist so ein Bauer, der da Rotwild farmt, ja, so, okay. Egal.
Oh, wie?
Ich hab zwischendurch jemand Zweites gesehen, das warst du jetzt hier, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab das nicht an, glaube ich. Wollen wir hier noch den letzten noch kurz abreißen? Denn es ist wieder Segelzeit! Und dieses Mal in einer Special-Spezial-Edition. Denn die gute Frau, mit der ich da schon immer so mitsegele, die Elisa, die hier auch beim CRE schon mal zum Thema wie war das, Internet, irgendwie, die hat doch dann so auch hier so ein Internet-Podcast mit dir gemacht. Internet-Wolke, genau. Die hat doch da so beim AMSIX und so gewirkt auch. Na ja, auf jeden Fall die mit der segel ich ja die letzten Jahre immer und dieses Jahr ist das Jahr, wo sie also den Atlantik überqueren will mit dem Boot, mit dem das ihr Vater schon vor 25 Jahren gemacht hat. Also das Segelboot hat ja eine lange Geschichte, ne? Und jetzt ist es gerade noch in Polen, in der Heimat Werft und wird da gerade sozusagen aufgerüstet, renoviert und mit etwas modernerem Equipment versorgt. Dann wird es runter gesegelt an der Küste Portugals entlang, dann, wenn alles gut läuft, rüber zu Madeira, dann...
Von Polen direkt nach Portugal?
Und runter? Naja.
Da fehlt was, glaube ich.
Du weißt schon, ne? Die ganzen anderen Länder auf dem Weg natürlich auch, aber...
Nord-Ostsee-Kanal oder obenrum?
Nord-Ostsee-Kanal, wie es aussieht. Und dann von Portugal Madeira, kanarische Inseln. Da wird dann im Sommer sehr viel noch rumgeschippert, weil dann diese Überfahrt im November über den Atlantik-Stand findet. Und dann im Frühjahr nächsten Jahres wird halt fleißig nach Karibik gesegelt. Und dann, weiß nicht, ein Jahr später...
Panama-Kanal.
Das kommt dann irgendwann wieder zurück. Es gibt auf der Webseite, poste ich jetzt hier auch natürlich gleich, die URL, da könnt ihr die Route sehen, die da abgefahren wird jetzt dieses Jahr. Es ist ein Terminplan angesetzt, hier, wenn man auf Join Us klickt, da im Menü auf der Webseite, dann seht ihr auch alle Termine und alle Routen. Und ich kann das ja, wie gesagt, nur sehr empfehlen. Ja, also ich mach das jetzt im fünften Jahr und dieses Jahr segel ich vier Wochen statt der üblichen zwei. Und das hat also jetzt keinen, also ich werd nicht dafür bezahlen. Im Gegenteil, das ist halt schon der geilste Urlaub, den man sich so vorstellen kann, wenn man halt einigermaßen... Jetzt will ich es mal richtig wissen, genau. Und das Einzige, was man halt so einigermaßen mitbringen muss, ist so eine gewisse Resistenz gegen Sehkrankheit. Also Leute, die direkt bei der ersten Wellenbewegung im Strahl kotzen, sollten das nicht in Anspruch nehmen. Aber für alle die, die so mit dem Wasser und so eigentlich ganz gut können, kann ich das sehr empfehlen. Und es ist eben nicht so ein normaler Charter-Urlaub, wo man halt sagt so, ja, wir fliegen jetzt nach Kroatien oder so und dann chartern wir oder mieten wir uns auf so ein Boot ein und werden da so zwei Wochen irgendwie von einem Hafen zum nächsten geschippert und dürfen uns dann irgendwas anhören oder angucken. Sondern die Elisa ist halt auch einfach nerd und cool und nett und hippiesque. Also das ist halt ein Boot mit Geschichte. Da hängen auch noch irgendwie die Fotos von ihrem Vater und wo sie als kleines Kind da so am Steuerrad sitzt drinne. Und das ist halt einfach sehr entspannt vom Flow her.
Welche Lacks willst du dir jetzt da machen?
Also ich fahre von Portugal, Madeira, kanarische Inseln. Und da sind halt ein paar Stücke von Portugal zu Madeira, wo man ein paar Tage lang nicht an Land ist und vielleicht auch kein Land sieht und von Madeira zu den kanarischen Inseln dann sogar noch ein paar Tage länger. Also ich will mal so richtig so segeln, segeln. Wobei die Atlantik-Überquerung, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das auch offiziell als Tour mit anbietet oder ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt schon belegt ist. Ich habe überlegt auch die Atlantik-Überquerung mitzumachen, aber das ist halt wirklich so eher ein Achievement Unlocked als wirklich ein toller... Karibik steht...
Dann dauerhaft da bleiben?
Nee, naja, die eine Saison will sie dann in der Karibik segeln, sonst lohnt sich dann auch nicht, wenn du anschlägst und gleich wieder zurückfährst. Und dann am Ende der Saison sozusagen, das heißt 2018 am Ende wieder zurück.
Dann muss ich mir noch mal meine eigene CAE anhören zu dem Thema. Da ging es ja genau um diese Strecke.
Hier mit Dingeskirchen.
Den zu Uwe Magert auch hier war. Der hat ja auch übergesetzt Atlantik und seitdem gondelt er da immer im Karibik rum und da ist er.
Genau, also wie gesagt, wenn du auf der Webseite klickst, da ist die Karte, da siehst du, wo sie lang will und wie sie da zurück will.
Das ist jetzt aber von Madeira zu den Kanaren nicht so weit wie von Portugal nach Madeira.
Das stimmt allerdings ja, richtig.
Aber schon noch ein bisschen Wasser.
Genau, also man hat auf jeden Fall mal ein paar Tage kein Land zum Andocken, aber auf dem Atlantik wären es gleich drei Wochen oder so. Das ist dann weniger spannend vielleicht. Also ich meine, meine Empfehlung wäre halt auch, bucht euch halt einen Trip mit Freunden. Das haben ja irgendwann schon mal irgendwelche Hörer einfach so zu zweit sich auf einer Tour mit eingebucht und wenn man dann die anderen vielleicht nicht so kennt, dann ist das vielleicht nicht so die gleiche fluffige Experience, als wenn man halt gleich so mit fünf, sechs Freunden da aufkreuzt und dann einfach schon gleich sowieso im Team-Modus ist. Das wäre meine Empfehlung. Das habe ich jetzt die letzten, also das erste Mal bin ich auch einfach so alleine mit anderen Leuten und Elisa mitgefahren. Das war glücklicherweise in dem Fall auch okay, aber in den anderen Jahren habe ich halt immer so mir die Freunde so mitgenommen und zusammengesucht und dann war es auf jeden Fall ganz großes Kino.
Wie viele Leute sind da so an Bord?
Na ich sag mal optimal finde ich es ja, wenn so sechs Leute insgesamt auf dem Boot sind, aber es sollen wohl schon zehn mit gesegelt sein, aber dann wird es sehr kuschelig. Also ich würde sagen sieben bis acht, das wäre dann inklusive Skipper, sind dann schon, das reicht dann locker. Also ich würde sagen, insgesamt sechs bis sieben ist perfekt.
Tja, meine Neid ist dir sicher. Ich hab auch schon mal überlegt, ob ich da vielleicht mal dazu stoße, ob ich jetzt gleich so übersehtaugt, ich bin, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, keine Ahnung.
Mal gucken.
Dieser Sommer wird eh noch eine Herausforderung, wie jeder Sommer. Also, wenn man Kinder hat, ist es halt immer eine Herausforderung. Du darfst dann halt eigentlich nur dann verreisen, wenn du dann für etwas anderes auch nicht Zeit hast, aber auch gleich mit allen anderen, damit es auch gleich schön viel teurer ist.
Aber deine Kinder sind jetzt fast groß genug fürs Boot. Also ich hab echt schon kleinere Kinder auf Booten da in den Hefen gesehen. Also gerade, wenn du an den kanarischen Inseln da so angekommen bist und da bist du ja jeden Tag an Land abends quasi. Das heißt, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass du da die Kinder da so tagelang auf den Boot einfährst.
Ich komm mir da erstmal eine Woche raus, wo ich vielleicht außerhalb der Flutwere mich nochmal frei machen kann.
So, das war die Freak Show vom 21.2., gerade noch so.
Wieso machst du jetzt hier so Hitparade oder was?
Ach stimmt, auf deinem komischen Workflow steht 21. Ja, einmal mit Profis, wenn man das Workflow hat. Hättest natürlich auch auf den Galender gucken oder auf die App.
Hättest ja auch mal korrigieren können. Ihr seid ja sowieso immer sehr spät.
Wir sind spät, du bist auch spät.
Aber wir machen jetzt Ende, oder?
Darf ich doch.
Das war die...
Das war die Freak Show!
193!
Seien Sie auch das nächste Mal wieder dabei. Wenn Sie Denis sagen hören... Kein Kommentar. Tschüssi!